foreign
python is one of the most emerging
programming languages according to the
most recent figures python is the most
used coding language for about 80
percent of developers the syntax of this
high level programming language is
simple to understand Python's large
Library System makes it a best choice
for data science machine learning and
artificial intelligence projects now
considering the job opportunities in
Python Tech giants like Google meta
Bosch and many other higher python
developers with hands and salaries with
salary in India starting from rupees 5.1
lakhs per annum and may get as high as
rupees 10 lakhs per annum whereas the
average base salary of python developers
in U.S is dollar 105k and may get as
high as 170k annually so this definitely
makes the point of interest for you to
brush up your knowledge in Python
improve your coding skills and get your
dream job so hello Learners welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel and today
we have come up with some amazing python
projects that will help you improve your
python skills in this video we will be
covering all the basic to advanced level
projects don't worry if you are a newbie
or an advanced level developer this
video will help you in different aspects
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technology videos so if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to now
miss an update from Simply learn let's
go through the agenda for this tutorial
we will start this video with IPL data
analysis using python where we will see
how the basic function works and helps
in data analysis we will also learn how
to download images from website using
python following that we will cover
python projects like automating Excel
with python Instagram profile analysis
Spotify data analysis and will also
create a QR code scanner and a music
player using python once you are done
with the basic topics we will move ahead
and cover intermediate level python
projects like converting text to speech
creating a speech recognition system
sentiment analysis of Amazon customer
reviews
OTP verification system and World
happiness report data analysis using
python moving on to Advanced projects we
have movie recommendation system face
detection with a webcam using opencv
python creating Instagram boards
Parkinson's disease detection using
Python and will also learn how to create
our own virtual assistant using python
it is rightly said that you can Master a
programming language just by programming
in it I hope you guys are ready to learn
something new so without any further
delay let's start with the first topic
for the day
you must be aware that Indian Premier
League commonly known as IPL is one of
the most vast and popular events in
cricket it is held every year for a
period of two months usually between
April and May only last year that is in
2020 it was held a bit late because of
the pandemic
so in this video we will perform a
exploratory data analysis and answer
specific questions
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to the simply loan Channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update also if you want to get the
source code files and the data sets used
in this video then please put your email
address in the comment section of the
video we will send you the files over
email
so in this video we'll be using two data
sets to perform our analysis now let me
show you the CSV files
so this is my IPL data set folder which
is on my desktop and these are the two
files that we are going to use the first
data set has information about matches
played between 2008 and 2020 let me open
this data set
all right you can see here
there are total
let me just go to the top
and I'll show you the number of rows we
have
we have around
817 crores of information
all right you can see this is the match
ID so these are all unique IDs of the
matches held between 2008 and 2020.
then we have the city in which the match
was held we have the date on which the
match was played we have
the player of the match which is
man of the match basically
then we have the venue column that is
the name of the stadium where the match
was conducted
we have a column called neutral menu
whether the venue is neutral or not then
we have the teams team one and team two
we have information about who won the
toss then after winning the toss whether
they decided to field first or bat first
then we have the winner who won the
match we have the results whether it was
one by runs or by wickets then we have
the margin so these big numbers are
basically runs 140 33 all these are runs
if you see here one of the match was a
very close contest where
the winning team won by just six runs
we have information about whether the
match was an Eliminator or a League
match we have a method whether there was
any DL method applied for deciding the
result and we have information about the
two umpires
these are basically field Empires next
coming to the second data set
now in the second data set
let me open it
all right
so this data set has all the information
for each ball bolt since 2008 till 2020
you see you have the match ID then we
have the information about Innings
whether it was a first training or a
second Innings we have which over it was
then we have which ball it was basically
the number of ball in an over
then we have the batsman who face the
delivery then we have the batsman who
was at the non-strike current or the
player who was at the non-strike current
then we have information about who the
bowler was and how many runs were scored
of that ball
whether there were any extra runs and
the total runs that were scored in each
ball
we have whether it was a boundary or a
non-boundary
then we have whether there was a wicket
taken in that delivery
now we have information about player
dismissed let me apply a filter and show
you the
values that we have you can see here
these are the players who have been
dismissed
now similarly let's see for
extra types you have buys leg buys no
balls penalty white deliveries
then we have the batting team and the
bowling team
all right
so we will be using these two data sets
to perform exploratory data analysis and
answer particular questions like the
total number of matches played in each
season the total number of runs scored
in each season will also look at the
number of tosses won by each team the
toss decision for each season then we'll
see whether the team opted to bat or to
field first after winning the toss we'll
also understand how a certain player has
performed so far in IPL
the player who has scored the most
number of runs and who has won the most
number of man of the match Awards all
right so let me take you to my Jupiter
notebook
so this is The jupyter Notebook we'll be
using for our demo I have already
written a few
lines of code you can see it here
all right so let's begin with the first
step which is to import the necessary
libraries decision libraries matplotlib
and c bond
the next step is to load the data set so
here I am loading two of my data sets
which is match underscore data and the
balls data set so to load the data set I
am using pandas library and the read
underscore CSV function and within this
parenthesis I'll pass in my file
location followed by the file name and
the extension of the file
so here I have my data set now let me
copy this location and I'll
paste the location here
will convert all the
backslash to forward slash
and finally
I'll give my
data set file name let me just copy it
and I'll paste it there
okay
followed by the file name extension
which is dot CSV now I will just copy
this
and similarly I'll paste for my second
data set will replace the file name
I'll copy this file name
and I'll paste it here
okay
now let me go ahead and
first run the
first cell
to import all the necessary libraries
you can see we have successfully
imported all the libraries then let's
run the second cell which is to load the
data sets so the first data set which is
IPL matches I'm storing in a variable
called match underscore data this will
be stored in the form of a data frame
and the second data set which is IPL
Ball by ball I am storing in a variable
called ball underscore data let's run it
okay there is some error all right we
need to put these within double quotes
don't forget to
put the location on within double quotes
otherwise it will throw an error now
let's run it again there you go so I
have successfully imported my data sets
now let's print the top five rows from
both the data frames now to print the
top five rows I'll use the head function
first I'll write match underscore data
which is my variable name for the first
keyframe followed by the headphone
function if I run this
you can see I have the type rows from my
matches preset you see here we have the
ID the city date player of the match if
I scroll to the right you can see winner
result result margin Eliminator method
and the two empires similarly let's see
the top five rows from the
ball data set so I'll write ball
underscore data which is my variable
name
followed by the head function
let's run it using shift enter
there you go so we have the top five
rows from the Ball by ball data set as
well
next let's check if there are any null
values in both the data sets now to
check for null values you can use the
Regional function and two
find the total number of null values you
can use the sum function
so I'll write match underscore data Dot
I'll use the original function to see if
there are any null values and
to find the sum I'll use the sum
function
there you go if I scroll down
you see here there are
13 null values or missing values in the
city column then you have
four null values in the player of the
match column
method you have 797 null value similarly
you have some null values for Eliminator
and result margin as well let me just
copy this
now we will check for null values
present in our ball data set
I'll replace this by ball
let's run it
there you go if I scroll down
here you can see for dismissal
underscore kind then you have player
underscore dismissed Fielder extra types
these all have a lot of null values
okay
now you can print the shape of the data
frame and also all the columns present
in it for that
I'll use the shape method
I'll write match underscore data dot
shape
you see here
in our match data set we have 816 rows
of information and 17 columns similarly
if you want you can check for the ball
data set
there you go so the first value
represents the number of rows and then
we have the number of columns
now if you want to print all the columns
present in the data set you can use the
columns attribute
you can see it here in the result we
have all the columns printed that are
present in the match data set
now let's look at the total number of
matches played so far
the cities where the matches have been
played and the team
which have participated
so for this I will be using three print
statement so I'll write print
match
played so far
I'll give a colon
and then with the comma I'll write
my variable name which is match
underscore data
and I'll give shape as 0.
let's print this
you can see matches Fleet so far is 816
write another print statement this is to
check
the cities in which the matches have
been played and I'll only print the
unique cities
so I'll give a
backslash n
I'll write cities
played at
let's give a colon now
and I'll use my variable which is match
underscore data
and within square brackets I'll column
name that is City so that it will
extract only the city values and I'll
give my function as unique since I want
to know only the unique cities in which
the matches have been played
if I run this there you go
so these are the cities in which the
matches have been played from 2008 till
2020. you have Bangalore Chandigarh
Delhi you have Durban Port Elizabeth you
have Centurion this
Dubai
and other cities as well
okay
now we'll print one more
result that is the total number of teams
that have participated so far
so I'll write print
within single quotes I'll give backslash
n so that there's a space
I'll write teams
participated
give a colon
and then I'll give a comma I'll pass in
my variable name which is match
underscore data
then within square brackets
I'll give team one
and again I'll use the unique function
if I run this
in the result you can see these are the
teams that have participated so far you
have RCB this Kings 11 Punjab the leader
devils
last year there was Delhi capitals you
have the rising Pune supergiants and
Super Kings Gucci tuskers Deccan charges
and other teams as well
all right
now we will add a new column to our
table that will have the year value
extracted from the date column of the
matches data frame
now if I go to the top I'll show you
what I want to do
so in this matches data frame you have a
column called Date which has all the
date values in which the matches were
played from this date value I want to
extract only the year
so let me show you how to do it
now to extract the EO value from the
date column
I'll use a function which is
date time index now let me show you how
to use it
I'll write my variable name which is
match underscore data
and
I'll create a new column called season
now this season column will have only
the year values
I'll give PD Dot and I'll use my
function date
time
index
and within this function I'll pass in my
variable which is match underscore data
and within
square brackets I'll give my date column
I'll come out and I'll give my abute
which is here
now
in the next line let me print the head
of the
data frame now
I'll write match underscore data dot
head
if I run this
scroll down a bit and I'll go to the
right
you see the last column we have added a
new column called season which has only
the year values
now we will use this column which is the
season column to perform multiple
operations
okay
now let's look at the total number of
matches that have been played or held
each season from 2008 to 2020.
so I'll give my variable name which is
match
per
season
equal to I'll write match underscore
data
Dot
here I am going to use Group by function
which is present inside
my pandas data frame so I am going to
group all the season values so basically
I am going to group all the year values
so that I can know how many matches have
been played each season
now I am going to count
all the match IDs for each season
so I'll pass in my ID column Dot and
I'll use my count function
then I'll reset my index
using the reset underscore index
function and then
I'll rename my column so I'll write
rename
within brackets I'll give columns equal
to
I'll pass in a dictionary so I want to
convert
the ID column
to matches
all right
let me just see it again if everything
is fine
and I am going to
print my
new variable that I have created which
is matches per season
let's run this
some error has occurred let me check it
says match per season not defined
there's a small typo here I have missed
a s
so I'll run this again
there you go you can see in the result
we have all the seasons starting from
2008 till 2020 and
here we have all the matches that were
played in each season so you can see
here in season 2013 there were the
highest number of matches that were
played which was 76 then in 2012 there
were 74 matches similarly in 2011 we
have 73 and if you see this
result in 2008
less number of matches were played
overall which was 58. oh no it's
actually 2009 where 57 matches were
played
okay
now we will visualize the above result
by creating a bar graph that will show
the number of matches held each year so
I am going to make use of this table and
using this table we'll create a bar
graph
Now to create a bar graph I'll use my c
bond Library which I had imported as SNS
I'll write SNS Dot count plot which is
to count the number of matches
so I'll pass in my data frame which is
match underscore data
and I'll give my variable as
season or the column name as season
next we'll use our matplotlab library
I'll write PLT dot X ticks
which is an attribute to
editor X labels
I'll give the parameters rotation equal
to 45
and I'll give my font size
as let's say 10
similarly
I'll use PLT dot y ticks
and I'll give my font size
as 10
now I'll
edit my X labels I'll write PLT dot X
label
in the X label we'll have the
season values
I'll give my
font size as 10
then let me just copy this
will have our PLT dot y label
and our
y
axis would have the count
font size let it be 10 then we'll give
the title to our bar graph so I'll write
PLT Dot
title and within single course I'll give
a title to my plot which is
total
matches
played
in each season
we'll also give a font size
of let's say 10 again
and I'll use
font weight
as
bold
all right
let me now run this and show you
how our graph looks like
there you go so we have a nice bar graph
on the top you can see the title of the
graph it says total matches played in
each season on the y-axis we have the
label as count on the
x axis we have the label as season and
now let me show you what I meant by X
ticks and Y ticks so I had rotated my X
values by 45 so you can see the year
values have been tilted and printed with
45 degrees and then
I had set my font size to be 10. so this
is
font size 10 and similarly count also we
have font size 10. now let's see if I
want to rotate this by 90 and I print it
you see here the your values are now
rotated in 90 degrees
now what happens if I just remove this
parameter
and we'll only have font size
if I print it you see this has been
printed in horizontal order like we have
it in the count column
I'll just
paste it here again
I'll okay now let's run it
so I have my
your values
okay
we'll move ahead and perform some more
analysis
so in my current cell which you see here
I am merging two columns from the
matches data frame to Ball State of
frame using a left join so here I am
adding the ID column and the season
column present in my match underscore
data frame
with the ball data frame and I'm using a
left join and I'm joining using the
common column which is ID which is
present in both the tables or both the
data frames and then I am dropping my ID
Loom let's go ahead and run this
okay you see here I have added my season
column to my
ball underscore data data frame
now we'll use this data frame now to
perform some analysis
now
now in the current cell which I have
selected let's visualize the total run
scored in each season so what I have
done is I have grouped my season values
and applied a sum function to the total
runs column and then I have reset my
index
and I'm plotting a line graph you see
here I've used sns.line plot which means
I'm plotting a line graph to see the
trend of runs scored each season I have
set my face color as black we have a
title called total runs in each season
given a font size a font weight now
before I run this cell let me change my
face color from black to gray so that my
plot is clearly visible
again
this palette you can choose whatever you
want let me show you how you can
select the seabon palette if I search
for SNS palette
there's a nice
blog or an article from seabon
and here you can see we have all the
pallets here whichever you want you can
choose there is hustle
we have set to paired
there are so many you can use whatever
you like
now let me go back
let's run this cell there you go so here
we have a nice line graph now if you see
this line graph in year 2009 least
number of scores or minimum number of
runs was scored
compared to other Seasons we had the
highest number of runs scored in 2013
which responds to this so more than 22
000 runs were scored in 2013 similarly
we had a drop in 2014 which was around
19 000 or less than 19 000 runs first
code in 2014 and if you see for 2000 and
20 which was last season more than 19
000 runs or
nearly 19 500 runs were scored in 2020.
okay now moving ahead
let's see our next
operation that we want to perform I'll
scroll down
now I want to find the runs code per
match in each season to do this I am
concatenating the match per season data
frame with the second column season data
frame so I am dividing the total runs
scored each season you can see it here
so I have divided the total runs by
the matches played per season now I have
set my index to season and I'm printing
runs per season
the result I am storing it in a variable
which is runs score per match let's just
run this there you go
if I scroll down
you see we have the
Seasons the different seasons from 2008
till 2020 and you have the total matches
that were played in each season you have
the total number of runs that were
scored in each season and then we have
our last column which is run score per
match so here you have
the
total number of runs or the average runs
scored in each match
okay
now we'll look at the number of tosses
won by each team for this I am finding
the count of toss winners and then I'm
creating a horizontal bar graph
so I am using the value underscore
counts function and I'm counting the
toss winners for each of the
teams
and here I have used my face color as
gray and then you can see I have set my
title to number of tosses one each
season my X label is number of tosses
one on the Y label I have the teams
let's just run this
okay if you see here
on the y-axis I have the different teams
and on the x axis I have the number of
tosses one by each team
you see Mumbai Indians so far have won
the highest number of tosses followed by
Kolkata Knight Riders then we have
Chennai Super Kings then we have Royal
Challengers Bangalore and if you see at
the bottom we have Kochi tuskers and
Rising Pune supergiants
all right the next cell of code will
help us analyze the task decision across
different seasons so if you want to find
out whether the teams decided to bat or
Bowl first
I'm using a count plot or a frequency
plot
let me just run this
and show you the results
so
this is how the distribution looks like
of the toss decisions across seasons
the purple color represents
field and the red or the orange color
represents batting which means after
winning the toss the team decided to bat
first and the purple color represents
after winning the toss the team decided
to Bull first
now let me explain you what this graph
tells us
in most of the seasons the team that won
the toss decided to
field first only in certain cases for
example in 2009
the toss winning team decided to bat
first similarly if you see first season
2013
most of the teams preferred to bat first
and do we have anything else
no
if you see the others is even in 2010 if
you see most of the teams prefer to bat
first after winning the toss but the
rest of the seasons be 2008
or B 2011
beat 2016 17 18 19 and even 2020 most of
the teams
prefer to field first after winning the
toss
okay
now
we will look at the match results to
analyze how many matches have been won
in terms of wickets
meaning that the chasing team won the
match
we will see how many matches have been
won by runs meaning that the team
batting second could not chase the
target we will understand how many
matches have been a tie so far
now to
get that result
I'll just write one line of code
I'll give my data frame name which is
match underscore data and I'll use my
result column
and then
I am going to use my value underscore
counts function if I run this
okay there is some error here
this should be value underscore counts
and not count
there you go if you see
most number of matches have been won by
wickets which means the team batting
second won the highest number of matches
and there are less number of matches
that have been won by runs which means
the team
bowling second won the match and then we
had 13 ties so far from 2008 to 2020.
all right now let's address some more
questions for example if you want to
know which stadium is best for winning
by wickets so I'll write match
underscore data
dot I'll use the venue column which is
present in my
match underscore data frame
and then
I am going to use my
condition as result not equal to
runs
and then I'll use the mod function
if I run this you see here Eden Gardens
is the best stadium for winning by
wickets so you have higher chances if
you bat second at Hidden Gardens you
will win the match
now see
you want to know which stadium is best
for winning by runs
to do that I'll just copy my
above
line of code and instead of not equal to
runs I'll write not equal to
wickets
if I run this
it says firoza kotla so firoza kotla is
the best stadium for winning the match
by runs so you have higher chances if
you choose to bat first
all right now we want to know for any
given IPL team which stadium is best
when they win the toss
so to answer that question
I'll use my data frame which is match
underscore data again I'm going to use
my column that is when you
and then
I'll write
match underscore data
Dot
dos underscore winner
let's see
I'll write equal to equal to
my T miles select is let's say Kings
11
Punjab
and then
I am going to
use another square brackets and give
match underscore data Dot winner
equal to equal to
I'll write again
Kings 11 Punjab let me copy this
I'll paste it here
and then I'm going to use the mod
function
if I run this you see here
the result is Punjab Cricket Association
Stadium Mohali which is the home ground
for Kings 11 Punjab so
for any given IPL team if you want to
know which stadium is best when they win
the toss most of the times you will find
it is going to be their home stadium or
the home ground now let's
verify this with another team let's say
I want to know in which stadium Mumbai
Indians have won the maximum number of
matches
so I'll
choose my team as Mumbai Indians this
time and let's see which stadium it
returns if I run this there you go it
says Vancity Stadium which is again the
home ground for Mumbai Indians let's see
for one more
now I want for
Kolkata Knight Riders
I'll
copy this
and I'll paste it here as well
if I run this again it says Eden Gardens
which is the home ground for Kolkata
Knight Riders
okay
the next question I want to answer is
which is the best cheesing team that is
the team that has won the maximum number
of matches batting second
so for that
I'll write match underscore data Dot
I'll use my winner column
and
within square brackets I'll write match
underscore data Dot
result
not equal to
runs and then
I want to
use the mod function if I run this
the result says
Kolkata Knight Riders and Mumbai Indians
are the best cheesing team which means
they have won the maximum number of
matches batting second
now if you want to know the best
defending team that is the team that has
won the maximum number of matches
batting first I'll just copy this line
of code
let me scroll down
I'll paste it here and instead of result
not equal to runs this time I'm going to
use result not equal to wickets
if I run this it returns me the result
Mumbai Indians which means Mumbai
Indians is the best defending team that
is the team that has won the maximum
number of matches batting first
now this one typical question that I
want to answer now is
thus winning the toss Mean winning the
match
to answer that
I'll create a variable called toss equal
to I'll write match underscore data
I use my column
that is toss winner
then I am going to compare it with equal
to equal to
match
underscore
data
and then I'll see
the winner so here I am choosing
who won the toss and whether the same
team was the winner
I'll create a plot here I'll write PLT
Dot
figure
I am going to give a
figure size
I'll write fig size which is my
attribute
present inside the matplotlib function
and I'll give my figure size as 10 comma
5.
I'll
use my count plot function present in
the c bond Library
and I am going to count the dos
and I'll display it using PLT dot show
let's run this
okay we have a nice
bar graph which says winning the toss
doesn't necessarily mean winning the
match you can see we have a lot of false
values here which means after winning
the toss
the team did not win the match but there
are a lot of True Values as well
now I want to answer one more question
which is does choosing batting or
bullying first help in winning matches
so for that I'll create another bar plot
I'll write PLT
figure
I'll give my figure size
equal to
let's say 12 comma 4
then I'll write SNS Dot
count plot
I'll write match underscore data Dot
dos underscore decision Which is my
column
then I'll write match underscore data
Dot
dos
underscore
winner
equal to equal to
match underscore
data Dot winner
then I'll just
plot it or display it using PLT dot show
let's run this
if I scroll down you can visualize the
result
we can see that choosing to field first
for the toss winner helped in winning
the match
then batting first in IPL from 2008 to
2020 so there are higher chances if you
choose to fill first you will win the
match
okay
now
we will use our Ball by ball data set to
see how a player has performed
throughout IPL now
for all these visualizations that we
have created and we have seen so far we
were using the match data set which had
information about the matches played
from 2008 to 2020
from now on we are going to use our Ball
by ball data set so the first thing I
want to
do is we'll analyze a performance of a
player throughout IPL so I am going to
take one of the popular players in IPL
that is Suresh Raina
so I am going to create a variable
called player equal to I'll use my
data frame name that is bold underscore
data
and then
within square brackets I'll write batch
man
equal to equal to
I'll give
SK Rhino because that is the name
present in our data set for Suresh Raina
then
I'll write data frame underscore
rhino
equal to
ball underscore data
within square brackets I'll write player
then let me print the head of the data
frame I'll write DF
underscore Rana dot head
there is an issue here let me debug the
issue
instead of dot this should be an
underscore let's run it
now the key here should be capital and
not small let's run it again there you
go if you see here we have created a
data frame only for the player name that
is Suresh Rainer you can see here skrina
cool
now moving ahead
now in the current cell of code
tells us how Suresh Raina has been
dismissed throughout the IPL in all the
seasons so here I am counting
I'm using the value counts for dismissal
kind
and I am going to use a pie chart
so let me run this
if you see here
okay
we have the dismissal kind and there is
a nice
pie chart
now this pie chart tells us that Suresh
Raina has been caught
for 68.8 percent of the times
and then
he has been bold for 10 percent time he
has got run out 7.5 percent of the times
been caught and bold for five percent he
has been stumped for five percent and he
has been given leg before Wicket for 3.8
percent of the times
all right
now moving ahead
in the next cell of code we are trying
to find the runs scored by Suresh Raina
in once twos threes and in boundaries
that is force and sixes so for that I am
creating a user defined function called
count which will count the runs scored
by Raina I'll just run this so that you
get an idea all right
if you see the results
Rhino has code
the maximum number of runs by
a boundary which is 4
then he has scored the second highest
number of runs by taking singles
then here score the
third highest number of runs by hitting
6s and has scored the least number of
runs by running a triple
okay
now if you want to know the details of
the match that had the biggest win in
terms of run margin let me show you if
you want to analyze the match that had
the biggest win in terms of margin so
you can use
match underscore
data
and then within square brackets I'll
write my variable name again match
underscore
data
again I'll give a square bracket
I'll say result underscore
margin
I'll give a condition equal to equal to
match underscore data
then I'll say result
underscore
margin
I'll use my
function that is maximum
if I run this okay so we have the
details of that match so this match was
played
in 2017 in the city Delhi so I'm
assuming this match was played at firoza
kotla which is the home ground for
delete Daredevils which is currently
known as Delhi capitals
the player of the match was
Simmons who is from West Indies
you see here we have the venue which is
firoza kotla
it was played between Delhi Daredevils
and Mumbai Indians
the toss Was Won by Delhi Daredevils but
they lost the match and the match Was
Won by Mumbai Indians
by runs and the result margin was 146
runs which is a huge number
when it comes to T20 cricket
and you can see the season as 2017.
okay
now
let's find the players who have scored
the maximum number of runs so far in IPL
to do that I'll create a variable called
runs equal to
I'll use my ball underscore
data and I am going to use my group by
function
so here
I am going to group The batsmans
So within single quotes I'll use my
column which is batsman
and then I'm going to use the sum
function over
the column that is batsman runs
I'll write batsman underscore runs and
I'll give a DOT and use my sum function
and I'll reset the index
okay
now in the next line I'll write runs Dot
columns
I am going to create two new variables
which is
batsman
and the second column would be
runs
next
I'm going to give a variable called y
which is runs dot I am going to sort it
I'll write sort underscore values
in terms of run so I'll write by
my new column that is runs
comma I'll give ascending equal to false
which means it will order my result in
descending order
I'm going to find the top 10 batsmen
in IPL who have scored the maximum
number of runs I'll write reset Dot
index
and then I am going to drop
my index
and I'll give
access equal to 1 which means I am going
to
drop it in terms of columns
let's print y
so what I am doing here is first I am
grouping all the batsmans and then I'm
going to find the total runs that they
have scored so I'm using the sum
function then I'm creating two new
variables or columns called batsman and
runs I am sorting
the Run scored by the top 10 batsman in
terms of runs let's run this
okay let me check what is the error
it says column not found
batsman underscore run this should be
batsman underscore runs
let's run it again there you go so we
have Virat Kohli the Suresh Raina David
Warner Rohit Sharma Shikhar Dhawan then
we have Chris Gayle de Villiers dhoni
uttapa and gambhir who are the top 10
batsmans in IPL
that I've scored the highest number of
runs
okay
now we will visualize the top 10 players
who have scored the highest number of
runs so this is the code I have written
already
now you can use whichever palette you
want I have used face color as Gray
let's just run this and visualize the
result
there you go you have a nice bar plot
and on the top it says stopped and runs
chorus in IPL
on the y-axis you have the total number
of runs they have scored on the
x-axis you have the player name so the
first player who has scored the maximum
number of runs is Virat Kohli if you see
the Run CS code is close to 6000 runs
next we have is Suresh Raina the second
graph or the second bar is for Suresh
Raina followed by Warner Sharma we have
MS dhoni uttapa gambhir and other
players
cool
now coming to our final visualization
where we'll see
the players who have won the man of the
match award maximum number of times
for that I am using my
column that is
player of the match
column let's run it
if I scroll down
you see here EB de Villiers from South
Africa Who currently plays for RCB has
won the highest number of man of the
match Awards which is actually more than
25 I believe
next we have Chris Gayle Rohit Sharma
David Warner you have Yusuf patan Suresh
Raina Virat Kohli and Gotham gambhir who
have won the
highest number of man of the match
Awards
okay
so let me go to the top and
just give you a brief on what we did in
this IPL data analysis demo so first we
imported our two data sets match
underscore data and our Ball by ball
data set then we checked using the is
null function to see whether there are
any null values present in any Columns
of the data sets we use this shape
function to display the shape of the
data set we printed the total number of
columns that are present in one of the
data sets
we saw how you could extract
the season or the year value from a date
column
then we printed the total number of
matches played in each season
then we converted that same result into
a nice
bar graph
then
we merged
two columns from one of the data sets to
another data set which was ball data
then we saw the total number of runs in
each season
we also saw the Run scored per match in
different seasons
now we visualize the number of tosses
one by each season
we saw the torch decision across all the
seasons where we found out that most of
the teams preferred to field first
then if I scroll further you saw how to
answer different kinds of questions
then we also
learned how you can
analyze a particular player and their
performance throughout IPL we saw for
Suresh Raina and the dismissal kind
we also
check the pattern in which he has scored
the runs
finally
we found out the top 10 run scorers in
IPL and saw who has won the highest
number of man of the match Awards
so if you want to get the source code
files and the data sets we have used in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comment section we will share the
files over email Indian Premiere League
that is IPL is one of the most popular
and exciting events in world cricket
IPL 2022 will begin on 26th of March so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held IPL auction data set
so in this video all the results and
insights that you will see are totally
based on the data we have collected from
Kegel we will leave a link to the data
set in the description of the video you
can go ahead and download it
for this demo we'll be using Python and
jupyter notebook to answer specific
questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook and
this is the file that we are going to
use so here you can see I have
some of the cells already filled in so
this will save us some time and we can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that I'll be using or the
IPython notebook cool so first let's go
ahead and import all the crucial
libraries that will be needed for our
analysis so here you can see I am
importing the pandas Library the numpy
library these are for data manipulation
and numerical competition then we have c
bond and matplotlib for data
visualization then
I have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the code cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell
so here we'll import
all the libraries okay it's done now the
next step is I am going to create a data
frame in the name of IPL
and here I am importing the data set
using the read underscore CSP function
which is part of the pandas Library so
PD here has been imported as pandas I am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is IPL
underscore 2022 underscore dataset dot
CSV is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have successfully
imported or loaded our data set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so I'll use the head function
for this
IPL dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we'll
see how to drop this column apart from
that we have the name of the players the
base price at which the player was sold
or whether the player was a draft pick
so here Rashid Khan from Afghanistan
hardik pandya then we have subman Gill
these are all draft pick and then we
have the
price at which the players were listed
in the IPL auction then we have the type
of player whether the player is a bowler
an all-rounder A batsman or
a wicket keeper then we have the cost in
rupees this is in crores so basically
this column tells us the price at which
the player was sold in the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars after that we have
2021 Squad basically this means
in last year's IPL where was the player
so here you can see Rashid Khan was
playing
for SRH this one Rises Hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for Gujarat Titans similarly hardik
pandya was playing for Mumbai Indians
for past few seasons including 2021 but
this season is going to play for which
are Titans
so on and so forth now let's see the
total number of players that are present
in the data set and the total columns
that are there for this I am going to
use
the shape attribute so I'll write IPL
dot shape you can see here there are
total 633 players that were part of the
auction and this includes the players
who were draft pick also and there are
total
eight columns in my data frame IPL
next
let's use the info function to check the
columns the data types and the total
non-null objects so I'll say IPL dot
info which is a function so I have to
use brackets
there you go so here you can see it
saves total 633 entries from 0 to 632
data columns we have total eight columns
and then these are the different column
names and here you can see the total
non-null objects present in the
column and here you can see the data
types and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the data set
so if I say IPL dot columns and run it
it will give me all the different column
names that are present in the data frame
now as I said
the First Column which is unnamed colon
0 is actually unnecessary so we are
going to drop it for that
we are going to use the dot drop
function and then I have passed in my
column name followed by the axis on
which axis is it there and then I say
increase equal to True which means it
will
replace
and permanently remove
the unnamed column from the data frame
so let's run it and now we'll again
check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the unnamed column which
was the first column in the data frame
and now we have successfully removed it
so player becomes the first column in
the data frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so I'll say IPL dot I'm
going to use the is null function
followed by this sum function
if I run this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values similarly base price and type
column also don't have any null values
but you can see cost in rupees and
cost in dollars have nearly 396.
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
IPL auction and hence there was no price
associated
and then you can see there were a few
players who were not part of the IPL
Squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the rows that have
cost in dollar as null or Nan so here I
have
used IPL and after that I am passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then I have used the install
function
if I run this
you can notice the cost in
dollars column all these values are any
n or null
and even the same
rules have
any n for cost in rupees as well
cool
now the next task is to
fill these null values or any n values
with zeros so for that I am going to use
the fill any function and here I have
passed in 0 so all the null values in
the data set will be replaced with 0 for
cost in rupees column and
cost in tolerance column
let me just run it
all right
okay
now
we will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means we will
check the rows that have null values for
the 2021 Squad column
so what I'll do is I'll say
IPL
Within
square brackets I'll say IPL and then
I'll pass in my
column name which is 2021 Squad
and then after this I'll say dot
is null
so
this
cell
will give us
the unsold players in the 2021 auction
if I run this
you see here
you mark the 2021 Squad column all these
players were unsold or did not
participate so hence it has any n values
all right
now what we are going to do is we will
replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 square column width
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with 0
here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
I'll say IPL
I'll pass in my column name which is
2021 Squad
equal to
I'll say IPL
2021
Squad
Dot
fill any
which is the function and here I'll pass
in a text or a string saying not
participated
all right
let's run it before that let me just
scroll it down
now I'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again so
I'll just say IPL Dot
is null
and then I'm going to use this sum
function
if I run this
okay this is also a function cool now if
you see we have successfully removed all
the null values and replaced with either
zeros or not participated and hence now
you can see none of the columns in the
IPL data frame have null value so it
shows 0.
great
now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called status
which will hold two values sold and
unsold but before that
we are going to
slice
a data frame so here I am looking for
all the rows where cost in rupees
is greater than
0
and those should be unique and
I am storing the value in a variable
called teams so here you can see we have
the different teams where the cost in
rupees is greater than zero
now
I'm going to create
another
column called status so I have written
IPL within square brackets I am passing
in the column name which is status and
that will be equal to the team
replaced by
sold value
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if I just say IPL
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players so there are duplicate rows in
the data frame but here the names of the
players are same but in reality the
players are different
so it is quite understood that
different players can have the same name
so
to get those names I am using the
duplicated function and I'll say keep
equal to false which means I don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see
we have
two entries so lalit yadav here is an
all-rounder whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 IPL and
last year
he was playing for the Delhi capitals
and this year also
he is sold
to Delhi capitals
next we have
lalit yadav who happens to be a bowler
so this is again different Lalita
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have Amit Mishra
who earlier used to play with the Delhi
capitals but this time he remains unsold
soon and so forth so you can see two
entries for subham shring as well and
Shivam Mishra
all right
now let's answer a very basic question
we are going to find out how many
players
have participated
in the 2022 IPL auction for that we have
already seen
the total number of rows that were
present but again I am going to use the
shape function and within
square brackets I am going to say 0
which means it will give me the total
number of rows
and you can see 633 players were part of
the auction this is as per our data that
we have collected from Kegel
up next we are going to find how many
types of players have participated
so I'm going to say
types equal to
say IPL
I'll use the column name which is type
and I'm going to find the count of each
type of players that are present in the
data frame
I am going to use the values underscore
counts function and then I'll say type
Dot
reset underscore index
if I run it
okay there is an error here let me debug
the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types are not type
so let's run it you can see here we have
the different types of players so all
rounders there are total 242 all
roundups who are part of the auction
then we have 215 Bowlers 112 batsmans
and 64 Wicket keepers
Now using the above table that we just
created
I am going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that I'm going to use the
matplotlib pi function so plt.pi I'm
using
types dot values since I want only the
values from this table
and then
I'm saying labels equal to types dot
index
I have used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space and then this is my
format in which I want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution I am going to use Shadow so
it says Shadow equal to True which is
another parameter or an argument and
then I'm going to start my angle at 60
degrees
and here I have used a title called Rule
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally I am saying PLT Dot Plot
so let me just run it there you go so
here we have a nice pie chart or a pie
plot so you can see the different pies
here we have all around the Wicket
keeper batter and bowler so majorly
there are all rounders in the auction
followed by Bowlers then we have 17.69
percent batters and 10.11 percent
wicketkeepers which is the lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another bar plot
or a bar graph that will tell us how
many players were sold and unsold
so for this I am going to use a count
plot so we'll create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold and
each of the bars will have different
colors one will have orange the other
one will have pink and I'm using labels
so to label the x axis and y axis I have
sold or unsold by label will have number
of players the title of my bar graph
would be sold versus unsold I am given a
font size of 15 and I'm saying
plt.plot now the function that you see
here at the bottom will display the data
labels for each of the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so I have used a figure size of 10 comma
5.
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now
you can also
print
the total sold and unsold values let me
show you how to do it
I'll say IPL
dot we can use the group by function
and I want to group it by status column
and
the value that I want to measure is
the players
count
so I'll say players
rather player and then I'm going to use
the count function if I run this you can
see here
I've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players around solder
396.
cool
now
we are going to see the total number of
players bought by each team again this
is going to be a count plot so basically
a bar plot
so here the condition I'm passing is in
the teams column the value shouldn't be
unsold
so players bot means the value should be
sold so here I'm using this condition
and the rest of the things Remains the
Same
one Improvement I have done here is I am
using X text rotation equal to 70
degrees this basically means the X
labels would be tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot there you go so here you
can see I have the title players bought
by each team on the y-axis we have the
number of players
and on the x axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see it better
and this is the bar plot
so the maximum a team can purchase is 25
players some of the teams have also
purchased 24 22 and 23 players let me
just show you so Gujarat Titans have
totally purchased 22 players
then
Delhi capitals have total 24 players in
the squad
again
Lucknow super Giants have 22 players
if I scroll and see again Bangalore
Royal Challengers or RCB they're all
challenges Bangalore have
22 players in the team
and Rajasthan Royals and Sunrisers
Hyderabad have 24 and 23 players
respectively in the teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns called
retention base price and base price unit
for that
first of all I am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to IPL
base price let me just run it
and then
I am going to replace these values that
are present in the list to crore 40 lakh
20 lakh one crore 30 lakh 1.5 crore with
from auction and I'm saying in place
equal to True let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price
so here
in the base price
column I am going to replace draft pick
value as 0 so let's run that as well and
now
I'm going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
brace spice unit and base price so
basically I am splitting
on this piece that I have let me show
you how it is going to split
so this is let's see our
base price column
what I did was I replaced the draft pick
values to 0 and then the rest of the
values will be split into two columns
called base price unit so basically it
will have the unit of the base price
let's say crores or lakhs and
the base underscore price column will
have the value which is 2 here 40 20 20
so on and so forth let me just scroll
down
and
run that particular cell
Now to create these two columns the base
price unit column and the base
underscore price column I have used the
Lambda function and I'm splitting based
on the space
let's just run it
now I have replaced
retained with zero and let me show you
the final data frame that I have
so here you can see we have replaced
the draft pick values in the base price
column to 0
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that I wanted to
create so one is called retention
so zeros refer to draft pick
any other value will say the player was
picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores lags and the value
base price is 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now
let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so I'll say
IPL let me just scroll down DOT
I'm going to use the
Group by function
then I'll say
team
comma
retention
then I am going to
use the value as
retention because I want to find the
count of
retained players
then I'll say colon minus 1.
let me run it
you can see here
the different team names because I have
grouped by team and then retention so I
have Channel Super Kings
from the auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players coming to Delhi capitals
Delhi capitals in the 2022
IPL auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
I scroll down let me talk about let's
say Punjab Kings they have picked 23
players from the auction and retained
two players from
the team last year
talking about
RCB or oil challenges Bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here I am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold and I'm going to use another
parameter called Hue for the different
colors so here I have used Hue as type
because I want to show the players in
each team based on the different types
again I have given my
title to the bar plot
and then I have the X label the Y label
and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if I scroll down you can see the
different
types of players here is the legend so
blue is for Buller orange or yellow
is for all rounder green is for batter
and red
which also looks like Maroon is for
Wicked keepers
and on the
x-axis you can see the different team
names
all right
now let's answer another
couple of questions so here I have what
is the highest amount spent on a single
player by each team
so to solve this question I'll see
my data frame name that is IPL
then I'm going to say
retention
equal to equal to
this should be from auction because you
want to see the highest amount spent and
not from the retained players
then I'm going to
group
by
I'll see
team
and then
I'll say
cost
in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees that is in crores
and
I'll say
Max
colon
minus 1
Dot
sort underscore
values
I'll say ascending equal to false which
means I want the sorted
result in descending order
okay
let me just
bring this
to the left side and we'll run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it sees
there's a spelling mistake this should
be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
Mumbai Indians have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be ishan kison
then Chennai Super Kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is Deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores Kolkata Knight Riders
bought shreyas Iyer for 12.25 crores and
so on and so forth so these are the
highest amounts spent on a single player
by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at maximum value or maximum
price
now if you follow IPL the maximum
price up at which a player was retained
happens to be ravindra jadija so let's
see at what price was he retained
I'll see
retention
equal to equal to I'll say
retained
then I'll see
sort underscore
values
by equal to
I'll use the same column
cost in
rupees that's in crores
I'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot head
and I want to find the top layer
again there's some error let's see
where is the error
C is ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket I should say
bye
I think this should be
fine now let's run it there you go
so you can see here my result is player
name ravindra jadija who was written for
16 crores by Chennai Super Kings
cool
now the next cell of code will
display or print the top five Bowlers
who have been picked in this year's IPL
based on
their cost in INR
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here Deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shuttle thakur
who was bought by
Delhi capitals earlier he was part of
CSK
for 10.75 crores then we have proceed
the Krishna who has been bought by
Rajasthan Royals this time
last year he was with KKR and he has
been bought for 10 crores similarly
lucky Ferguson has been bought by
Gujarat Titans and he played for KKR
last season he has been bought for 10
crores while his base price was two
crores then we have avish Khan
can see avesh Khan's base price was just
20 lakhs and he has been bought for 10
crores by Lucknow super Giants again and
lastly he was part of the Delhi capitals
now you can replace
this value
suppose let's say you want to find the
top five batsmans pigged or batters
picked with the highest amount you can
just see
batter instead of bowler and if I run
this you can see here
was bought by Kolkata Knight Riders for
12.25 crores lasted it was part of Delhi
capitals
then you have simran hitmeier who's from
West Indies he has been picked by the
Rajasthan Royals for 8.5 crores then we
have Rahul tripathi sikha Dhawan and
devdat particle
now if you wanted to check for
let's see all Rounders
you can replace batter with all rounder
if I run this you can see Lamb
Livingstone has been bought by Punjab
Kings this season for 11.5 crores his
base price was just one crore and last
year he was part of the Rajasthan Royals
then we have a player from Sri Lanka
asaranga then we have harshal Patel
Shahrukh Khan and Rahul devatiya who
have been the top five all-rounders
picked at
highest amount
cool
now finally
we want to
see the players who were part of the IPL
last season but were not picked for this
year's IPL
so for that what I am doing is first I'm
renaming my 2021 Squad column this
column I want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
I am going to find out the unsold
players so here I am saying previous
team not equal to not participated and
then
I'm using another condition the team
should be equal to equal to unsold and
I'm going to find out only the player
and the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the IPL last
season but they haven't been picked this
season and last season they had played
for let's say Suresh Shrine update for
CSK Steve Smith was part of the Delhi
capitals soccer ball Hassan was part of
KKR if I scroll down you have David
Milan who played for Punjab Kings in
2021
or in Morgan
who played for KKR he also captained KKR
but unfortunately he was not picked this
season Chris Lane from Australia also
remained unsold this season
and to Tai we have been cutting Aditya
there are other players as well
you have Kane Richardson
cool so these were the players who are
part of the IPL season 2021 but
unfortunately were not picked and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on IPL data
analysis 2022 so we learned
how to
use the different functions
and attributes that are part of
the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualize the data and answered
some specific questions
hi everyone welcome to this video
tutorial on python data analysis project
for 2022. in this video we'll be
covering two interesting Hands-On
projects using Python Programming you
will learn how to use real world data to
perform data analysis and data
visualization the two projects are based
on coronavirus and Olympics data you
will learn to collect analyze clean
manipulate and visualize data with the
help of python libraries such as numpy
pandas matplotlib and c-bond these two
projects will give you the idea to solve
real world problems using exploratory
data analysis so let's get started with
our first project
today we are going to perform two
Hands-On projects on covet data analysis
using Python and tableau this is going
to be a really interesting and fun
session where I'll be asking you a few
generic quiz questions related to
coronavirus please make sure to answer
them in the comment section of the video
we'll be happy to hear from you kovit or
Corona virus is an ongoing Global
pandemic of coronavirus disease that
emerged in 2019 and was first identified
in Wuhan China
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
commonly known as SARS cove2
on March 11 2020 the who declared
covid-19 a global Health Emergency the
virus has so far infected over 22 crore
people and killed more than 4.5 million
Innocents in India there have been over
3.3 crore confirmed cases and nearly 4
lakh 41 000 deaths have been reported so
far
this data is according to official
figures released by The Union Ministry
of Health and Family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project
what does Corona in coronavirus mean
here are the options is it a beer
B respiratory is it C crown or is it d
sun this is a very general question I'm
sure a lot of you may already know some
of you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comment section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use three
different covid-19 data sets and perform
data analysis using Python and tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and raw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in Tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals
the project will give you an idea about
the impact of coronavirus globally in
terms of confirmed cases that's reported
the number of recoveries as well as
Active cases
we will also see how India has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
covid-19 influence and the vaccination
status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using so for our first
project using python we'll be using the
first two data sets covid-19 India and
covet vaccine statewise let me open the
two data sets
okay
so this is the first data set you can
see here
we have
the date we have the time
then we have the different state names
but scroll down you can see we have
Kerala Tamil Nadu Delhi haryana
Rajasthan this ladakh Punjab
Telangana and other states
then we have something called as
confirmed Indian national so actually
this two data sets confirmed Indian
national and confirmed foreign National
we won't be using so in the demo itself
we'll be dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns
the
cured cases or the recoveries
the number of deaths reported and then
we have the total number of confirmed
cases let me just
sort the B column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have
I'll continue with the current selection
and
sort it you can see here
this is
till
11th of August 2021
so this data was collected from Kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo the data is available for
free we will provide the link to the
data sets in the description of the
video so please go ahead and download
them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
data sets that we'll be using we haven't
pre-processed the data to remove
outliers or any missing values
now before I jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so covet vaccine statewise is my
second data set
let me open it there you go so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python project you can
see we have a column called updated on
then we have the state again you can see
here there are a few discrepancies here
uh
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and
you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered we
have the sessions sites first dose
administered then we have the second
dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different vaccines
administered covaxine and Kobe Shield
you have Sputnik V
and here are the different age groups as
well
and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day
we have information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day
all right before we jump into the
Hands-On part let's have a look at the
second quiz in this project
so here is the second quiz question
which is the first country to start
covet vaccination for toddlers is it a
Japan B Israel C Portugal or is it D
Cuba
this is a very recent development that
took place if you watch Daily News
updates on coronavirus you will be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comment section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin
with our demo
so I am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
Python jupyter notebook I'll just rename
this notebook as
covid
data analysis
project
I click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first I am importing pandas SPD this is
for
data manipulation then we have numpy as
NP numpy is used for numerical
computation then we are importing
matplotlib c bond and plotly these three
libraries will be used for plotting our
data and creating interesting
visualizations finally I am also
importing
my date time
function
all right
so I'll hit shift enter to run the first
cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the covid-19 cases in India for the
different states and union territories
so I'll create a variable called covet
underscore DF DF is for data frame
I'll use my pandas Library
and then
give the read underscore CSV function
since our data sets are CSV files and
inside double quotes I'll pass in the
location where my data sets are present
so I'll just copy this location
I'll paste it here
we'll change
the backslash to forward slash
and after that I'm going to give my
file name followed by the extension of
the file
as a coved 19
India dot CSV
let's go ahead and run it
all right
now
to see the first few
rows of the data frame I am going to use
the head function I'll say head and
within brackets let's say I'll
pass in 10 which means I want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if I run it there you go
here you can see from 0 till 9 so we
have 10 rows of information and these
are the different
column names you have S number
date time state or Union territory then
you have confirmed International
confirmed foreign National cured cases
deaths reported and the confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead let's use the info
function to get some idea about
a data set
if I run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns the total number of entries of
the rows we have 18 110 rows of
information starting from 0 till 18109
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that I'll be using the describe function
okay so if you can see here
the describe function is for
numerical columns only
and you have the measures such as count
the mean standard deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50 percentile and the 75
percentile value
okay
now let's move ahead and import the
second data set
which is related to vaccination
so I'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore DF
I'll write PD Dot
read underscore CSV function which is
present in pandas
Library I'll move to the top and I'll
copy the
file location and we'll change the name
of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of covert underscore 19
underscore India
I'm going to say covid
underscore
vaccine
underscore statewise
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covid underscore vaccine underscore
statewise
all right
let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
I'll be using the head function and
inside the function I'll pass in 7.
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6 there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
covet underscore DF data frame we'll be
dropping a few unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed Indian national and confirmed
foreign National as well as the s number
we don't need these columns so it's
better to learn how to drop the columns
for our analysis
so I'll say
covid underscore DF
Dot
I'll use the drop function
and within square brackets I'll pass in
the
column names the first is s number
we'll give a comma
within double quotes I'll see the next
column is time
my third column that I want to drop is
confirmed
Indian national
give another comma
within double quotes I'll say
confirmed
foreign National
outside the
square brackets I'll give another comma
and pass in my next argument
that is in place equal to I'll say true
I'll give another comma and say
axis equal to 1.
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
the error
says confirmed Indian okay it should be
Indian national and not Indian Nation
I'll just
mention it as National we'll run it
again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go
so we have only the date column state or
Union territory cured deaths and
confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to date time
I'll say covet underscore DF
I'll pass in my column name that is date
I'll say equal to
PD Dot
I'll use the pandas function that is 2
underscore
date time
I'll say covid underscore DF which is my
data frame name
pass in my variable which is date
give a comma
and I'll use my argument that is format
equal to
I'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage m
if another Dash and say percentage d
let's run it
and I'll print
the head of the data frame
cool
now moving ahead
now we will see how to find the total
number of active cases so active case is
nothing but the total number of
confirmed cases minus the sum of cure
cases plus deaths reported
so let's
find the Active cases I'll give a
comment
okay
I'll first write my
data frame name that is covered
underscore DF
within square brackets I'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
I'll say equal to
covet underscore DF
and My First Column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
I'll say
covet underscore DF
then I'll pass in my cured column
Plus
I'll again say
covid
underscore DF
and add my
death column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
it
says data frame object has no attribute
Tails this should be TL
there you go
you can see here we have added a new
column called Active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured and deaths reported column
now we will learn how to create a pivot
table using the pandas Library so in
this table we'll be summing all the
confirmed deaths and cured cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
I'll create a variable called statewise
and say PD Dot
I'll use the pivot underscore table
function
I'll pass in my
data frame that is covet underscore DF
and then
we'll give my
values parameter inside the square
brackets I'll pass in my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cure column
give a comma
and next
argument would be index
which is going to be my state slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
I'll say Union territory
I will
give a comma Now
and pass in my last argument which is
AGG
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be Max
all right
let's run it
okay
now
I'm going to find out the recovery read
so recovery rate is basically
the total number of cured cases divided
by the total number of confirmed cases
into hundred
so I'll say
statewise
and within
square brackets I'll
pass in my variable that I want to
create which is recovery rate
this will be equal to
the
cured cases
multiplied by hundred
by the total number of
confirmed cases
within square brackets I'll give my
column as confirmed
let's run this
okay
I'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths divided by the
total number of confirmed cases into
hundred so I'm just going to
replace the names here I'll say
mortality
all right and then instead of cured I'll
say
my deaths column
into 100 divided by the confirmed cases
let's run it okay
now
we are going to
sort the values
based on the confirmed cases column
and we'll sort it in descending order so
let me show you how to do it I'll say
statewise equal to
I'll use the function short underscore
values
so
we'll pass in my variable statewise Dot
and use the
short underscore
values function I'll say by
I want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and I'll say
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual so for that I'm going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function we'll pass in
our cmap parameter
I'll show you how to do it
say style Dot
background
underscore gradient
and inside this we'll pass in a
parameter called cmap so cmap stands for
color Maps this is present inside the
matplotlib Library so here you can see
there is a nice documentation on
choosing color maps in Matlab
this is provided by matplotlib.org
if I scroll down you can see there are a
number of c maps that you can use
purples Blues you have something called
Reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter cool
all these you can use whichever color
map that you want and here you can see
the different
sheets
or the gradients
okay
so I am going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as I said in the beginning there are
a few discrepancies in the data set so
here you can see
this one called Maharashtra and there is
also Maharashtra Triple Star
this you can ignore even if I scroll
down you have madhya Pradesh followed by
three asterisks you can ignore this
value as well even for Bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union territories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
date and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in
descending order of confirmed cases so
so far
our data sees that Maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
Kerala Karnataka Tamil Nadu Andhra
Pradesh and uttar Pradesh so these are
the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases even if you see the
mortality rate is also high for
Maharashtra
and
if I scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if I scroll further
your Punjab the mortality rate is also
High
all right
so this was our first
visual that we created in the
Kobe data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
Active cases
so we'll start
I'll give a comment top 10
active
cases States
okay
so we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as Group by
so I'll first
in my data frame which is covered
underscore DF
dot followed by the group by function
I am going to group my data based on
state slash
Union territory column
then I'll say
Dot
Max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
Active cases so I have passed in my
Active cases column
and
we're also going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we are going to sort the values so I'll
use my function that is sort underscore
values
I'll say shot by
column that is
Active cases
let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
I'll give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot
and then
reset my index
for that I'll use reset underscore index
function
okay
let's check if everything is fine
I have
missed a square bracket here let me give
another square bracket here
okay
and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay that is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now I'll create another variable called
fij
here we'll pass in
the PLT which is for matplotlib library
and will give the
figure size
using the
fixed size
argument
is equal to and within a tuple and
passing the size let's say 16 comma 9
we'll run it
okay
and
let's give
a title to our plot so here we are going
to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title will pass in the title
let's say top 10 states
with
most
Active cases in India
I'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the
x axis on the y axis
I'll say ax which is for axis
to pass in the axis I am going to use
the bar plot function that is present
inside the c bond Library
I'll say sns.bar plot
I'll say data equal to
my variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
States
this is actually active States
all right
and now
I'm going to use the
ilock function
and take the first 10 states so I'm
using a colon and then giving 10 as my
value iloc is for index location
I'll give a comma and say my
y-axis to be
Active cases
give another comma and say my x axis to
be
state
slash
Union territory
give another comma
we are going to pass in the line
width
to 2
I'll say line width equal to 2 and we'll
give
an edge color
let's say the edge color is
red
okay
so I have my
access defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
activity it's not found
let's go to the stop and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 Active cases let me change it to
cases here
now run it
okay the x-axis also has a mistake this
should be state slash Union territory
now let me run it
there you go we have our
plot created but as you can see here the
labels of the different states and union
territories are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
X labels I'll say plt.x
label
and my
X label would be States
then I'll say PLT Dot
by label
my y label will have the total
Active cases
and finally I'll write PLT dot show
before I run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
India into one cell
so what I'll do is I'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
I'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and will
paste it here
next let's dig the
title and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
the cell
and I'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it
there you go
you see it here
we have a nice bar plot ready on the top
you can see the title top 10 states with
most active cases and you see the edges
are in red color for all the bars
on the x-axis you have the different
state names Maharashtra Karnataka Kerala
we also have Andhra Pradesh Gujarat West
Bengal and chattisgarh so as you can see
Maharashtra has the highest number of
active cases based on our data followed
by Karnataka Caroline Tamil Nadu at
second third and fourth please
respectively and in the ninth place we
have West Bengal the 10th place we have
chhattisgarh
on the y-axis you can see the total
Active cases
which are in Lacks
okay now moving ahead now we'll see the
top 10 states based on the total number
of
deaths reported
so I'll give a comment
top states with
highest
deaths
okay
so I'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
debts
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of Active cases
we'll be using depths
okay
so I'll start with my
data frame that is covered underscore DF
followed by using the group by function
and I want to group my data
based on
the state slash
Union territory column
then I'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets I'll pass in
my column names deaths and date
let's make it consistent I'll be using
single quotes
okay
I'll say dot
I'm gonna
short my
result therefore I'm using the sort
underscore values function I want to
sort it by
death column
I'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means I
want to
order my result in
descending order
then I'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that I'll give my
figure size I'll say PLT dot figure
and within brackets I'll pass in my
argument which is
fixed size
equal to
using a tuple I'll say 18 comma let's
say five
now let's give a title for that I'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
I'll say
top 10 states with
most
deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels I'll just scroll down
okay
so I'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so I'm
using my c bond Library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be top
underscore 10 underscore deaths which is
this variable
I'll give
my index location iloc
I'm going to choose
12 States the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
I'll show you once I plot this result
so in the y axis we'll have
deaths column
in the x axis we'll take
state
slash
Union territory
okay
I'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and will give an edge color to our bars
like we did here
so I'll say Edge color equal to let's
say
black
okay
now
finally we'll give
the X label the Y label
so I'll say PLT dot X label
X label would be States
my y label
will be
total
death cases
then I'll write PLT dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths now what I
specifically wanted you to see was these
discrepancies in the data you can see
here Maharashtra is repeated twice even
in our data that we collected from Kegel
Karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where Karnataka is
spelled as
k-e-r-e-a-n instead of k-e-r-n-a all
right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results I had given my index location
till 12 so we have Maharashtra Karnataka
Tamil Nadu Delhi then uttar Pradesh West
Bengal Kerala Punjab Andhra Pradesh and
chattisgarh
with the states that have the most
number of deaths reported
okay
now we'll create a line plot to see
the growth or the trend of Active cases
for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
Maharashtra Karnataka Kerala Tamil Nadu
and uttar Pradesh I can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay
I'll just give a comment saying
growth
trend
all right
so for that
we'll start with our
figure size as
PLT dot figure
I'll use my parameter fixed size equal
to
12 comma 6.
I'll say
my axis as SNS Dot
this time we are going to create a line
plot
my data would be
my original data frame that is covid
underscore DF
and
within square brackets I'll say covid
underscore DF
and we are going to pass in the
State or the Union
territory column
I'll give
a DOT and use the is in function
so the States should include
Maharashtra
we'll give a comma the next state should
be
Karnataka
next
we have
Kerala
give another comma
my fourth state is Tamil Nadu
give a comma
and my fifth state would be uttar
Pradesh
all right
so I'll give
a comma here and then say x equal to
the date column
y will be
Active cases column
and I'm going to use another parameter
called Hue which is to
give different colors to the different
states the five states that we are
looking for
so hue
will be my
state slash Union territory column
okay
after this
I'll see
ax Dot
set title
my title will be top five
affected States
in India
will give a size let's say
16.
all right okay this should be size equal
to 16 and make sure everything is fine
let me just
move it to the above line
okay
now we'll run it
okay there is some error again
it sees
invalid syntax let's see where we went
wrong
let me bring this to the above line
okay this should be covered underscore
DF
okay
make sure you
keep these small errors in check
let's try and run it again all right
if I scroll down
there you go here you can see we have
the top five affected states in India
you see the different
States here and the colors so
this violet or the purple color is for
Maharashtra you can see how the Active
cases
searched around
April and May
and then you can see even for Karnataka
the Active cases searched very rapidly
around me
and June
then it has decreased luckily
similarly you can see the plots for even
uttar Pradesh
as well as for Tamil Nadu so all the
five states you can see one common Trend
that after March so around April
the cases started to emerge very rapidly
and
later after July they started dipping
okay
now
we are going to use our second data set
which is related to vaccination
all right
so first and foremost let me go ahead
and
print the data frame for you
so that you know
the data that we are going to use so
this is the data we are going to use
for our next set of analysis
even this data has a few errors and you
can see there are a lot of missing
values it makes sense because not all
the days you would have vaccination
for people
and
very crucial error that we are going to
deal with is this state column here you
can see
in the state column we have India in a
few rows so we are going to ignore these
rows
all right
first let's rename are updated on column
to just
vaccine date
so
you can use the
rename function present in the pandash
library to do it so I'll say vaccine
underscore DF Dot
rename
I'll say columns equal to
Within
curly braces
I'll write
updated on
Which is my
original column name
give a colon I want to change this to
vaccine underscore date
I'll give a comma
and say in place equal to true
so it will change
my
column name from updated on to vaccine
underscore date in the
original data frame
let's run it
now
let me go ahead and print
the first
10 rows
in the data set you can see here we have
successfully changed
the column name to vaccine underscore
date the rest of the columns remain the
same
all right
now you can check
the
total number of columns rows
the data types and the memory usage
using the info function
here you can see it
we have total 24 columns
7845 entries
and these are the
columns that are present
and if I scroll further
you see here
says
the memory usage and here on the right
you can see the
data type
cool
now as you saw
the data has a lot of missing values
let's find the sum of all the missing
values for each column
so I'll say vaccine underscore DF dot is
null
and then I'm going to use the sum
function over it
Fair on it
there you go
so almost all the columns have
missing values but columns such as
meal individuals vaccinated female
individuals vaccinated even for columns
like
the age groups there are a lot of
missing values
now in the next step we are going to
drop a few
missing value columns
so I'll say
a new variable called vaccination
I'll give the data frame name vaccine
underscore DF and use the drop function
and inside the drop function we are
going to write
columns equal to
I'll pass in the
column names that I want to drop
I'll say
doses
administered
so this is the column that I want to
delete Sputnik V doses administered
I'll give a comma
the second column is e e f i
the next column is
18 to 44
years
within bracket
has deuces
administered
give a comma
I'll say 45 to 60.
years
doses
administered
to another comma
the final column that we are going to
drop is
60 plus which is this one 60 plus years
deuces
administered
okay
so these are the columns that we want to
drop
and finally I'll give my parameter axis
equal to 1.
okay let me just recheck this
column names first one is Sputnik V
doses administer then we have
EFI
followed by
18 to 44 years dose is administered then
we have 45 to 60 years doses
administered
finally we have 60 plus years I have
added
s here which was missing and there
should be a space as well because
there's a space here in the column now
let's run it all right
so we have successfully dropped
The Columns that we wanted to drop
now I'll see vaccination dot head
you can see here
we have dropped those columns and we are
left with these columns now
okay
now
we are going to create a
plot
that is a pipe plot to see
the vaccination for me land
female individuals so I'll give a
comment
as male versus
female vaccination
to create the Spy plot I am going to use
the plotly library that we had imported
which is this one plotly
okay
so first of all we need to filter out
the
meal individuals
from our data frame
I'll say meal equal to
vaccination
meal
I'll passing in the column
individuals
vaccinated
we need to recheck the variable name
whether it is correct or not
you see here mail
individuals vaccinated
then I'll say dot sum
similarly we'll filter out the female
individuals
I'll say female equal to
vaccination
which is my new data frame
within square brackets I'll pass in the
column name female
individual
foreign
vaccinated
I'll say dot sum
okay
these should be individuals as per the
column name present in the data frame
cool now I'm going to say PX
dot Pi function which is present in the
plotly library
I am going to
Give the names of the
pies
so first one is mail
and the second one is
female
give a comma and say
values equal to
mil comma
female
then I'll give a comma and pass in my
title which is
meal and
female vaccination
okay
this should be names
all right now let's go ahead and run
this cell
so it'll take some time to create the
pie chart here we go
see here I have my title male and female
vaccination
so these are the two
pies or the areas
you have the liberal female and the
value
here you have the label meal and the
value so from our data you can see 53
percent meal
individuals have been vaccinated
compared to 47 percent for female
okay now we are going to drop all those
rows where
our state was mentioned as India in the
original data set
I had shown this to you in the beginning
so we are going to remove
ruse where
state is India
okay
so to do that I'll say
vaccine I'm creating another variable
called vaccine
and
we'll use our original data frame that
we had imported
which is vaccine underscore DF
I'll say
vaccine underscore
DF Dot
state
not equal to
India
now let's
print vaccine
okay you can see here we have our
data frame printed and from this data
frame we are taking only those values or
the rows where state is not equal to
India
cool
now what we are going to do is
we'll rename the last column which is
total individuals vaccinated to
just total
so I'll say vaccine Dot
rename
we'll use the parameter columns equal to
Within
curly braces I'll say
total
individuals
vaccinated
give a colon and we'll change this to
just total
give a comma and say in place equal to
true
and finally I'll print my
head of the new data frame
this should be columns equal to
okay
now you can see here if I scroll to the
right and if I check we have
successfully renamed our column
all right
now moving on to the last two
visualizations that we'll see in this
first project using python that is to
find the states with most number of
vaccinated individuals and the state
with the least number of vaccinated
individuals
okay
just give a comment
most
vaccinated
state
okay
for this I'll first create a variable
called wax underscore
vac which is for maximum vaccination
I'm going to use my
data frame back scene
followed by the group by function
I want to grip it by State column
and
we'll find the total sum
of vaccinated individuals
for each state
I'll convert this to frame
there should be a DOT
two underscore frame
and I'll pass in my column name which is
total
after that I'll say Max underscore BAC
equal to
Max underscore vac Dot
short
underscore values
I'm going to sort it by
my total column
and say ascending equal to false which
means I want to sort it in descending
order
so that we have the
states with the
highest number of individuals vaccinated
I want the top five states
now
let's go ahead and print it
so this will create a nice table for us
there you go
here you can see
we have Maharashtra uttar Pradesh
Rajasthan Gujarat and West Bengal as the
top five states with most number of
vaccinated individuals
now we are going to use this table and
convert it into a
chart
now I had already written my code for
the bar plot I'm just going to paste it
so here I have defined my figure size as
10 comma 5
then I am giving a title as top 5
vaccinated states in India and the size
is 20. after that I have created a
variable called X which is going to
store my bar plot this part plot we have
created using the c bond Library
and
you see here I have my
y-axis defined
then I have the line width and the edge
color as well
I've given my X label as States violable
as vaccination and I'm finally going to
display my plot so let's go ahead and
run it
okay you can see it here
we have converted this table into a bar
plot now
so first we have Maharashtra with the
highest
number of vaccinations
then we have uttar Pradesh Rajasthan
Gujarat and West Bengal
now
I want
the viewers watching this video to
find the states with least number of
vaccinated individuals and convert that
table into a bar plot that will show the
bottom five vaccinated states in India
which means the states which have least
number of individuals vaccinated
so please go ahead and put your codes in
the comment section of the video it will
be very similar to these two cells just
that now we want to know the least five
vaccinated states in India
so please put the code Snippets in the
comment section of this video will be
more than happy to know from you in case
you are not able to do it we'll
definitely keep the answers in the
comments itself
all right so this brings us to the end
of the first project on covet data
analysis using python
so in this project we used two data sets
one was on
the covid-19 India data set for
different states and union territories
and the second data set that we used was
for
analyzing the status of vaccination in
the different states in India
now we'll move on to our second project
okay so before moving on to our Tableau
project let's see the final quiz which
of the following is not a common
coronavirus symptom so this question is
to make you aware of the correct covet
symptoms here are the options is it a
fever B visual loss C loss of taste and
smell or is it t cuff
please put your answers in the comment
section of the video and let us know
what you think
now we'll move on to our second covet
data analysis project for this project
we'll be using the Tableau Software and
a global coronavirus data set
first we look at the data set and the
fields we have
okay so I am in my data set folder
we have already seen the first two data
sets in our python project this time we
are going to use the global covet data
let me open it
all right so here you can see we have
the different country names there are
192 countries in our data set
let me go to the top
so
we have
country or region
we also have the code
for each of the countries
then we have a column called last
updated so here you can see our data is
still
12th of March 2021
and there are two columns which
don't have any information that is
people hospitalized and people tested
then we have a column called
Active cases then we have a column for
confirmed cases in the different
countries we have the number of deaths
and then we have the incident rate
the latitude and the longitude for the
countries then we have the mortality
rate this is in fractions
then we have the number of recovered
cases and finally we have a column
called uid
so we'll be mostly using the country
column
active
confirmed deaths and the recovered cases
column
and we'll be using the Tableau Software
to create interesting visualizations and
we'll convert those visuals and put it
in the form of a dashboard
towards the end of the project
okay so let me close this file or let it
be open
I'll search for Tableau public you can
see here I have Tableau public installed
you can use the
desktop version of Tableau or the public
version of tableau
so for this project we are going to use
the tableau
public edition
so here you can see I have created a few
visuals already
if you want you can clear them out
okay
now
the first thing we need to do is to
connect our CSV data set to Tableau for
that
under connect
we have to a file
I'm going to use text file
and under Chrome download so I'll search
for my folder
covered
Dash India and here I have my Global
covet data file let me open it
this will take some time to load
then you can see
so on the Tableau you can see the view
here
it shows the country or the region
you have the last update
you have columns like active confirm
deaths
mortality rate and recovered
and here you can see the
symbols for the
different columns so this is
a globe which means this field
is a region or a geographic field
ABC means it's a text field then we have
the calendar which is for a date field
abcr text field and this
hash represents numeric fields
all right
so now that we have loaded our data let
me just click on sheet1
so this is the canvas where we are going
to create our different reports all
right
so on the left you can see there are two
panes the data Pane and the analytics
pane
in the data pane you can see the
name of the data set Global covet data
and here you can see the different
columns that we have in the data set so
on the top
the ones marked in
blue are called as dimensions and at the
bottom whatever you see
are marked in green and are called as
measures so dimensions are always
represented with blue icons and measures
are in green icons
so
Tableau has automatically detected the
different data types for each of the
columns
all right
so first of all we are going to create a
simple table
to see the total number of confirmed
cases for each of the
countries
so for that I am going to drag my
country or the region column onto rows
here you have rows I'll just drag it and
drop it here
there you go it has populated all my
country names starting from Afghanistan
till Zimbabwe so it has ordered in
ascending order of alphabets
now to
see the total confirmed cases for each
country I am going to drag my confirmed
column onto text so here under marks
card you have the text option I'll just
drag it and drop it here
there you go
so Tableau how easily has
shown me a table where you can see the
different country names and on the right
you have the total number of cases that
have emerged
from these countries
now this is not the most recent data as
I told you this data was till March 2021
cool
now you can go ahead and
shot the table based on the
total confirmed cases here on the top
you can see here
there are two options to sort in
ascending order or in descending order
let's first sort in ascending order
by sum of confirmed cases within country
and region there you go so here you can
see these are the countries which have
very few cases
and if I scroll down
you have France UK Russia Brazil India
and us with the highest number of
covid-19 cases
if you want you can also
short it in
descending order so that the countries
with the highest number of confirmed
cases appear at the top
you can see it here
and these are the countries that have
very few covet cases
now you can convert this simple table
into different charts and graphs to do
that here on the right top corner you
have an option called show me
now
I can just click on
this horizontal bar graph
so that will automatically convert my
table into a bar graph
again you can go ahead and short the
data
there you go so here you have us India
Brazil Russia UK France Spain and Italy
this is a horizontal bar graph sorted in
descending order of confirmed cases
now suppose you want to display only the
top few countries with the highest
number of confirmed cases for that you
can select These Bars
so I'll select till let's say
Germany
or let's see till Argentina
okay and I'll click on keep only you can
see it here it says 12 items selected
that is the sum of confirmed cases I'll
just click on keep only
there you go
so
this horizontal bar graph has
information only for these
few countries that have the highest
number of confirmed cases now you can go
ahead and
play with the color formatting so here
under colors let me choose
a green color
okay
now you can Mark here since we selected
only the top 12 countries with the
highest number of confirmed cases so
what we did was we just filtered it to
the top 12 countries so Tableau has
automatically added country region in
the
filters card
now if you want you can go ahead and
edit this filter as well
suppose you want to remove Argentina you
can just uncheck this click on apply and
okay you see here Argentina has been
removed I've click on undo so Ctrl Z to
get it back cool now you can convert
this horizontal bar plot into a vertical
bar plot let me show you how to do it
I'll just remove these fields from my
chart now what I'm going to do is I'll
drag country or region onto columns and
I'll have
confirmed
column under rows
there you go here you can see we have a
vertical bar plot now and again you can
use the axis now to short your data this
isn't
descending order similarly you can sort
it in ascending order here you have the
option to sort your data
okay
cool
and Below you can see the
different country names
all right
now you can go ahead and
give
a name to this sheet let's say
top 10.
confirmed
countries
the supply
and click on OK you have the title to
this plot similarly you can change it
here as well top 10
confirmed
countries
okay
now let's move on to our second
visualization where we will create a
global map so this global map will show
the different countries
present
in the map and the cases that they have
so to create the map first I'll drag my
longitude generated
field onto columns and then I'll drag
latitude onto rows
you see here we have the map ready and
now
I'll drag
country region onto detail
so this will give you the different
country names you can see here we have
Canada
the United States
Mexico
here you have India Sri Lanka
there's Australia this is Brazil and
similarly we have Spain France Belgium
there's
Italy here we have also Greece
similarly we have the African countries
like
Central African Republic the Congo
Angola
and on the top you have Russia and this
is Iceland so on and so forth
now
I am going to drag
the Active cases column onto
detail again
now if I hover the cursor you can see
the active numbers for Brazil you can
see for India
you have
countries like China
then here you have Thailand
Algeria
now
I'm going to drag the confirmed cases
column onto label so that you have the
labels here you can see here the
confirmed labels
cool
now if you only want to focus on a few
countries
present in a particular region you can
highlight that region for example
suppose for Europe you want to focus on
this region if you select it it will
highlight only those countries and if
you hover your mouse over these points
it will show you the Active cases and
the total number of confirmed cases
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and change the color of the
circles let's see I'll keep it as
red
okay
so this is how you can create a
map to represent the different active
and confirmed cases
I'll rename the title to
global
cases
I just click on apply and ok
similarly I'll change the sheet name as
well to
Global cases
okay
now from this map you can see the
countries such as USA
Brazil
you have Russia
and India with the highest number of
covid-19 cases even in countries such as
spin the numbers are really high
and a lot of the African countries were
also impacted
and these small countries like Solomon
Islands you have
fizzy islands with few number of cases
even for New Zealand as well
all right
now moving to our next
visual
now we are going to see the top 10
countries where highest deaths have been
reported so far due to the pandemic for
this we'll create a tree map now
so first of all I'll
choose my country column and
put it under columns and then I'll
select the deaths column and put it
under rows
I have the
bar plot ready
next I'll go to show me and here I have
the option to select a tree map
you see here for a tree map you need one
or more dimensions and one or two
measures so I'll just click on the
Stream app
okay here you can see I have my tree map
ready so Tableau has automatically
adjusted my Fields so it has removed my
fields from rows and columns and put it
under size color and
label
next I will drag my
country column and put it under filters
and from here
I am going to choose top
I'll filter by field I am going to
select the top 10
countries based on the total number of
deaths just click on apply and click on
OK
so these are the countries us Brazil
Mexico India United Kingdom Italy Russia
Spain France Germany
which have the highest number of deaths
reported
now you can also
give the label
I'll put the deaths column under label
so that you have the labels here
all right so this was a tree map that we
created to show the
top 10 countries with the highest
number of deaths
I'll just
change the title top 10
deaths
cases
now you can also edit the title in terms
of the font color and everything
that's I'll keep it Tableau bold
and I'll choose this as 14 click on
apply and ok
there you go
similarly let's rename the sheet to
death cases
cool
now moving to the next visualization
where we'll see about the recoveries
so before we move on to create a
visualization for the
top 10 or let's say the bottom 10
countries in terms of recoveries let me
show you how to change the
color of the Stream app
so here
by default Tableau select the automatic
palette
if you want you can change it to
different
palette let's see I'll go with
gold purple diverging
click on apply and I'll click on OK
if this is
not looking
that grid you can select another one
let's see
red green white diverging
cool
now let's
go to our
fourth visualization which is about
top 10
recoveries
I'll click on apply and ok
first I'll drag my country or the region
column under columns
and then I'll take
the recovered column under rows this
time
instead of
sum
we are going to choose
average
okay
and here
I'll select
my bagged
bubble chart
after that I am going to drag my country
or region onto colors
and then I'll also put country under
filters
so I'll go to
the top
menu and I'll filter it by field I want
to show the top 10 countries based on
the average number of recoveries if we
click on apply and ok you can see here
these are the countries that have the
highest number of
average recoveries you have India Brazil
turkey Italy Argentina Germany Colombia
Russia Poland and Mexico
I'll just rename this sheet to
recovery cases
cool
now let's move on to our next visual
okay
so here we are going to create a scatter
plot to analyze the total confirmed
cases versus the total number of deaths
so whenever you have two numeric Fields
it is better to create a scatter plot to
visualize the
cases so for that I am going to
drag my confirmed
cases to columns and then I'll drag my
deaths column onto rows
okay
so by default the shape is a circle
and
to see all the countries I am going to
drag country under color
I'll see at all members
there you go
here
you can see the legend
for the different
countries
and
the top you have
us with the highest number of confirmed
cases and the highest number of deaths
as per our data set then you also have
Brazil here which has the second highest
number of delts
then you have
Mexico followed by India so this data is
not a very recent data this data was
last updated on March
now from this we are going to filter out
the top 10 countries with the highest
number of
confirmed cases
and the debts
so for that I'll drag my country column
onto filters
and I'll go to top
filter by field
I'll say top 10 and I'll click on apply
and ok
so here you can see we have Siberia
Sweden
Belgium Netherlands spin Italy France
Russia UK and
you have Brazil
so these are the countries which have
the
highest number of
Active cases so instead of active let's
select deaths click on apply and okay
okay
now if you see we have us here
Brazil India
then Mexico
UK Russia France Italy Germany and Spain
which have the highest number of deaths
reported so far
now if you want you can change
the size of the circles based on the
highest number of active cases so I can
just drag my active column under size
so you can see here
Spain France UK have the highest number
of active cases
now let's say instead of active I'll
just have my confirmed cases under size
okay
and then
you can also change the shape from
Circle to any other shape let's say
square or this asterisk
okay
let's go with the triangle
cool
I'll rename this sheet to
confirmed versus
deaths click on apply in ok
I'll rename this to
confirmed
versus deaths
all right
now moving on to our
next visualization where we will see
the mortality
for each of the countries
and figure out which countries have the
highest
mortality rate
okay
so
first I'll drag
mortality rate
onto
column
and then I'll have
my country column under rows
so there you go
now let me go ahead and
sort it in
descending order so you can see here you
have Yemen
there is Mexico Syria Sudan Egypt
equator China and other countries which
have the highest mortality rate
and you can also
select the country region under colors
let's go ahead and edit the color
stop automatic let's select summer or
you can go for some other palette let's
say
Tableau classic medium I'll assign this
palette yes I'll apply and okay
all right
finally
will
move ahead to our
last visualization where we'll create a
dual access chart
so the Dual axis chart in Tableau will
have one column and two different
visualizations on the rows so here you
have one column and on the right also
you'll have one column with the roon
access values
so this dual axis chart will be for
recovered cases and the
death cases let me show you how to do it
so I'll drag my country
field onto
columns
and then
I'll choose
recovered column onto
rows
so here I have got my
line chart
and the second
column I'm going to choose is the deaths
column
I'll hold my cursor and I'll place it
when I get this
green color rectangle I'll place it here
there you go
so now we have created two measure names
that's and recovered
and here you have the access values
you can synchronize the access values if
you want
the recovered cases are in millions and
the deaths are in thousands
now let's go ahead and
change the recovered line two
bars
and
we're going to short it
okay
now let's change the color
we'll select let's say
blue
I'll assign the palette click on apply
and okay
and if you want you can also change the
color
for
deaths from Blue to let's say
winter I'll assign the palette click on
apply and ok
you can have whichever color you want
and to make the axis same you can just
right click on this axis and click on
synchronize axis
so here you can see the values
let's keep it in thousands only
cool
I'll rename this sheet to
dual axis
okay now before we move ahead and create
our final dashboard I want to show you
one more
feature in Tableau that is to format the
labels so you can see here
instead of writing 5 lakh thirty
thousand eight hundred and twenty one we
can change this in terms of millions or
thousands and write it as let's say 530k
to do that
what I'll do is I'll go to format and
here we have the option to select
font
and in font I'll go to fields and click
on sum of deaths
and here
in this pane I'll choose
number custom
decimal places will be zero
and
display units I'll select
thousands you can see here the values
have been changed to 531k 193k 158k so
on and so forth
cool
now let's go ahead and create our final
dashboard here is the option to create a
new dashboard so I'll just click on
new dashboard
and we are going to increase the
size here so that it fits our
View
so we have selected the default view and
the size I am going to
choose here is automatic so now we can
drop our sheets one by one
first let's drag the Global cases sheet
here
okay you can see we have our map
now
I'm going to choose the top 10 confirmed
cases
all right
and after that we'll choose the
death cases sheet so Tableau will prompt
you to place the sheet at the right
location
okay
and now I choose my
fifth visual which is confirmed versus
deaths
and if you want you can choose any one
of
these let's say I'll take the Dual
access chart
now you can just
minimize the
sheets and adjust the sizes to
make it look better
okay
so you can see here we have our
dashboard ready now you can still go
ahead and customize the dashboards in
terms of adding different filters to it
we are not going to
show that now you are getting some
messages here to unknown four nulls you
can
remove them as well
and here on the top you have the option
to
click on the presentation mode
there you go so this is our final
dashboard that we have created all right
so this brings us to the end of the
second
coronavirus data analysis project using
tableau
now you can just click on escape to go
back
all right now you can save this
and
this will be published in the
Tableau public
platform under your profile
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on Kobe data analysis
project using Python and Tableau welcome
to this exciting video on Olympics
dataset analysis using python by simply
loan this is going to be a very
interesting and interactive session
where I'll give you a brief about the
history of Olympics and throw some light
into the recently held Tokyo Olympics
but we'll focus more on using Olympics
data set that is available on Kegel and
perform some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in Python to analyze and
extract meaningful information
during the course of our discussion I'll
be asking you a few general questions
related to the Olympics try to answer
them in the comment section of the video
so let's begin
the Olympics is one of the biggest
sporting events on the planet it is held
every four years the first modern
Olympics took place in Athens Greece in
1896. as per National Geographic
the original Olympics took place in 776
BC
so they began as part of an ancient
Greek festival which celebrated Jews the
Greek god of sky and weather
the Rings in the Olympics logo represent
the five continents Europe Africa Asia
the Americas and Oceania
from 1924 to 1992 the winter and the
Summer Olympics took place in the same
year but now the alternate every two
years
before I move on here is an interesting
question for you only two people have
ever won gold medals at both the summer
and the Winter Olympics
who are those two people
please share your answers in the comment
section of the video we would like to
know from you
the Summer Olympics in Tokyo began on
the 23rd of July and recently concluded
on the 8th of August
we got to witness some Thriller matches
that went down to the wire some amazing
victories and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well winning and losing a
pardon parcel of any game
fans across the world were really happy
to see This Global event happened this
year Following last year's postponement
due to the coronavirus pandemic
with our Olympic fever High let's take
this opportunity to work around a
project to perform exploratory data
analysis using python to analyze and
visualize past Olympics data and answer
specific questions in this video we'll
be using specific python libraries such
as numpy pandas matplotlip and c-bond to
make sense of our data and extract
meaningful information
we are going to visualize our results
with different charts and graphs
before I show you the data set that we
are going to use for our analysis I have
another general question for you
which is the first Olympics where all
the participating countries sent female
athletes a repeat which is the first
Olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the ear and the city name where the
Olympics was held in the comments
section of the video
we'll be more than happy to hear from
you
now let me go ahead and show you the
data sets that we'll be using in this
video
so here you can see I have my Olympic
status at folder that has two datasets
these are CSV files one is called the
athlete underscore events and the other
one is called NOC underscore regions so
we'll be using these two data sets these
data sets can be downloaded from Kegel
we will post the data set links in the
description of the video please go ahead
and download them these data sets have
been directly taken from the internet
now I'll show you the data sets
so this is my first data set you can see
on the top athlete underscore events so
I have
around 15 columns you can see the count
here and there are nearly
2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
so this is a huge data set that we are
going to use the other data set we are
going
to use in this demo is called NOC
underscore regions now here one thing to
note is NOC stands for National Olympic
Committee this is a three letter code
that is given by the Olympic Committee
we have the region names so afg is for
Afghanistan you have ALB for Albania elg
for Algeria we have also a column called
nodes you find some
notes about the region for example here
antiqua is actually antiqua and Barbuda
all right
let's move to the first data set that I
showed you this is a primary data set
for our demo
so these data sets have been directly
taken from the internet and were not
validated so the results that you will
see in the demo is purely based on the
data that we have collected
so the file athlete underscore
events.csv contains nearly 2 lakh 71 116
rows of information and there are 15
columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
Olympic event
so here ID is actually a unique number
for each athlete then we have the name
which is basically the athlete's name we
have the sex or the gender which is male
or F for female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of integers
we have the height in
centimeters of the athletes then we have
the weight in kilograms we have the team
name these are the country names you
have China Denmark Netherland there are
around 200 country names
then we have the NOC as I said NOC is a
three letter code that stands for
National Olympic Committee
we have the games this games contains
the year and the season you can see here
1992 summer you also have the Winter
Olympic information
all right
then we have a specific year column
to
tell you in which year this event had
occurred
now the year column is also an integer
column
we have the season so whether it was
summer olympics or Winter Olympics
then we have the city name this is the
host City
then we have the sport name you can see
here we have basketball Judo football
tug of war
speed skating
there are so many
then we have another column called event
which is the complete even name as you
can see the sport name is basketball but
the even name is basketball men's
basketball to be very specific
again for Speed skating you have
different categories like women's
thousand meters 500 meters
all right
now the final column is the middle
column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether
the athlete had won a medal be it gold
silver branch and any means the athlete
did not win any medals so we'll use
these two data sets now let's
get started with the demo we'll be using
jupyter notebook for other analysis so
I'll take you to my Jupiter notebook
right away
I have opened it on Chrome so this is my
jupyter notebook that we are going to
use you can see here Olympics data set
analysis I have already
have a few cells that have been filled
with some piece of code
and you can see there are
some comments written as well we are
going to use this data set
so let's get started
first and foremost we'll import the data
sets so we are going to use numpy pandas
matplotlibbon c-bond let me hit shift
enter to import all the
libraries
all right
now the next thing is to load the data
sets
using pandas read underscore CSV
function
so
I'll create a variable called athletes
I'll say equal to
PD dot I'll use the read underscore CSV
function
and inside this function we'll give the
location
of the files so I'll copy this location
and here I'll paste make sure this is
within
quotations
and these are all
forward slash
give another forward slash and after
that I'll give the
file name that is
athlete
underscore
events
dot CSV
I'll close the quotation
let's run it
okay
similarly we will load the second data
set I'll create another variable called
regions
so it will have my data frame
I'll use the same function PD dot read
underscore CSV
I'll just copy this
file path till here
we paste it
and
I'll give my second file name which is
NOC underscore
regions dot CSV you can verify here
the first one is athlete underscore
events the second word is NOC underscore
regions
okay I'll close the quotation and we'll
run it again
okay there seems to be some error I
think this is Regions
cool
now moving ahead let's see the
first few rows of both the data sets
I'll use the head function for that
I'll say
athletes dot head
so this will print the first five rows
from my data set athletes you can see
here
from 0 to 4 you have five rows of
information the ID name sex or the
gender each height feet
if I go to the right you have games here
season sport event and medal
now let's see the
second data set that we
imported or loaded I'll see regions dot
head
it says regions
is not defined
let me cross check it
okay I have taken it as region let's
make it regions
cool
now let's run it there you go so these
are the first five rows from our second
data set you have NOC region and some
nodes
all right
now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function
let me show you how to do it
so this is going to be a horizontal join
I'll create a variable
called athletes underscore TF
then
I'll use my first variable which is
athletes
I'll say dot merge which is my function
name
I'm going to merge
the Region's data frame
I'll use the how parameter
in how I'll give my value as I want to
do a left join
and my common column in both the
datasets is actually NOC
so I am going to use
the NOC column as my common column to
merge both the data sets now let's go
ahead and
print the
most data frame I'll say athletes
underscore DF dot head let's run it
there you go
so if you see clearly if I move to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and nodes
added to my
First Data set that is
athletes underscore
events
cool
now one thing to note here is
see the column names are not consistent
if you see here the rest of the columns
start with a capital letter but if you
see the last two columns that we just
added now start with the lowercase
letter so we'll use
the rename function to
meet the column names consistent
but before that
let's
see the
shape of the data frame so I'll print
the shape of the data frame to know the
total number of rows and columns I'll
say
athletes if I hit tab
you will see it will give me
The Prompt I'll select athletes
underscore DF
I'll use the
shape attribute
let's run it
and see the result you can see here it
gives me the total number of rows so 2
lakh 71 116 rows and earlier we had 15
columns in the first data set and now
that we have added two more columns so
the total number of columns becomes
17 now
cool
so now it's time to make the
column names consistent
so I'll show you how to do it I'll see
athletes underscore DF
dot I'll use the rename function
and then I'll say
columns
equal to
I'll use curly braces
My First Column that is region I want to
change it to
the region but the r should be Capital
now
or uppercase
give a comma
and then see
my second column this should be
a region actually
my second column that is notes
I want to
change the first letter to uppercase so
I'll say capital n
the rest all remains same
we'll give a comma here and say in place
equal to true
so it will change
the column names and will reflect
in this athletes underscore DF data
frame
let's run it
now to verify you can again use the head
function I'll run this again
let me scroll down and move to the right
you can see the difference there you go
so we have successfully renamed the last
two columns region and notes
all right
now moving ahead
now
I'll show you how you can use the info
method to print information about a data
frame including the index data type the
column data types non-null values and
memory usage
so for that you just need to use the
info function so I'll write
athletes underscore DF
dot info
let's run it there you go so here we
have the
data columns you can see total 17
columns you have 2 lakhs
7116 rows or entries
then you have the
different column names and
you say it says non-null and the data
type of the column
below you can see some information about
the memory usage
all right
next
the describe method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the
percentiles of the numerical values of
the data frame and much more
it analyzes both numeric and object
series and also the data frame column
sets of mixed data types
so let me show you how using
the describe function you can display
some statistical summary
I'll just write describe
and
give parenthesis let's run it
okay if I scroll down
you can see here
by default
the describe function will only give
information about numerical columns so
here you can see we have the total count
the mean of each of these columns you
have the standard deviation the minimum
and maximum value and then we have the
25th percentile the 50th percentile and
the 75th percentile value of the columns
ID age height weight and year
all right
now one thing to notice here is if you
see the year column the minimum year is
1896 so this is when
Olympics started and until recently the
Rio Olympics that was held in 2016. all
right now moving ahead
now let's check if there are any null
values present in The Columns of the
data set
so first I am going to create
a variable called
Nan values
give equal to I'll say
athletes underscore DF and the function
to check is I'll see is any
I'll create another
variable called any in underscore
columns
and here I'll use the any function I'll
say Nan underscore
this
variable which is underscore values
dot I'll see any
and I'll print my nan columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of
Boolean values so if there are any null
or any n or missing values in any of the
columns it will say true otherwise it
will say false
let's display the result
there you go so if you Mark here clearly
so there are
nearly six columns where we have missing
values we have
age height weight middle region and
notes columns that have
missing values so hence it has given us
true the rest of the columns do not have
any any n or missing values hence they
are false
all right
let me scroll down
now
let's see the total number of null
values for the
above
six columns
so I'll say
athletes
underscore DF dot I'll use the function
is null and again I'll use this sum
function
okay this should be is null
if I run it you can see it here
so our age column has 9474
rows where we have null values
then we have some null values for the
height column as well for the weight
column so these are the total number of
rows where we do not have any
information regarding each height weight
or region
notes this middle is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in Olympics
don't win any medals so for them the
value is any now before I move ahead
I have a question for you people so the
question is I want you to print the
column names containing null values or
missing values in the form of a list
so please answer this question and put
it in the comment section of the video
we would be happy to know your approach
so the question I'll repeat it again I
want you people to print the column
names containing null values or missing
values in the form of a list so
basically on the top we saw there were
six columns that had null values I want
you to print these six columns in the
form of a list
all right now moving ahead now let's see
the data for specific countries
let's say you want to see the athletes
who have participated in the Olympic
Games from the beginning for India
for that you can filter your result
using a function called query
so let me show you how to do it I'll see
athletes underscore DF Dot we'll use the
query function
and then
I'll say team
which is my column name
should be equal to equal to
and the value I'll give us India
now let's display the first five
rows of information
or the details for the athletes who are
from India if I run this
okay there is some error here
okay so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within single quote I'll just delete
this single code from here and we'll add
it in the end
now let's run it there you go so here
you can see we have
the top five rows of
the athletes who are from India you can
see here the region is India you can see
the no Seas India the team is India and
let me go to the left you can see the
name of the athlete the sex each so for
each you have some missing values you
have the wheat team here and everything
all right
similarly you can also check for Japan
let me just copy the
above code
I'll paste it here and instead of India
I'll say Japan
I'll run it
there you go
so if you see here
you can see all the details are for the
athletes who are from Japan
all right
now moving ahead now I want to know the
top 10 countries who have participated
since the Inception of Olympics in 1896.
so for that I'll create a variable
called top underscore 10 underscore
countries
and say equal to
I'll use my data frame that is
athletes underscore TF
I'll say dot team
then I'll use the function
value underscore
counts
I'm going to
sort
my count
in ascending order
just Mark the way in which I am writing
the functions
any error in terms of syntax or the flow
will throw you an error
I want to display the top 10 countries
now let's go ahead and
print it I'll say
top underscore 10 underscore countries
all right
let me run it
okay it has given us an error let's
debug it okay so this should be value
counts and not count
let's run it again
another error
okay so this should be short underscore
values and not value
let's run it again there you go
so here you can see the top 10 countries
participating in Olympics since
1896 you have United States then we have
France so these are the number of
participants who have taken part since
1896
so the most number of participants have
come from U.S then we have France Great
Britain Italy Germany Canada Japan
Sweden
we also have Australia and Hungary
I'll scroll down
we are going to convert this table that
we got or the output that we got
in the form of a graph so I'm trying to
create a bar plot to plot the top 10
countries who have participated in
Olympics so here I'm using the
figure function to give the figure size
so these are the dimensions 12 comma 6.
now I'll tell you about this PLT X text
means just wait for a while
I have given a title to my plot saying
overall participation by country
and then
using the c bond library and the bar
plot function I am plotting the X and
the
y-axis so my x-axis has top
I should make this top 10 countries
because above we used top underscore 10
underscore countries similarly for
y-axis I'll make it top underscore 10
underscore countries and then I'm using
a color palette called set 2. let's run
it
there you go so if I scroll down you can
see here we have a nice bar plot this is
a vertical bar plot and here you can see
the bars which represent the different
country names first we have United
States which has the highest
participation since the beginning of the
Olympics then we have France Great
Britain Italy Germany Canada
and we have the rest of the countries
cool
now moving ahead
the next visualization we are going to
see is the age distribution of the
athletes so for this we are going to
create a histogram
I'll be using the matplotlab library
specifically for this visualization
so I'll say PLT dot figure
will give the figure size using the
argument fig size
equal to
and this will be a tuple actually
my size is going to be 12 comma 6.
I'll say
PLT
Dot
title
now you can give
any title that you want I'll see
each
distribution
of the
athletes
then we'll also give the X labels I'll
say PLT Dot
X label
this will have each
then we'll see PLT Dot
y label
and this will have
the label as number of
participants
next I'm going to use the hist function
so I'll say plt.hist
and I'll
pass in my data frame that is
athletes underscore DF
Dot
each
which is my column name
comma
I am going to pass in the
bins
for that I am going to use the NP dot
e-range function so MP is for numpy
and inside this I'll say 10 comma
80 comma 2.
so my bins will start from the value 10
and go until 80 with a size of 2.
comma
I'll give another parameter that is
going to specify the color of the bins I
want my color to be orange
and then
I'll use
The Edge color to separate the bins
LC Edge color this is the
parameter or the argument name and the
color I want is white
let's give a
semicolon here and this should be Edge
color there's a spelling mistake here
now let's run it and we'll see the
output so there you go
so this is a nice histogram that shows
the distribution of the
each of the athletes you can see the
title is distribution of the athletes on
the y-axis you have the number of
participants on the x axis we have the
age values ranging from 10 to 80 with a
size of
2
and if you say this we have most number
of athletes
who have each between
20 to 30 you can see here so early 20s
we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the Olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
Beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we have a few athletes even closer to 60
also and similarly we have a few
athletes who are under 18 years of age
all right
now you can see here the bins we had
taken orange color so are all the
bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color
all right
now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
Olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter Olympic Games
just to give you a heads up the Winter
Olympic Games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice
so here I have my variable name winter
underscore Sports so I'm extracting
for season equal to equal to Winter and
I am going to display only the unique
values now let me run this cell
okay so we can see here these are the
different winter sports that are
held during the winter Olympics
similarly let's see for
Summer Olympics so what I'm going to do
here is I'll just copy this cell of code
and we'll edit the
variables I'll say summer
underscore Sports
athletes underscore DF Remains the Same
here season will change it to
summer
dotsport dot uniquely means the same and
here I'll say summer underscore Sports
this should be small
now let's run it there you go
so here you can see we have
more number of Olympic sports that are
held during the summer olympics compared
to
Winter Olympics
so these are the sports that have played
on snow and ice and these are the sports
that are played
during
summer
moving ahead
now it's time to analyze the total
number of male and female participants
who have taken part in different games
since 1896 till 2016 Rio Olympics
all right
so I'll say
gender
underscore counts which is my variable
name
I'll use my
data frame that is athletes underscore
DF Dot
my variable name that is sex Dot
value underscore
counts
and then we are going to print
gender underscore counts
let's run this
there you go
so since the Inception of Olympics
we have more number of male participants
than female participants
now here in this current cell you can
see we are trying to plot a pie chart
for male and female athletes so I have
given my figure size then I have my
title as gender distribution I am using
the macplotlab library and the Pi
function I am using the variable gender
counts that we used here
then I am giving my labels as gender
underscore counts.index now I am using
this Auto PCT the auto PCT parameter
enables you to display the percent value
using python string formatting so this
is my string formatting that I have used
and I'm
initialized my start angle for the pie
chart as 150 degrees and I am also
giving Shadow to my pie chart so I have
written Shadow equal to True let's run
it all right so you can see here this is
my
pie chart that shows you the
distribution of the male and female
participation
so for me it is 72.5 percent of female
so far it is
27.5 percent as per the data set that we
have
we can change this start angle to let's
say 180 degree
and it will
change the pie chart to this direction
cool
now moving ahead
this time
we are going to find the total number of
medals that the athletes have won
so I'll use my
data frame athletes underscore DF Dot
and then my column that is Middle I'll
say dot value
underscore counts
let's run it there you go so you can see
the gold medals the bronze medals and
the silver medals are very much similar
to each other the numbers are pretty
much the same
all right now it's time to focus on the
total female athletes who have taken
part in each
Olympics
so I'll create a variable called female
underscore
participants
I'll say equal to and then use my data
frame name that is athletes underscore
DF
using square brackets
I'll see
athletes
underscore DF Dot
the gender should be equal to equal to
female
and
I'll use ampersand
I'll say
just copy this
paste it here
LC Dot
season
equal to equal to we'll check for Summer
Olympics
and I want to extract only
the gender column so here it is X comma
my year column which is here
okay
and then
I'll say
female
underscore
participants
equal to
I'll just copy this
paste it here
and then I'll use the group by function
say Group by which is part of the pandas
Library
I'll see here
and then I want to find the count
I'll reset the index
say reset underscore index
is a function
and finally we are going to print
female underscore participants
and let's say the head
all right
so what we are trying to do is I am
trying to filter my data only for the
female athletes for Summer Olympics and
here I am printing
the participation based on each year so
I'm finding out the count
so here we need to add
one more square bracket
all right
now we'll
run it and see the result there you go
so you can see here from 1900 1904
all these years you can see the female
participation
let me change it to tail so that we have
the recent data of the Olympics
you can see it here for the Beijing
Olympics 5816
women athletes participated in 2012
London Olympics we had
5815 Olympics similarly for the 2016 Rio
Olympics we had
more participation than the London
Olympics so 6223
women athletes that participated
all right
now here
this is another way in which you can
filter your data for female athletes so
I'm
using two parameters my gender should be
equal to female and season
is Summer Olympics let me just run it I
have stored it in a variable called
women Olympics
now
here I am trying to find a
count plot or I am trying to create a
count plot using my c-bond SNS Library
I have set my style to dark grid then my
figure size I have given as 20 comma 10
my count plot will have the x-axis
as year
the data is women Olympics and Palette
I'm using as spectral and then I have
given a title women participation
let's run and see the output
there you go if I scroll down you can
see on the top I have the title for my
count plot which says women
participation and on the y-axis I have
the count and at the bottom you can see
the different year values from 1900 till
2000 and
16
and 2016 had the highest number of
female participation
cool
let me scroll down so in this cell of
code we are trying to plot a line graph
let me run it and show you the output
so this line graph shows the trend which
says plot for female athletes over time
so here you can see the line graph so
gradually the women participation has
increased in Olympics since
its Inception there was a slight
decrease here this is around
1950s and again you can see here there's
a decrease with the women participation
in 1980 but since then since 1980 there
has been continuous
increase in the participation of female
athlete numbers
cool now coming to the next section of
our analysis
we are going to filter the data to see
the details of the athletes who have won
gold medals
so I'll create a variable called gold
medals
it's equal to I'll use my
data frame as athletes underscore DF
and
within parenthesis I'll use my data
frame name
which is
athletes
underscore
DF Dot
I'll use the condition middle equal to
equal to
and my value would be gold
next
I am going to say
gold medals dot head
let's run it there you go
so here
we have the
top five rows of the athletes who have
won a gold medal you can see all the
records have middle as gold
now we are going to use this
subset
of the data and perform some more
analysis so here
I want to take only the values that are
different from any n so I'm going to use
is
finite
function and inside that I have set gold
medals each
let me just run it cool
now I want to see
the athletes who have secured a gold
medal beyond the age of 60 years
which is very rare
so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of age
having won a gold medal
so here I'm going to say
gold medals
I'll use my
column as ID
and then
I'll use
my variable gold medals
and then
I'll say each
should be
greater than
60
and then
close my square bracket and say count
okay let me just verify if everything is
fine
yeah
I'll run it and we'll see the result so
there are total
six athletes who have won a gold medal
having aged more than 60 years
cool
now let me check
for which
sport these six gold medals have come
so I'll say
sporting underscore event
this is going to be my variable name
equal to
I'll use the
same variable name gold medals
I'll going to choose
my support column
and then
I'll give my
condition each
greater than 60.
now let's go ahead and we'll print
the variable sporting event if I run
this you can see it here
so
for art competitions
even for archery and suiting and this
one called Rook
we have had gold medals from athletes
who had an age
more than 60 years
now we are going to plot
this result or the table that we
achieved on the top
so I'll say PLT Dot
figure
I'll give my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 5
then
I'll say PLT Dot
we'll use the
tight layout
see tight underscore layout
then I'm going to use the c bond library
and
create a count plot
for my variable
sporting underscore event
then I'll say PLT Dot
title
I'll give the title as
gold medals
for
athletes
over
60 years of age
let's run it
and if I scroll down you can see here we
have a nice count plot I have my title
gold medals for at least over 60 years
and since for archery we had three
players who secured a gold medal having
an each more than
60 years
you can see here archery is three art
competition one Rook is one and shooting
we had
One Medal
all right
now we'll see the total gold medals
from each country
so for that
I'll say
gold
medals
Dot we'll use the
region column
and
followed by that I'll use the
value underscore counts function and
I'll reset the index
with name
equal to I'll provide the
middle column
then we are going to print the
head for the top five
countries let me run it you can see it
here
so
USC
has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have Russia Germany UK
and then we have Italy
cool
now in this cell I am going to create a
plot to
visualize the table that I got above
so I've used my labels my titles I am
using the cat plot function that is
present in the c bond Library I have my
x-axis my y-axis the data which is total
gold medals
let me just verify
okay and we'll run it
if I scroll down
you can see this is a different palette
that I had used which is a rocket
and you can see USA has got the
most number of gold medals then we have
Russia Germany UK Italy and France now
we also have included France here which
was not present in this table the reason
being I have used head as six so it will
give me the top six countries
all right
now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
Olympic event that is present in our
data set I'm talking about the 2016 Rio
Summer Olympics
so first of all I'll create a variable
called Max ear
which will be equal to my data frame
name athletes underscore DF
my column name here and I'll use the max
function
then
let's go ahead and print my Max here
I'll just show you the output you can
see here my Macs here present in the
data set is 2016 the Rio Olympics
next
we will create another variable called
team underscore names
that will be equal to
my
data frame name athletes underscore DF
within square brackets I'll give
parenthesis and then see
athletes underscore TF
Dot
year
should be
equal to equal to
my output that is Max here
which is actually 2016.
and then I'll say
ampersand
I'll just copy this
will paste it here
this time I'll use the
middle column and c equal to equal to
gold
I'll say dot team
then I'll say team underscore names Dot
value
underscore
counts
dot head
and will display the
top
10
countries
let me run this
there you go so in Geo Olympics
United States secured the
most number of gold medals now the
reason this is 137 is we have also
counted the team events for example
basketball
similarly Great Britain had 64 gold
medals in total
Russia 50 we have Brazil 34 Argentina 21
France 20 and Japan 17.
all right
now
using the above result we are going to
create a bar plot I'll just change the
steam underscore list to team underscore
names
similarly here also I'll make the
corrections as team underscore names
cool
now we'll run it and you can see here we
have a nice
horizontal bar plot so we have United
States at the top Great Britain Russia
Germany China Brazil so here I am
displaying the top 20 Nations since I
have used head
as 20
so these are the top 20 Nations who
secured the most number of gold medals
in the Rio Olympics
all right
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal but before that
we need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal now if you
had noticed here are
medals column also had a few
null values so we are not going to
consider those null values here
we are only going to consider for the
athletes who have
bonamedal
so for that I'll create a
variable called not underscore null
underscore
medals
equal to I'll say
athletes underscore DF
then
I'll give my
let's make it DF
I'll give my condition
let me just copy this
I'll paste it here
and then
I'll give my condition height
and use the
not null function
and then I'll say
ampersant
create another parenthesis I'll see
athletes underscore DF
this time we'll consider the weight
column
again I'll use the function as not null
and
I'll close the parenthesis
okay I had missed one s here cool
let me just run it now all right
now we are going to create our final
plot I'll say PLT dot figure
I'll give my
figure size
equal to
I'll say 12 comma 10.
I'll say
access
equal to
SNS Dot
we'll be creating a scatter plot to plot
the
height and weight of the athletes who
have won a medal
I'll say scatter plot
in my x-axis I'll have
height
comma
in my Y axis I'll have
weight
comma
my data should be
not underscore null underscore medals
so this is what we created here not
underscore null underscore metals
comma
I'll use Hue equal to my sex column
cool
finally I'll say PLT dot I'll give a
title to my plot
saying
height
versus
weight
of
Olympic
medalists
cool
now let's see our scatter plot this
might take some time to
keep the result because there are so
many athletes present in a data set who
have won a medal and also we are
filtering
in terms of
Hue which is for male and female there
you go
so if I scroll down you can see here
we have a nice scatter plot on the top
we have the title of the plot saying
height versus wheat of Olympic medalist
you can see
are each as the hue
so blue points are for the male athletes
and orange points are for the female
athletes
and on the y-axis we have the weight in
terms of
kilograms and you have the height in
terms of centimeters
cool
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on Olympics data set
analysis
so we used two data sets to
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we created some visualizations to
analyze and visualize the data
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on Olympics data set
analysis
Indian Premier League that is IPL is one
of the most popular and exciting events
in world cricket
IPL 2022 will begin on 26th of March so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held IPL auction data set
so in this video all the results and
insights that you will see are totally
based on the data we have collected from
Kegel we will leave a link to the data
set in the description of the video you
can go ahead and download it
for this demo we'll be using Python and
jupyter notebook to answer specific
questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook and
this is the file that we are going to
use so here you can see I have
some of the cells already filled in so
this will save us some time and we can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that I'll be using or the
IPython notebook cool so first let's go
ahead and import all the crucial
libraries that will be needed for our
analysis so here you can see I am
importing the pandas Library the numpy
library these are for data manipulation
and numerical computation then we have c
bond and matplotlib for data
visualization then
I have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the code cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell
so here we'll import
all the libraries okay it's done now the
next step is I'm going to create a data
frame in the name of IPL
and here I am importing the data set
using the read underscore csb function
which is part of the pandash library so
PD here has been imported as pandas I am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is IPL
underscore 2022 underscore dataset dot
CSV is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have successfully
imported or loaded our data set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so I'll use the head function
for this
IPL dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we'll
see how to drop this column apart from
that we have the name of the players the
base price at which the player was sold
or whether the player was a draft pick
so here Rashid Khan from Afghanistan
hardik pandya then we have subman Gill
these are all draft pick and then we
have the
price at which the players were listed
in the IPL auction then we have the type
of player whether the player is a bowler
an all-rounder A batsman or
a wicketkeeper then we have the cost in
rupees this is in crores so basically
this column tells us the price at which
the player was sold in the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars after that we have
2021 Squad basically this means
in last year's IPL where was the player
so here you can see Rashid Khan was
playing
for SRH this one Rises Hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for Gujarat Titans similarly hardik
pandya was playing for Mumbai Indians
for past few seasons including 2021 but
this season is going to play for Gujarat
Titans
so on and so forth now let's see the
total number of players that are present
in the data set and the total columns
that are there for this I am going to
use
the shape attribute so I'll write IPL
dot shape you can see here there are
total 633 players that were part of the
auction and this includes the players
who were draft pick also and there are
total
eight columns in my data frame IPL
next
let's use the info function to check the
columns the data types and the total
non-null objects so I'll say IPL dot
info which is a function so I have to
use brackets
there you go so here you can see it says
total 633 entries from 0 to 632
data columns we have total eight columns
and then these are the different column
names and here you can see the total
non-null objects present in the
column and here you can see the data
types and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the data set
so if I say IPL dot columns and run it
it will give me all the different column
names that are present in the data frame
now as I said
the First Column which is unnamed colon
0 is actually unnecessary so we are
going to drop it for that
we are going to use the dot drop
function and then I have passed in my
column name followed by the axis on
which axis is it there and then I say
increase equal to True which means it
will
replace
and permanently remove
the unnamed column from the data frame
so let's run it and now we'll again
check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the unnamed column which
was the first column in the data frame
and now we have successfully removed it
so player becomes the first column in
the data frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so I'll say IPL dot I am
going to use the is null function
followed by this sum function
if I run this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values similarly base price and type
column also don't have any null values
but you can see cost in rupees and
cost in dollars have nearly 396.
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
IPL auction and hence there was no price
associated
and then you can see there were a few
players who were not part of the IPL
Squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the rows that have
cost in dollar as null or Nan so here I
have
used IPL and after that I am passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then I have used the install
function
if I run this
you can notice the cost in
tallest column all these values are n a
n or null
and even the same
rules have
any n for cost in rupees as well
cool
now the next task is to
fill these null values or any n values
with zeros so for that I am going to use
the fill any function and here I have
passed in 0 so all the null values in
the data set will be replaced with 0 for
cost in rupees column and
cost in dollars column
let me just run it
all right
okay
now
we will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means we will
check the rows that have null values for
the 2021 Squad column
so what I'll do is I'll say
IPL
Within
square brackets I'll say IPL and then
I'll pass in my
column name which is 2021 Squad
and then after this I'll say dot
is null
so
this
cell
will give us
the unsold players in the 2021 auction
if I run this
you see here
you mark the 2021 Squad column all these
players were unsold or did not
participate so hence it has any n values
all right
now what we are going to do is we will
replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 score column width
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with 0
here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
I'll say IPL
I'll pass in my column name which is
2021 Squad
equal to
I'll say IPL
2021
Squad
Dot
fill any
which is the function and here I'll pass
in a text or a string saying not
participated
all right let's run it before that let
me just scroll it down
now I'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again so
I'll just say IPL Dot
is null
and then I'm going to use this sum
function
if I run this
okay this is also a function cool now if
you see we have successfully removed all
the null values and replaced with either
zeros or not participated and hence now
you can see none of the columns in the
IPL data frame have null value so it
shows 0.
great
now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called status
which will hold two values sold and
unsold
but before that
we are going to
slice
a data frame so here I am looking for
all the rows where cost in rupees
is greater than
0
and those should be unique and
I am storing the value in a variable
called teams so here you can see we have
the different teams where the cost in
rupees is greater than zero
now
I'm going to create
another
column called status so I have written
IPL within square brackets I am passing
in the column name which is status and
that will be equal to the team
replaced by
sold value
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if I just say IPL
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players so there are duplicate rows in
the data frame but here the names of the
players are same but in reality the
players are different
so it is quite understood that
different players can have the same name
so
to get those names I am using the
duplicated function and I'll say keep
equal to false which means I don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see
lalit yadav we have
two entries so lalit yadav here is an
all-rounder whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 IPL and
last year
he was playing for the Delhi capitals
and this year also
he is sold
to Delhi capitals
next we have
lalit yadav who happens to be a bowler
so this is again different Lalita
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have Amit Mishra
who earlier used to play with the Delhi
capitals but this time he remains unsold
soon on so forth so you can see two
entries for subham shring as well and
Shivam Mishra
all right
now let's answer a very basic question
we are going to find out how many
players
have participated
in the 2022 IPL auction for that we have
already seen
the total number of rows that were
present but again I'm going to use the
shape function and within
square brackets I am going to say 0
which means it will give me the total
number of rows
and you can see 633 players were part of
the auction this is as per our data that
we have collected from Kegel
up next we are going to find how many
types of players have participated
so I'm going to say
types equal to
say IPL
I'll use the column name which is type
and I'm going to find the count of each
type of players that are present in the
data frame
I'm going to use the values underscore
counts function and then I'll say type
Dot
reset underscore index
if I run it
okay there is an error here let me debug
the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types are not type
so let's run it you can see here we have
the different types of players so all
rounders there are total 242 all
rounders who are part of the auction
then we have 215 Bowlers 112 batsmans
and 64 wicketkeepers
Now using the above table that we just
created
I am going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that I'm going to use the
matplotlab pi function so PLT dot Pi I'm
using
types dot values since I want only the
values from this table
and then
I'm saying labels equal to types dot
index
I have used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space and then this is my
format in which I want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution I am going to use Shadow so
it says Shadow equal to True which is
another parameter or an argument and
then I'm going to start my angle at 60
degrees
and here I have used a title called Rule
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally I am saying PLT Dot Plot so let
me just run it there you go so here we
have a nice pie chart or a pi plot so
you can see the different pies here we
have all around the Wicket keeper batter
and bowler so majorly
there are all rounders in the auction
followed by Bowlers then we have 17.69
percent battles and 10.11 percent Wicket
Keepers which is the lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another bar plot
or a bar graph that will tell us how
many players were sold and unsold
so for this I am going to use a count
plot so we'll create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold and
each of the bars will have different
colors one will have orange the other
one will have pink and I'm using labels
so to label the x axis and y axis I have
sold or unsold by label will have number
of players the title of my bar graph
would be sold versus unsold I have given
a font size of 15 and I'm saying
plt.plot now the function that you see
here at the bottom will display the data
labels for each of the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so I have used a figure size of 10 comma
5.
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now
you can also
print
the total sold and unsold values let me
show you how to do it
I'll say IPL
dot we can use the group by function
and I want to group it by status column
and
the value that I want to measure is
the players
count
so I'll say players
rather player and then I'm going to use
the count function if I run this you can
see here
I've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players around solder
396.
cool
now
we are going to see the total number of
players bought by each team again this
is going to be a count plot so basically
a bar plot
so here the condition I'm passing is in
the teams column the value shouldn't be
unsold
so players bot means the value should be
sold so here I'm using this condition
and the rest of the things Remains the
Same
one Improvement I have done here is I am
using X sticks rotation equal to 70
degrees this basically means the X
labels would be tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot there you go so here you
can see I have the title players bought
by each team on the y-axis we have the
number of players
and on the x axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see it better
and this is the bar plot
so the maximum a team can purchase is 25
players some of the teams have also
purchased 24 22 and 23 players let me
just show you so Gujarat Titans have
totally purchased 22 players
then Delhi capitals have total 24
players in the squad
again
Lucknow super Giants have 22 players
if I scroll and see again Bangalore
Royal Challengers or RCB the Royal
challenges Bangalore have
22 players in the team
and Rajasthan Royals and Sunrisers
Hyderabad have 24 and 23 players
respectively in the teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns called
retention base price and base price unit
for that
first of all I am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to IPL
base price let me just run it
and then
I'm going to replace these values that
are present in the list to crore 40 lakh
20 lakh one crore 30 lakh 1.5 crore with
from auction and I'm saying in place
equal to True let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price so here
in the base price
column I'm going to replace draft pick
value as 0 so let's run that as well and
now
I'm going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
brace spice unit and base price so
basically I am splitting
on this piece that I have let me show
you how it is going to split
so this is let's see our
base price column
what I did was I replaced the draft pick
values to 0 and then the rest of the
values will be split into two columns
called base price unit so basically it
will have the unit of the base price
let's say crores or lakhs and
the base underscore price column will
have the value which is 2 here 40 20 20
so on and so forth let me just scroll
down
and run that particular cell
Now to create these two columns the base
price unit column and the base
underscore price column I have used the
Lambda function and I'm splitting based
on the space
let's just run it
now I have replaced
retained with zero and let me show you
the
final data frame that I have
so here you can see we have replaced the
draft pick values in the base price
column to 0
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that I wanted to
create so one is called retention
so zeros refer to draft pick
any other value will say
the player was picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores lags and the value
base price is 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so I'll say
IPL let me just scroll down DOT
I'm going to use the
Group by function
then I'll say
team
comma
retention
then I am going to
use the value as
retention because I want to find the
count of
retained players
then I'll say colon
-1
let me run it
you can see here
the different team names because I have
grouped by team and then retention so I
have Chinese Super Kings
from the auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players coming to Delhi capitals
Delhi capitals in the 2022
IPL auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
I scroll down let me talk about let's
say Punjab Kings they have picked 23
players from the auction and retained
two players from
the team last year
talking about
RCB or oil challenges Bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here I am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold and I'm going to use another
parameter called Hue for the different
colors so here I have used Hue as type
because I want to show the players in
each team based on the different types
again I have given my
title to the bar plot
and then I have the X label the Y label
and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if I scroll down you can see the
different
types of players here is the legend so
blue is for blue
orange or yellow
is for all rounder green is for batter
and red
which also looks like Maroon is for
Wicked keepers
and on the
x-axis you can see the different team
names
all right
now let's answer another
couple of questions so here I have what
is the highest amount spent on a single
player by each team
so to solve this question I'll see
my data frame name that is IPL
then I'm going to say
retention
equal to equal to
this should be from auction because you
want to see the highest amount spent and
not from the retained players
then I'm going to
group
by
I'll see
team
and then
I'll say
cost
in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees that is in crores
and
I'll say
Max
colon
-1
Dot
sort underscore
values
I'll say ascending equal to false which
means I want the sorted
result in descending order
okay
let me just
bring this
to the left side and we'll run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it sees
there's a spelling mistake this should
be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
Mumbai Indians have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be ishan kison
then Chennai Super Kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is Deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores Kolkata Knight Riders
bought shreyas Iyer for 12.25 crores and
so on and so forth so these are the
highest amounts spent on a single player
by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at maximum value or maximum
price
now if you follow IPL the maximum
price up at which a player was retained
happens to be ravindra jadija so let's
see at what price was he retained I'll
see
retention
equal to equal to I'll say
retained
then I'll see
sort underscore
values
by equal to
I'll use the same column
cost in
rupees that's in crores I'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot head
and I want to find the top player
again there's some error let's see
where is the error
C is ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket I should say
bye
I think this should be
fine now let's run it there you go
so you can see here my result is player
name ravindra jadija who was written for
16 crores by Chennai Super Kings
cool
now the next cell of code will
display or print the top 5 Bowlers who
have been picked in this year's IPL
based on
their cost in INR
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here Deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shuttle thakur
who was bought by
Delhi capitals earlier he was part of
CSK
for 10.75 crores then we have proceed
the Krishna who has been bought by
Rajasthan Royals this time
last year he was with KKR and he has
been bought for 10 crores similarly
lucky Ferguson has been bought by
Gujarat Titans and he played for KKR
last season he has been bought for 10
crores while his base price was two
crores then we have avish Khan
you can see avish Khan's base price was
just 20 lakhs and he has been bought for
10 crores by Lucknow super Giants again
and lastly he was part of the Delhi
capitals
now you can replace
this value
suppose let's say you want to find the
top five batsmans pigged or battles
picked with the highest amount you can
just see
batter instead of bowler and if I run
this you can see here
was bought by Kolkata Knight Riders for
12.25 crores lasted it was part of Delhi
capitals
then you have simran hitmeier who's from
West Indies he has been picked by the
Rajasthan Royals for 8.5 crores then we
have Rahul tribati shikha Dhawan and
devdat particle
now if you wanted to check for
let's see all Rounders
you can replace batter with all rounder
if I run this you can see Lamb
Livingstone has been bought by Punjab
Kings this season for 11.5 crores his
base price was just one crore and last
year he was part of the Rajasthan Royals
then we have a player from Sri Lanka
asaranga then we have harshal Patel
Shahrukh Khan and Rahul devatiya who
have been the top five all-rounders
picked at
highest amount
cool
now finally
we want to
see the players who were part of the IPL
last season but were not picked for this
year's IPL
so for that what I am doing is first I'm
renaming my 2021 Squad column this
column I want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
I am going to find out the unsold
players so here I am saying previous
team not equal to not participated and
then
I'm using another condition the team
should be equal to equal to unsold and
I'm going to find out only the player
and the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the IPL last
season but they haven't been picked this
season and last season they had played
for let's say Suresh Shrine update for
CSK Steve Smith was part of the Delhi
capitals succubal Hassan was part of KKR
if I scroll down you have David Milan
who played for Punjab Kings in 2021
or in Morgan
who played for KKR he also captained KKR
but unfortunately he was not picked this
season Chris Lane from Australia also
remained unsold this season
and to Tai we have Ben cutting Aditya
there are other players as well
we have Kane Richardson double kulkani
cool so these were the players who are
part of the IPL season 2021 but
unfortunately were not picked and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on IPL data
analysis 2022 so we learned
how to
use the different functions
and attributes that are part of
the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualize the data and
answered some specific questions
in this video we'll be using four
publicly available data sets about
formula one that has information from
1950 to the 2019 F1 season
we'll see how using the python libraries
you can perform exploratory data
analysis and draw valuable insights so
let's begin by understanding what
formula one is
Formula 1 also known as F1 is a
motorsport defined by open wield single
sheet race cars it features the best
drivers in the most powerful and
technically Advanced cars
the sport is governed by the FIA that is
international automobile Federation here
10 teams comprising of two drivers each
compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and a Constructor
champion
on our demonstration we'll be using four
data sets let me show them one by one
these are all CSV files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo so if you
notice the data set does not have
columns names in fact none of the data
sets have column names so while
importing the data set we'll assign the
column names using the names parameter
I'll show that in a while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
the result ID
then we have the race ID driver ID
we have the Constructor ID grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest lap then we also have
information about
rank
the fastest lap speed
and the status ID
now moving on to the second data set
which is about races
now this is the second data set which is
about races so it has information about
the race ID the year in which the race
was held then we have the round number
circuit ID
then the name of the
Grand Prix so you can see here
Australian Malaysia and Chinese Spanish
Monaco Turkish British German
and others
then we have the date on which the GP
was held or the Grand Prix was held
we have the time and a URL which
basically leads to the Wikipedia page of
that particular Grand Prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set
so this is our third data set which is
about drivers
now it has the driver ID the name of the
driver you can see here Hamilton rosberg
Alonso reichen
then we have Sato
Masa battle Weber and all
after that we have the
number code
and we have the
phonem of the driver the surname of the
driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well foreign we have the
Wikipedia page
for the driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
Constructors
so this is the fourth and the final data
set that we'll be using in our data
analysis project so here we have the
Constructor ID then the Constructor
reference
in Formula One
and this is the actual name of the
Constructor so we have McLaren
we have BMW sober Williams then we have
Ferrari Toyota Red Bull force India
we also have Jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the URL
that is the Wikipedia page of that
particular Constructor
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my Jupiter notebook that I'll be
using for this demo you can see some of
the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we see it sometime
so using these data sets that we just
saw under libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib and c bond
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and Constructors who have
been the most successful throughout the
history of firm sport
then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and if
the speed of the cars has changed over
the years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here I am importing numpy Panda
smartplotlib and c bond and after that
I'm writing percentage matplotlib inline
that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line I'll
hit shift enter to run it
will take some time there you go so if
you have successfully imported all the
libraries now the next step is to load
the data and assign
column names
so I'll load my
First Data which is results I'll say PD
Dot
read underscore
CSV
I'll give my
file name which is results dot CSV
and then using the
names parameter I'll pass in the
column names so actually I have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so I have this F1
notepad created which has the column
names I'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter I'll paste it
if I scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that have been
assigned
and that
I'm going to say
comma
and I'll write
header equal to none
I'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's
import the second data set which is
about
races I'll say
PD Dot
read underscore CSV
I'll give my
file name which is racist Dot
CSV
and then
I'll give the names parameter this is
actually names are not name
okay
I'm going to
copy the
second line
and I'll paste it here
and again
I'll say
header equal to none
we'll input our third data set which is
about
drivers
so I'll say PD dot read underscore CSV
I'll say
drivers dot CSV
and then
again use the
names parameter
and I'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names
for the drivers data set
here I
need to give
another parameter which is header
equal to
none
finally we are going to import our
constructor's data set
is a Constructor is equal to PD dot read
underscore CSV which is the function
present in the pandas Library
I'll say
Constructors dot CSV Which is my file
name
and then again I'll use the names
parameter
I'll go to my notepad and this time I'll
copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors data set
I'll paste it
and
here I'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right
now
let me hit shift enter to run it
okay we see some error here let's debug
the error it says no such file or
directory drivers dot CSV
let's see
where was the issue
okay they should be
driver.csv
cool now we have successfully loaded the
data and assigned The Columns to the
various data sets
now the
next analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here I'll create a data frame called
DF and I'll use PD Dot merge function
first I'll use the
results data frame that we just imported
above this one
and
I'm going to merge it with
racist data frame
and from the recess data frame I am
going to take
specific columns like the
race ID
then
I need the year
after that I need
name
next
I'm going to take
a round column as well
and
I'm going to use
on parameter so
on parameter is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and reaches
so here my common column is going to be
the race ID because it is present in
both the data sets
and I would like to merge
so for that I'm going to use how so I'm
going to use a left join
so
if you know SQL you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table and only the matching rows
from the right table
again going to use the merge function so
I'll write DF equal to PD Dot March
I'll say DF comma and now I'm going to
merge the
reverse data set
and
I'm going to select
specific columns so I'll say
driver ID
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
in the
column names
then I'll say
driver
ref which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma and then I want the
nationality of the driver
all right
we'll give a comma I'll say on
which column I want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver ID
again
how is going to be a left join
coming to the final
merge part I'll say again DF equal to PD
Dot
merge
I'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which I have is about
Constructors
from Constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so I'll take the
Constructor
ID
then I'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
here I'll say on equal to
the common column I'll use is
Constructor ID
and give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
cool make sure
you're merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the four data sets
I'll hit
enter
oops there is some error let's see it
says Constructor
ID index
okay there is a spelling mistake this
should be
Constructor ID cool
let's run it there you go
now
the next thing we want to do is to drop
the unnecessary columns so I'll say DF
Dot
drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names I'll say
number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have
position underscore
text
after that we have
labs
next we are going to drop
fastest lap
then we'll also drop the
status ID
comma
we'll drop the
result underscore ID column
and
going to drop the race underscore ID
column
will also drop
driver underscore ID column
and finally we are going to drop
the
Constructor underscore ID column
and I'll say access equal to
one
and in place I'll see equal to true
because I want to remove it from my
original data frame that is DF
there you go
now the next
thing I want to do is I want to rename
some of the columns so I'll say DF Dot
rename
I'll say
columns equal to
now we are going to pass in a dictionary
I'm going to change the
rank
to
test
underscore lap underscore rank
let me give a comma
now I'll say
name underscore X
equal to
I'll say the
Grand prename so I'll say GP underscore
name
scholar I'm going to focus is
the nationality column so I'll say
nationality underscore
X
I'll give a colon the value I'm going to
pass in as
driver nationality
all right
up next
we have one column called
underscore
y
and that I am going to change it to
Constructor name
another comma
I want to see
nationality
underscore y
Olan
change it to
Constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column and that I am
going to replace with
just
driver
finally I'll see
in place
equal to
true
just verify if all the column names are
correct
let's run it all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell I am going to rearrange
the columns so here I am using the same
data frame and we have just renamed the
columns so starting with your grand
prename round driver
nationality and others
let's run this
up next
we are going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete so I'll say DF equal to
DF
then I'll see
here
not equal to
2090
let's see how to sort the values so I'll
say DF equal to DF Dot
sort underscore values which is the
function name I'm going to sort it by
year
followed by
round
followed by
the
position
underscore
order
comma I'll say
ascending equal to
first let's say is false
next I have true
and then I'll have true
all right
Wing ahead
now we are going to see how to replace
the
put slash n values in the time column
with something called Nan because the
time column was not registered when a
driver did not finish a race or was
slapped by another driver
so to do this I am going to say DF Dot
time
dot I'm going to use the replace
function
and here I'll say
forward slash or backward slash
n
and I'm going to replace with
numpy's Nan
I'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
meters
I'm going to replace the
milliseconds value
milliseconds Dot
replace I'll paste it here
then I'll say DF Dot
fastest
underscore lab underscore rank Dot
replace
it
next I have
DF Dot
fastest Dot lab
Dot
time
say replace
to that I have
the next column which is speed so I'll
say fastest
underscore lap underscore speed dot
replace
I'll paste it
so here I'm going to replace
this particular value the
backward slash n with Nan
let me run it cool
step I'm going to change the data types
for fastest underscore lab underscore
speed to float then fastest underscore
lab underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float again for milliseconds also
we are changing it to float values
let me run it
now
I'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
I'll say DF Dot
reset
underscore
index
I'll say
drop
equal to
true
we'll give a comma and say
in place equal to true
all right
that we have
done our initial processing step of the
data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see all the data sets the
total number of non-null values the
memory usage and we'll check the head of
the data set now to see the total number
of
rows and columns I'll say print DF dot
shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use DF dot info function
so it gives me the
year the Grand Prix name
the round number
driver Constructor name grid position
order total number of points time
then time in milliseconds the first slap
rank the fastest lap speed the
nationality of the driver the
nationality of the Constructor then here
we have the total number of non-null
objects then you also have the memory
usage at the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so I'll see DF
Dot head let's say I want to check the
first 10 rows
there you go
if I scroll down you can see here we
have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the ear the Grand Prix name
round driver Constructor name and other
columns now let me just brief you about
what these column names stand for
so the year column that you see here is
this season that the Grand Prix took
place and then we have the name of the
Grand Prix now the round column is the
number of the Rays in each season for
example one means it was the first race
of the season and then two means it was
the second race of the season so so on
and so forth then we have the name of
the driver
for that we have the
name of the car Constructor so you can
see Ferrari Mercedes Red Bull Renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race then we
have the points column that is the total
number of points scored in the race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the winner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if I just scroll down
I'll just move to the right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lap
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during a race next we have
fastest lap time that is the shortest
amount of time that took to complete a
lap in the race
then we have the lap speed that is the
average speed of the
fastest lap then we have the country to
which the driver belongs to and then we
have the Constructor nationality that is
the country where the car Constructor is
based out of
okay
now here I am going to set my figure
size to 10 comma 6 this is going to be
for all the plots that we are going to
create afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the Grand Prix winners
so here I'm going to see
rival
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame
TF dot I'll say Loc
then I'll say DF
I want
the position underscore
order
and that should be equal to 1 so which
means
the driver one there is
and then
I'm going to use the
Group by function
I'm going to group it by driver
and
for values I'll say
position underscore
order
use the
count function
followed by
sort underscore values
I'll say
ascending equal to
false
change it to two underscore frame
Dot
reset underscore
index
what essentially I am doing here is I am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and won a Grand Prix
next
I'm going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so I'll say
SB
which we have taken in our
analysis ideally it should be SNS but SB
also will work so I'll say SB Dot
bar plot
I'm going to say data equal to
driver underscore
winner
the y-axis I'll have
driver
in the x-axis I'll have position
underscore
order
then I have
color equal to
green
that I'll set my
Alpha value
to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so I'll say PLT
Dot title
let's say most Grand Prix
winners in F1
then we are going to label our access so
for y label I will have
driver
name
we have the X label
that will have
number of
Grand Prix wins
and I'll see
PLT Dot y
text
cool
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot shows
that there are a large distribution of
ground prevents only a few drivers in
history of F1 have won over 20 Grand
Prix in their careers and there are some
drivers who completely dominated the F1
racing and have won over 50 Grand Prix
in their career so we are going to focus
on those top five or top 10
drivers in the next section so what I'm
doing here is from the
above result that we just got I'm going
to filter out only the top 10 so I'm
going to use the head function
and
inside that I passed in 10 if I print it
you can see here as per the data that we
have
we have Michael Schumacher who
is the position
order leader with 91 GP wins then we
have Hamilton Vettel Frost Senna Alonso
then we have Stewart Clark and Laura uh
the data that we have is not the most
recent one so if you check the actual
stats Hamilton has actually overtaken
Michael Schumacher and has won over 100
and
3 close to 103 races as of now
and next we have Michael Schumacher so
this is not the most recent data
cool
Now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so I'll say SB Dot
bar plot
I'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so I'll say top 10
drivers
in the y-axis we'll have
the
driver name
in the x-axis will have
position
underscore
order
for the bars I'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
I'll set my Alpha value
to be
0.8
and I'll see let's see
line
width
equal to
0.8
and I'll also give
an edge color of let's say black
follow the seam drill I'm going to give
a title to my plot so I'll say PLT Dot
title
most
GP windows xenophone
you give a y label
that says
driver
name
and then I'll have
X label which will have
number of
on-prey wins
cool
let me see if everything is fine and
then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal bar plot that shows the
top drivers in F1 so as per our data
that we have we have Michael Schumacher
who has won over 91 or close to
91
races then we have Hamilton battle
Alonso Clark and others
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top Constructors that
have participated in F1 so here I'm
finding out
all the
Constructor windows so here
I'm using my position underscore order
equal to equal to 1 and then I'm using
the group by
based on the Constructor name
and then I'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values in
descending order and I'm changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot I'm using the
bar plot function the data which is
Constructor underscore winner in the
y-axis I'll have the Constructor name on
the x-axis I'll have the position order
so you can see here I've used color as
pink and I've given a title acceptable
by label
and white X let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely
spread
so we have a lot of Constructor names
now our next task is to check the
top 10 GPA Constructor windows so here
I'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10 if I run it you can see
here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of
races or Ferrari McLaren Williams then
we have Mercedes Red Bull Tim Lotus
Renault
I know those
okay now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10 Constructors
let me show you how to do it
so I'll see
SB which is for c bond Dot bar plot
I'm going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 Constructors
scroll down I'll see Constructors
y-axis I'll have
Constructor
on the x-axis I'll have
position underscore order
then
I'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars
then I'll set my Alpha to
0.8
I'll see
line width equal to
0.8
and my
Edge color I'll say
black
that I'll say PLT Dot
title see top 10 most
GP wins
LT Dot
by label would be
Constructor
name
then I'll have PLT Dot
X label
as
number of
GP wins
cool
let's run it there you go so here you
can see we have Ferrari at the top then
we have McLaren Williams Mercedes I'm
pretty certain by the end of 2021 season
Mercedes would have gained a lot of wins
since Hamilton has been on the top
for Mercedes for quite some time now
all right
now
finally we are going to
create a
regression plot that will
show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing position vary
so to do that I'm going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the Bit Lane
so I'm using this function called reg
plot
to plot my
regression line
let me run it and show you the result
there you go so if you see here
we can easily see there is a linear
relationship between the starting and
finishing position so on the x axis we
have the starting position on the y axis
we have the
finishing of the finished place
so which is what is actually expected
right now we can also see that most
recess had up to
25 drivers you can see the density of
the points here but
some of the races also had over 30
drivers you can see the light color blue
dots
next
we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years now since this
data is only available from 2004 onwards
so we have
we have taken years that start from 2004
onwards
now let me show you the result
of this data
so essentially we are plotting the
average speed amongst all teams during
the fastest lap at individual Grand Prix
and here on the
i-axis you have the average fastest
speed in kilometer per hour and then you
have the different GPS and
you can see here the ear values now
in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around 2015
for almost all these circuits
and again from 2015 onward the speech
started
to increase
you can see here there's an increase up
to 2015 there's an increase there's an
increase here as well
you can also notice that the speed is
very different on each track for
instance if you check the
Italian Grand Prix which is here
Italian GP has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over
240 kilometers per hour on the other
hand if you talk about the Monaco Grand
Prix let me show you if you see here the
Monaco GP is the slowest race with
average speed below 160 kilometer per
hour now this is actually expected
because the Monaco Grand Prix
has very narrow streets and hence the
drivers cannot drive fast in this
circuit all right
so
hello and welcome to this session on
python projects
and today we are gonna discuss about how
we can leverage python as a programming
language in order to automate
downloading of images
from a web page or Google search
so we will see what all python libraries
and utilities are required in order to
perform that activity
so this is primarily an automation
activity which you can perform in Python
where you want to download certain
amount of data certain images we are
taking images as an example over here so
how can you scrap a web page download
the images automatically in a particular
folder
now what we are going to do is we are
using the selenium utility the selenium
package
in Python in order to perform this
activity
so what we are going to do is we do
we're going to import selenium package
and then from selenium we are going to
import these libraries Webdriver
buy then if we are going to import
requests IO
import image and time okay so these are
the relevant libraries which you're
going to use in this particular example
now for executing this example you need
a particular Chrome driver as we're
going to use Chrome uh we're gonna
download this chrome driver so in order
to download the Chrome driver you need
to go to this URL of chrome
driver.chromium.org downloads
and please download the latest version
if you respect uh depending on what
operating system you're operating on so
I am using Chrome driver with 32 so I'll
download the Windows driver
and unzip it at the relevant folder so
wherever you're going to unzip the
Chrome driver.exe file please give the
path over here
and then initialize that
using the Webdriver utility which you
have imported
okay
so this is the initialization and you
can see a Chrome browser has got opened
now we are going to create a function
called get images from Google
and
we are gonna write uh
internal function which will scroll down
which will scroll through that
particular browser to a particular
position and at a particular delay it
will start downloading the data
now
as a sample what we have done is we have
embedded a tree search a tree image
search Google search in my URL
so this so This search will
automatically get opened from my python
script automatically so you'll see that
add
then
I'm gonna run that in a loop and put
that image URLs as a set
now I'm right I'm gonna write a loop how
many images I want to download by that
I'm going to run a while loop on the
particular function and
write the piece of code in order to
download
till the time my Max images have been
reached now I will
find Elements by class name Q4 l u w d
okay
foreign
now for images in thumbnails I'll start
clicking that image so I'm using the
selenium utility over here I'm clicking
the image and then I'm getting the
source attribute of the image URLs and
then downloading it so this entire
function actually allows you to download
the image
and then I have a function which is the
download function
now I'm going to download images
from the web page I want four Images now
please make sure that you have provided
a path
so
see the images have started to get
download and four Images the parameters
which I have passed are getting utilized
and if I want to quit it
now my program has got quit so if you
see this the browser
from where the uh images were starting
to get downloaded got open automatically
and now as I have quit the program it
got closed
and here are the four Images randomly
which has been picked from that
particular search and added
so I've killed the connection so that's
why that's why this error is coming
hello everyone I am Monk and welcome to
Simply learn today we will take you
through the Hands-On lab demo of how you
can automate Excel using python before
we start I hope this screen is clearly
visible and the audio is fine if yes
please type in yes in the chat section
if there are any issues do let us know
in the chat section so that we can
resolve them I am repeating again before
we start I hope this screen is clearly
visible and the audio is fine if yes
please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
so I am waiting for some more winners to
let other people join
okay till then let me tell you guys that
we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
if you are a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for the latest technological Trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will go through what
is Excel after that we will see what is
Python and moving forward we will see
what is Automation and where it is used
at the end we will see a Hands-On lab
demo like how you can automate Excel
with python in detail
we already have data set with us we will
perform different function and automate
Excel data set using python before we
move on to the programming part let's
discuss what is Excel first and
importance of the same
so Microsoft developed Microsoft Excel a
spreadsheet for Windows Mac OS Android
and iOS it has calculating or Computing
capabilities graphing tools pivot table
and the Visual Basic for applications
the Microsoft Office program package
includes Excel users of Microsoft Excel
May format arrange and compute data in a
spreadsheet data analysts and other
analysts can make information easier to
examine as data is added or altered by
organizing data using tools like Excel
the boxes and excels are referred to as
cell and they are arranged in a row and
column the key features of excels are
they spreadsheet document in Ms Excel
can have headers and Footers and user
can protect their data by giving it
password protection
and the second one is filtering is
supported allowing you to locate the
necessary data in your spreadsheet and
replace it with the appropriate value
after discussing what is Excel let's go
through and see what is python so python
is the one of the most popular
programming language available today it
is widely used in various sector of
business such as programming web
development machine learning and data
science given its expected use it is not
surprising that python has surpassed
Java as a top programming language
python frequently used to create
software website and to perform data
analysis and many more because python is
a journal purple language it may use to
develop a wide range of programs and
isn't alert for any particular issues
so the key features of python are it is
open source and free
python can be downloaded from the
company official website it is simple to
download and install
python is open source because allowing
users with solid technical background to
modify the code to suit certain business
use case and product requirements since
python is a language for beginners most
anyone with the understanding of
programming can quick pick it up and
begin coding
so after seeing what is python let's
move forward and see what is automating
Excel with python
we all know python is dominant
everywhere and we also know that
compared to other language python is
beginner friendly and simpler to use
automation is the one of the coolest
thing you can do with python so how to
automate an Excel sheet in Python
imagine that you are asked to create
accounts for 30 000 employees on a
website what would you think you will
undoubtedly become frustrated carrying
out this talks manually and repeatedly
additionally it will take too much time
which is not the wise choice
so just try to picture that what it is
like for employees who work in data
entry
the responsibility is to extract the
data from tables like Excel or Google
sheet and insert it in the another
location they read various magazines and
website get the data there and they are
entered it into the database
additionally they must perform the
calculation for the entries in general
this job performance determines how much
money is made greater entry volume more
pay of course everyone wants a higher
salary in their job so however don't you
find doing the same things over and over
boring
the question is now
how can I accomplish it quickly
and how to automate my work spend an r
in coding and automating these kind of
course to make your life simpler rather
than performing these kinds of things by
hand by just writing fewer lines of
python code you can automate your
laborious activity in simpler so overall
python Excel automation is a creative
method that allows you to build visual
reports on python in a smoother manner
similar to how you would on Excel
businesses can use Python Excel
automation to streamline their operation
in accordance with their requirements
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answer in
chat section so I can see the answers
are given by you are correct or not
I'm repeating again here is one question
for you guys I will give you one minute
for this you can comment or you can give
your answer in chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is which type of
programming does python support
object oriented programming structured
programming functional programming and
all of the mention
so I'm repeating again which type of
programming does python support
option a object oriented programming
option b structured programming
functional programming and all of the
mention
so I am starting the timer of one minute
just type your answers in comment
section or in chat section do let me
know your answers guys so like please I
want that everyone should participate in
this so I am starting the timer
so
so your time starts now
so I want that everyone should
participate in this guys please to let
me know your answer in chat section or
in comment section
so I can see if the answer is given by
you are right or wrong so
like 36 seconds or more
is guys I want that everyone should
participate in this so
let me know your answers in chat section
or comment section
so you can just type the answers or a b
c d
your wish totally your wish so
10 seconds are left guys hurry up please
I want that everyone should participate
in this five second more
okay so time is over we will give reply
those who gave correct answers and those
who didn't give correct answer we will
give you a reply with the correct answer
okay so no worries
so now let's move to our programming
part to perform Excel automation using
python so first we will open command
prompt to write command to open Jupiter
notebook feature notebook
yeah
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open
select here new open new file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in importing our workbook
or worksheet so the first one is let me
first rename this
we will write Auto meeting
cell
using python
yeah sounds good
okay
so the first one is Open PI Excel open
py
Excel okay I have to write import yeah
perfect
so a python package called open pyxl can
read and write Excel 2010 xlx format
Excel SM format xltx and xltm files
it was created since there was no
library that could read and write office
open XML files natively from python
since open py Excel was initially based
on PHP Excel all pressed to the PHP
Excel team so open py Excel does not by
default provide protection from your
quadratic blow up or billion after XML
as sold installed diffused XML to
protect yourself from these assault so
we will write open py Excel and then
like
yeah
so
then we will write for important our
workbook so we can write here from open
p y Excel
report
workbook
code
underscore workbook
is capital here
so and this is for code for the
importing our workbook so let me write
in command like you can import workbook
like this so I can write you can import
workbook
this
okay perfect
yeah
so
here
let me import workbook then
so I have to write WB for Workbook
question
load
underscore workbook
the destination of the workbook so uh
the destination is in like desktop so I
have to write C
users
lp09
375
stop
Dash automation
that
we learn
Dot
cell SX format
okay cool
users SLP this one desktop automation
simply learn DOT xlx fine
so our workbook is loaded to Jupiter
notebook
we can see yeah perfect no error so
let's activate this workbook for the use
so we have to write WS for worksheet so
worksheet equals to WB DOT active
active
like import from openmpi Excel our book
there must be always been one worksheet
in a workbook it is accessible through
the workbook dot property active so
that's why we have write WB DOT active
so after making workbook active so we
will print our workbook like
we can print
so print
WS
so here
so here you can see the sheet one so it
is showing worksheet sheet1 why sheet1
because if you open your workbook and
see here is your worksheet name like
like so this is my automation
file
this is simply learn
so here you can see
the shade one
that is why it is showing sheet1 there
so uh okay so let me just
finish it
so moving forward
let's change the worksheet name so
I will write here import
open
pyxl
so like it's your wish that you want to
write this import file or like this
thing this is not necessary at all so
now I will import the workbook so I will
write here
WB equals to open py Excel
dot load underscore
workbook
when pyx L it is
my bad sorry guys
so
you have to give the path so I can copy
path from here
yeah perfect
okay sounds good
yeah yeah WB underscore sheet
equals to
WB and square brackets then you have to
write the sheet name so there we have
sheet 1.
sheet 1.
so sheet1 okay correct
so I can change with WB underscore sheet
dot title
sheet
dot title
equals to
code with
simply learn
perfect
yeah seems good let me save this
WD dot save
and the same
copy
here paste
yeah
so when a sheet is generated it
immediately receives a name like they
have sequential numbers of names like
sheet sheet1 sheet 2 and so on with the
worksheet you can modify this name
whenever you want to like using the
title property so
here let me save this
and yeah where are so again go to Simply
learn
yeah you can see code base simply learn
first it was sheet1 and now it is
changed to codebase Simply learn
so let me cut this again
okay
so if you want to change the color of
your sheet name tab whereas written code
will simply learn so you can write like
here
you can write
WD
or okay let me make this new one
okay right I will write here so
underscore sheet
dot sheet
underscore properties
app
color
was to
here you have to give hex
values so four zeros okay
so let me save this okay it is saying
sheet1 why sheet1 because we already
changed sheet1 to code which simply
learn so what you have to do is
here we have to write code with
simply learn
pre-learn
okay same same simply learn simply learn
same code code yeah so what I will do
here I will just
make W Capital so yeah
now it will work fine yeah
so
if you save or run your code like like
this let me
let me show you one thing uh like
color is already changed wait for one
minute guys I will show you something
crazy so it will see like this w
okay
so here I will small
so
if you save or run your code not
actually save but run your code while
your Excel sheet is open so my Excel
sheet is open code will simply learn
yeah
so my Excel sheet is open so it will
give you error like vital
repeat like whatever
this okay let me do one thing this is
one okay
it will give you
the brilliant one does not exist let me
check this is simply learn code will
simply learn
one
code with okw's capital there
okay see this is a
permission denied
then the location it is showing
permission denied
so this is something important to
remember that Excel file should be
closed while running the code and
repeating again so like this is
something important to remember that
Excel file should be closed while
running the code
so first what I have to do is close the
Excel file
then I have to run it again so no error
now so here you can see
what we simply learn that red color came
yeah perfect
so moving forward let's create new
workbook till we were working on the
same worksheet which was present me in
my like desktop so let's create new book
so for that I have to write
import
cell as X writer
so I will write here in command to
create
new notebook
WB equals to excel SX
writer
Dot
workbook
and where you want to
save the workbook so I will give
the same
path
but with different name
so this time I will give only like
coders simply
okay simply coders
then I will write WD close
okay I will run it yeah
so the primary class export by the XLS
writer module in the workbook class and
that is only class you will need to
instantiate directly so the workbook
class represents both the whole
spreadsheet as it appears in the Excel
and the Excel file as it is stored on
the disk internally
so you can see now
yeah you can see now
the workbook which is created in the
desktop with the same name is like
simply coders
so this is done
let's move forward and let's retrieve
cell values so right now we are not
having any data inside the workbook so
let's put some random values like names
and all so uh
I will put some random values
we'll put here
names
okay
mayank
kaushal
okay
well
like jelly
Chloe
so let's save it
let's save it
and let's move to our coding part so
here what I have to write to retrieve
cells here I just write a equals to A is
variable here
so I am assigning is WS
that
A1 value
the value which is presented at A1
so here I will write in comments like
to
retrieve cells
okay
so here I will print
print
a
okay okay
what I have to do is like we have
created this one file so it's it is not
giving
the uh this is giving sheet1 dot A1 why
because it is taking from the simply
coders one so what I can do is I can
import this file because we have saved
data in this file
so that base is here and make it active
detective yeah so yeah you know I
haven't write here value
well name A1 only so now it will print
aims why why names
because at the A1
at the A1 position we have names so if
you want to like print Anjali so what
you have to do is okay let me check this
B3 okay
if you want to print Anjali you have to
just write here just copy paste this
code
okay just right here the location
B3
you can see Angela is printed
so this is how you can retrieve cells
and we can do the same for the others as
to
so there is one thing like retrieving
we can change the sales values too
so just we have to write here so let me
give first enter enter for the better
visual
yeah
so here what we can write is WS
like I want to change the name of uh
name of name of
uh
I will take this A4 Smith
let me close this
okay
I will give here A4
dot value
equals to here you can give the value so
here you can write Smith you can write
John
here as a replaced value
so I will write here in as a command
inch cell
value
okay
so what you have to do is just save it
WB dot save
you have to give the path for the same
yeah
fine
so let me save this and
let me save this first and run this
first okay no error and let's open our
workbooks to see the changes
so here you can see
the changes has been implemented in our
workout
first there it was like Smith and now
John so like this you can change the
cell values and let's move forward and
see how we can merge the cells in a
worksheet
so like just close this and yeah
so
we are doing for the merging cells so
here I will write from
open pyxl
dot styles
import
alignment
so here I will write
merge cells
for your better understanding
okay
so here I have to write WB equals to
workbook
okay let me active this workbook
WB DOT active
merge
to the cell
set
which one uh let's take for a while A1
and B2
okay A and B should be in capital
letters
so after that we have to save this
we will save in this only
so I can copy I can paste it here
okay
fine
like using merge underscore cells and
after giving cell position you can
easily merge the cell so let's see the
output so let me open this simply learn
file
you can see
they are merged together and like but
what if you want the values at the same
time they should be capital
alignment
okay
so the same thing you have to write wdb
equals to
workbook
WS equals to
WB DOT active
don't have to give parenthesis
WS dot merge
underscore cells
cells
A1
B2
so here I have to give the cell value
equals to WS dot cell
which row which column so I can write
row equals to 1
problem
equals to one
so cell
dot value
equals to
here you can give the value which you
want to print at the cell
so here I will write code with simply
learn
okay fine
so what we can do this we can give the
alignment
alignment equals to
alignment
or horizontal horizontal
equals to Center
and from vertical
and from vertical the same
Center
okay let me save this file WB dot save
at the same location so I can copy the
path from here
copy here and paste here so I will
yeah seems good let me save this
white is giving error cell object has no
attribute alignment okay alignment
spelling is wrong
sorry my bad
gnme and T
eight seems good now
oh good to go
so
so here you can see
like by giving rho equals to one column
equals to one basically position and
after giving the value to what to print
on that cell and one more thing is
alignment like it is not necessary to
give alignments like I just wrote it to
cover it uh like in video so you can
give alignments like uh right left this
time I gave the center to print in the
center
so let's
move and see the results
so you can see the value has been
printed exactly at the center of the
cell
well I will make it like this you can
see
the value is printed exactly at the
center of the cell because I gave the
alignment center so let's do one more
for like
to see what is the default place if you
don't give the alignments okay if you
don't give the center alignments what is
the default value so let me first remove
this okay save no issues
okay yeah
so
we had a line
alignments
or here what we can do is like
from
UI Excel dot styles
import
alignment
it is not necessary to light import
alignments
okay this is without
okay I can write this default
live
's good
okay everything we have to cover from
here so I can just copy from here and
paste it here
so what we will do here we have to give
row
equals to 6
and column must be
it so let make it be cs6b6
okay let's column should be six
so code will simply learn coders of
Simply learn
photos of Simply learn like we are
giving the value
so at the same time we have to just save
it WB dot save
copy
paste here
okay
so this time we are not giving the
alignments you can see here we have gave
alignments not now so
let's run this and after that we will
open our workbook
so this is saying merge cells
okay 2 must be greater than 3. okay so
here what is happening
okay I can write here D6
right
so now it will run properly I guess yeah
it's working
so
let me open this
so you can see
this is the default value of like uh
it so here you can see the value is
printed at its default location
not in centered or not in right not in
left it is default location
so till now we know how to merge cell so
I repeat I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any questions or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
so
moving forward
until now we know how to merge cells so
let's learn how to earn muscle okay so
let me open the code
yeah
let me open the code and write for you
so let me quickly write the code how we
can myself so we can write open
from
open
y
Excel
dot styles
so just I can copy this from here
I have to write here import alignments
yeah alignment only
so what we are doing here we will not
give any value or any this
so here I will remove like B6
actually we can give
like a
six
P6 as a value
let's see the cells are merged or Not by
running it
okay see permission denied because
our Excel was opened so let me save this
and close it
and run it again no error
so
here you can see
let me Zoom if I can yeah so as you can
see A6 and B6 are merged so what should
I do to unmerge I have to write
yes you can write here like
where you can write WS Dot unmerge
underscore cells
okay cells
got it and just give this same value
A6 underscore B6
okay colon B6
let me save this again no error let me
open the file
so you can see here
A6 and B6 now unmerged
so by just using unmered cells you can
easily unmerge the cells in your
workbook so let's move forward and see
how can you set dimensions for a
particular cell or column
so
let me close this and go to the workbook
again
this is something frustrating by like by
regularly doing the same thing going
next next next
so like you need a particular column
height should be something and which
should should be something so that is
what I'm like meant to be Dimensions so
let's write code for it you will see and
understand by seeing so
import
open p y Excel
#to set
dimensions
of a particular
cell
okay
WB equals to
open p y Excel
dot dot workbook
worksheet equals to
workbook DOT active
ws.row
underscore dimensions
okay
one I will explain you don't worry
height
equals to
let me give 70 for a while
okay w s dot column
underscore
dimension
wait I will explain you don't worry
don't worry it
so let me save the file WB dot save
and let me copy the path from here
okay
everything seems
good
okay
y column okay column name is like okay
no column Dimension okay
dimensions
so like this
you can see here one for the column like
2 for the column three for the column
let me Zoom it
you can see now one for the all the one
column Row 2 for the two Row three for
the three row
like this
for you can say I use one for the
particular row or you can say one for
denoting row particular Row one two
three four five six like this
chicken I repeat
and particular alphabet to denote the
column see a for this column B for this
column C for this column D for this
column like this okay
so here you can see every cell of Row
one has the same height this this this
this this this this this this
and every cell of
bit and every cell of column B has same
width
BS same width
so
like we can do one more thing we can
print
value though in a particular cells like
okay let me
close this
and open the this one
so what can I do is I can write
here
like we can write at wd's cell
rho equals to 1
comma column
equals to 1.
okay
dot value
equals to
hello
okay and WS dot cell
here I will write rho equals to 2
comma column
equals to 2
dot value
dot value
equals to
coders
so I have to write it here not below
this yeah
okay cool let me give this space line
okay so let me save this
and
let me check
so here you can see
hello is for the row one and coder at
the column B
okay fine
so let me close this and
okay next I repeat next let's see how we
can move data to a particular row or
column or you can say a particular cell
here we need data to make it move so
let's fill some random data
on it so what I can do is
I can put some random data
of like
fruit
vegetables
and some names like Mayan
jelly
above
social
oh no
and we can give like
anything is myth
John
and Chloe
Sarah
and
all right surgeon
okay
I think this much is enough so let me
save this
and yeah
so data part is done and let's move to
the this one and write import
open pyxl
so let me write here move
cell
you can say move or jump whatever you
want to say so from open p y Excel
import
workbook
come on Lord
underscore workbook
will be equals to
load
can give the path like this yeah
C and we
okay let's make it active WS equals to
WB DOT active
of X seems good okay
so I have to move WS
dot move
score range
this is I can give okay let me see
the data first
okay I will make
an above here
and
blank here
or here okay
so let's see again I forgot it is B
5 and A4
B5 A4
okay
so what we can do it uh like
oh
e
five
comma like rho
was to
and call
V rho is equal to 2 and calls equals to
so let me save this w dot save
and let me
so here what I'm doing is changing the
position of the value which is present
in the location
A4 and B5 so and moving them by you can
say the value will jump by two rows and
two columns because I gave here two rows
rows equals to 12 columns equals to 2.
so let me save this run this okay
and
so here you can see
so let me run this and what you have to
do is open this file
yeah
so you can see A2 means one two
it comes fruit comes here and coders
come here so this is how you can move
your
coding part
I repeat so this is how you can move the
cell values so let's move forward
and
G moving forward let's see how we can
insert a row in our workbook okay so
first what I will do is
I will add some data like
name here like fruits
and something like car
and here I can like bike
okay
something here coding
okay all the data is filled and all rows
are filled by some values so here we
have no like no empty row present here
till now so what we will do is
we will insert a row
okay so what we have to write is import
open p y Excel
hashtag
insert
goes
okay
from open p
p
so
port
workbook
command load
and let's go
load
all right
let me copy the path
see
so let me make it active
so I want to insert row
deposition to
and one more row
at the position 5.
so let me save this I will copy from
here
okay
I will make it like this so let me save
this no error
let's move to the workbook
you can see here Row 2 is created and
Row 5 is created with no values
so
as you can see rows are added to the
particular position or you can say the
indexes
so we have seen how we can insert the
rows let's see the deletion of the rows
so what we can write is let me open the
code
so what we can write is let me copy to
save our time
okay just delete this
so we can write
WS
dot delete
underscore
close and which row
2 5 uh I will delete row number two
for a while
so let me save this
and run this
so you now you can see empty Row 2 is
deleted
so by using insert rows and giving them
index you can insert the row at the
index position you give and meanwhile
you can use delete underscore rows
function to delete the particular row so
moving forward let's quickly write code
for the insert column
so for inserting column
I will copy from here
yeah insert row
column
and this one is for
e-leating
row
okay
so I have to write here WS
Dot
active not active sorry insert
calls add the position
second
okay at the position one and
okay I will make it
insert
calls at the position three
okay let me save this file by copying
this path
okay saving let me do one thing
yeah perfect
so let me open the workbook
so here what I've done is insert call at
second position here we can't give
alphabet we have to give a number for
denoting a position so
as you can see the column is added at
the position one
and three
so by using insert underscore calls and
by giving index you can insert column in
your workbook
so let's do one thing guys
okay first let me close this and yeah
so what I was saying that let's do one
thing guys
you will tell me how can I delete a
particular column
okay let me write here
the question
comments like
how
can
you
delete a
particular
particular
column
okay
I'm giving you one minute for this just
comment the code for this column
deletion or else you can reply on chat
I will suggest you to write a comment
because after this session our team can
easily check who gave the correct answer
and who didn't give the correct answer
don't worry I will provide you the
answers at the end of the session or our
team will reply at your comment at the
same time
so uh like for those who are watching
this video like we watch normal video
means you are not watching the live
session so what you can do is just pause
the video right now and put the comment
how you can delete the column
I am repeating again I will suggest you
to write a comment because after this
session our team can easily check who
gave the correct answer and who didn't
give the correct answer
don't worry I will provide you the
answer at the same time
or our team will reply at your comment
at the same time
and those who are watching the video
like we watched normal video
so that you can do is just you can pause
this video and put the comment how you
can delete the column
so I guess time is up guys I hope most
of you gave the correct answers by
putting comments we will verify your
comments and we will back to you soon so
okay moving forward let's see how we can
style the font in Excel
okay this is something crazy and
interesting
so you will not get bored and writing
from open pyxl
dot styles
import
font
so here I will write for your styling
okay
so what I can do is like WB equals to
open
p y Excel dot workbook
blue s dot
equals to WB DOT active
I will don't worry I will explain you
rho equals to 1
comma column
equals to 1 equals to
um
relearn
okay
and I will set the size of the cell
so WS equals to
sell
rho equals to
1
comma
column
equals to 1
Dot
value
here I have to write font
equals to
font
equals to
font and you have to write size
equals to 24.
okay here I have to give
dot value
now we can do it for the many others
but we will do it
we will
change
hello
not world again we will write coder
hello coders and
here we will add code with simply learn
and here we will write
hello YouTube
so
what I will do is like it will
2 column two row two
two here
what I will do is font size equals to
24 and and I will make it italic
question
true
okay fine and I will make it
old
only question true
and here I will give
three
three
okay and at the end what I can do is
okay bye
Thanks new
one
so let me save it quickly
WB dot save
with a fart
so let's run this and see the results
so let's run this again one more time
so here what I did is just gave the
particular row and column value where we
want to print the value like simply
learn hello coders hello YouTube code
which simply learn
okay and by using font I am giving the
font size and font like italic bold and
so on like this is italic this is bold
okay and here you can see at the End by
using name here you can see
at the End by using name
we assigning the styles of the
particular text like Times New Roman and
you can give the name of your choice
so why it is not because
I have gave the it is collapsing
so here I have write 444 okay now it
will it is collapsing now hello YouTube
and simply learn
so what I will do is now I will run
now you can see
yeah perfect
so this is simple one this is it in
italic this is in bold and this hello
YouTube is in Times New Roman Style
okay
so okay let's move forward and do
something with cells
um like what we can do it let's do color
them okay
let's add code for this
how we can like color a particular cell
we know how to color the particular tab
of sheet
and now
let's color it so we can write as import
open py Excel
here I will write coloring
particular Google
cell
okay
so I will first copy this thing here
from here
okay I don't think I want this I have to
write from open
py Excel
spice
port
and fill
I want something like this
okay so WD dot open py Excel workbook
here I can write open pyxl
dot load workbook
okay
workbook
and here I will give the path
fill
a t t pattern
type should be I will prefer solid
okay
and
comma
FG color
foreground color
equals to
I will write here f
c 2 C
0 3. okay
fine we can make four cells
four cells
four cells are enough I guess
so we can write here cell one
paste copy paste copy paste so we'll do
four
today
2 solid solid solid yeah
so let's change color we can give 0 3
FC F4
here I will give
three five F C 0 3.
perfect
here I can give
o f c
a 0 3
so now let me assign
let me assign the cells to them WS
like
you can assign a
a one
sine A2
dot fill
equals to
fill
underscore cell
KR
ill
underscore cell one
it seems good
this I can make it for four we we
MRA 2 8 4 A5
A3
everything seems good
let me save this so I will copy from
here
why error permission denied because it
was open so let me cut this
foreign
so let me see
so here I'm using the pattern field to
fill the color and solid style and
giving the FG color like foreground
color
and at the below you can see I'm like
assigning these cells to a particular
pattern fill cells so
let's see the output yeah it's working
here you can see the results we colored
these for the particular cell like A2 A3
A4 A5
so this is something you can style the
color so let's move forward and see how
we can import the image in our workbook
like something here something here
something here let's see
so let me first cut this okay
let me do one more thing yeah
perfect
coloring particular cell
so how we can import
our file or image you can say
so I will write
from
open p y Excel
both
load underscore workbook
okay load underscore workbook load
underscore workbook
and
I have to write have
workbook
right WT equals to
load underscore
workbook
give
let me copy this and this hole
so logo is for
variable used for the match image
okay so I don't have any image for right
now
let me do one thing
uh let me import one image
any kind of image for a while so I can
do like
so this is my image
what can I do is
what can I do is I can give the path
like
uh
path would be same
path would be same
we will change here something don't
worry don't worry
X stop
don't remember name of the file this is
picture two
yeah
peace is smaller capital
p is capital so I have to write
pictures
so
I will give logo
dot height equals to 150
logo
Dot width
equals to
150 a bit of resizing to not fill the
whole spreadsheet with the logo
so that's why just for that so WS dot at
image
to logo
comma
cell in which cell you want to print I
will m 2. fine
so here we will
save it
by using this one
okay perfect
cannot image import name image from
mobile file drawing during this one
so might be there is problem
open p y Excel Dot
drawing
dot image
okay
import image
I think I is capital here
seems
logo image okay ice Capital here
yeah it seems good
yeah here is the picture so what I do is
what can I do is
so here we need one more Library drawing
image a variable logo this one
is for the location of the image and
giving and height and weight because a
bit of resizing to not fill the whole
spreadsheet with a logo like with the
whole spreadsheet with the logo so just
a bit of resizing
and add image function is used to append
image on it and M2 is for like this M2
M2 is for position m
2 like that it's for in which cell you
want to append it so
image is coming to the particular index
M2
okay
so this is how you can import image and
Excel using python okay let's move
forward and see how we can import date
and time
so let's write code for that quickly
okay
so what I will do is I will write here
import
date time
I will write
date
time
from
open py Excel
import
workbook
time
so what can I do is
make it WB equals to
workbook
low should be Capital here
and WS equals to WB DOT active
what can I write is Ws dot cell
row
1
comma column
was to one
dot value
equals to
date
and time
it's something
so I can copy it
paste it
what I can do is
let me first change the
three
oh
equals to 3.
okay
follow me question two I guess
value
so here I can assign date and time
date
time dot date time
dot now
Dot string
format strf
time
what you have to write it percent y
percent m per month
percent D for days
percent h
then percent
I am for minutes and percent
seconds
so this should be
in between this
okay
yeah
right
so let me save this
close it
import data time not date time it's date
time
okay row equals to 1.
data time no date time
again
date time dot now
daytime Dot date time
80 dead time the daytime objects has no
attribute strf
time okay time it is yeah
okay
yeah
Finance working no errors
so air like okay
so here I have imported some libraries
like date time and so on strf time used
for string formatter and date time now
used for the current date time this date
time now is used for the current date
time
and so let's run this and see
so here you can see the correct time and
date is coming it can be different from
your from which country you are watching
this live session
so
what if you want to print the time after
like two seconds late
so for that we can write here
quickly
so I will copy this hole
we
so like
we have to copy this and just what you
have to do is
let me make for to see the difference
v v okay three are enough
so what I will do is
go four
five
okay fine what I will add here is time
dot sleep
how much seconds you want like two
for this one and
something for this one like
five seconds for this one
okay
so what we can do is let's save it
and let's see the results
so here I've used the time dot slave
function given parameter as 2 or 4 I
guess five for printing the seconds
difference
so here you can see the difference in
seconds okay the time is not coming wait
wait let me check
okay why permission did not sorry guys
now I have to turn it
open it
and it is not coming why so
shouldn't denied
okay
let me run it again
okay okay because I'm giving seconds
difference not that why that is why is
giving permission denied so let us wait
for two five five seconds
okay I think five seconds are over now
we can open it
yeah you can see 47 seconds and 49s two
second difference and 49.54 5 Second
difference
so here I've used the time slip function
given parameter as 25 for printing the
second different
so let's move to the workbook uh
a bit here you can see the difference in
seconds so I hope you understand till
here if you have any questions or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
I'm repeating again I hope you
understand till here if you have any
questions or any doubt
or any query regarding any code or
whatever it is so just put as in
comments or our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
so moving forward
moving forward let's see how we can add
values as an array
okay
so what I will write import
xlsx
writer
WB equals to xlsx
writer Dot
workbook
okay I will give the path
from here
okay WS equals to
WB dot at
worksheet
W should not be Capital here
okay so what I will do is rho equals to
0
and column equals to zero
okay so I will write here uh
data
equals to
and take us
the names just names
we
this random names they are
above let's take
one more kissly
so
for
atom
and data
and WS
dot right
I will explain you line by line don't
worry
row comma
column
comma item
perfect so here what I will do is rho
plus equals to 1 or you can write rho
equals to rho plus 1
w b Dot
close
okay
let's save this
let's see our data is appended or not
okay first I will explain this code to
you
so here I have created one new workbook
like name
no I haven't created so let me create
two
okay
example
okay
so I will run this yeah perfect so yeah
I repeat so here I have created one new
workbook name example
so at row 0 column 0 I am printing my
content values
like for data values using for loop I am
moving to the next iteration of the
values like from undue to cos U and then
my Ang then so on
so let's see the results
okay
yeah
so here you can see all the values are
printed so using these chords of line
you can do things like this easily
so for that we need
so we need data for that so let me add
the full data
of let me
copy some data from somewhere
so
just give me a minute
okay
is the blank worksheet
let me give me one minute guys
okay what I will take is
fun
I can take this
some values we can copy like 50 values
okay
50 is high enough
see
yeah
yeah
we have data now
we have data in this simply learn okay
now we can write code for that like how
to retrieve multiple column
so the same
font
see
let's do WB
DOT active
okay
WS
equals to
WB
spreadsheet
column
in worksheet
a
okay
so what I have to do is just print
column values
column dot value
I hope it will work uh
WB DOT active
workbook object has no attribute active
okay let me see
okay sorry
import open p y Excel
XLS title is used for
to create new workbook okay open p y
Excel
dot load
underscore workbook
now it will work I guess
still it is not working
out
it should work I guess
open pyxl
open pyxl Dot load okay okay sorry my
bad here Dot
now it will work okay sheet
too much this is sheet one
you never know
when the sheet will create
one
yeah
you can see all the list of column A is
printed here
all the 50 values and you can match from
here to
all the 50s values okay Trail Travis
Scott
so let me match this
got okay
so
I hope you understand till here if you
have any questions or any query
regarding any code so just put as in
comment or our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution after doing
importing exporting the values and all
let's perform some basic operation like
addition average and all okay
so first we will start with the addition
so I will write here so we need data in
workbook for the addition
so let's take some data from
from which set
the same install data set
so I will take this
this
values are enough
okay
copy it
and let me paste here
so what data we have let's code for it
we have to write here import
open p y Excel
we are doing sum of columns
not column column values values
yeah
like from open
p y Excel import
book
comma load underscore workbook
so WB equals to load
underscore
a note workbook
workbook
copy the path
a
so I will make it active
so here what I'm doing is
I will tell you shortly
so it is in C I guess C or p
which column
or p
B 50
one I guess yeah
P51
B should be capital
equals to
see carefully what I'm doing like sum
from B one
one
till
B I guess 50 values we have 50.
okay B should be Capital my bad sorry
okay this is what I'm doing and WDS dot
save
the save one
so here I have added all the values
which are between in the range of B1 to
B 50.
and what I'm doing is the result will be
displayed on the b51 cell okay so let's
run this code
okay
let's go to the b51
yeah result is coming for verifying the
result is correct or not I won't use
calculator
for this so we can use
this code for the same for average
product and count so let's
do it quickly
okay so let me just copy paste this
stuff
c v this is will be for
average
a spelling mistake average
okay what I will do is just write
Capital heavy
Bridge here okay and I will print it to
50
2.
okay code is almost same just one change
like you have to write instead of sum
you have to write average
there
and just okay
let's see then
so now you can see this is the 137 point
something something is the average of
these all values
everything look good
let's see the count
quickly let's
be
code is almost same just we have to
okay capital
fifty three
visible okay
this count will give you how many values
are there between the range till 1 to
50. so let's check let's run it again
and check
if it's working or not yeah 49 values
okay
so
what I'm planning is let's do one thing
now guys uh you will tell me how I can
find the product of a particular range
I'm writing question as a command as I
did before
so
how to
a
okay
how to find
product
of numbers
like where
yeah
at the range is between
a A2 to a 98
okay
so I'm
giving you one minute for this just
comment the code for this like
multiplication or else you can reply on
chat you can write just syntax only for
the product
I will suggest you to write a comment
because after this session our team can
easily check who gave the correct answer
and who didn't give the correct answer
don't worry I will provide the answers
at the end of this session or our team
will reply at your comment at the same
time
and those who are watching the video
like we watch normal video or you are
not attending the live session so you
can just pause this video and comment on
how we can find the product in Excel
using python
I'm repeating again I will suggest you
to write a comment because after this
session our team can easily check who
gave the correct answer and who didn't
give the correct answer don't worry I
will provide you the answers at the end
of this session or our team will reply
at your comment at the same time
those who are watching this video like
we used to watch normal videos uh so
what you can do is just pause this video
and comment on how we can find the
product in Excel using python
so I guess time is up guys I hope most
of you gave the correct answer by
putting comments we will verify your
comments and we will back to you soon
so moving at the last
of this session let's do something with
charts so what I will do is first I will
move it bit up
yeah
so let me write code for that for the
chart
so I will write from open
p y Excel
import
workbook
um
open p y Excel
dot chart
import
reference
comma
line chart
okay we will create line chart WB equals
to workbook
WS equals to
workbook DOT active
so after this I will set the chart title
title equals chart
okay
let me create these rows so rows equals
to
uh what I will do is
I will create something like
um
X
okay comma
uh
sale
comma
veggiesel
yes
Oma
not here
Obama
and I have to give the values weeks are
Monday
okay let me keep this same
what cell should be like 100
comma 200
Tuesday
from a 200
comma 300
Wednesday
300
comma 400
but
until Thursday
I'm a 400
or 20 30.
hey
20
comma
at the day
60 comma 30.
okay it seems good
let me do
like four
s
okay Row in rows
blue s dot append
oh
values
equals to
reference
WS comma min
call
s to 2 comma Main
rho equals to 1
comma Max
column equals to 3
comma Max
underscore row equals to 7.
okay it seems good okay x dot values
equals to
reference
the score string
equals to
chart
A2
A7
so chart equals to line chart we are
making
so let's add the data to line chart
object
chart
dot add underscore data
values
command titles
t i t
t i t l e s titles
underscore from underscore data
constructo
okay
it should be capital
so let's set x axis
chart dot set
categories
X underscore values
okay let's set chart
Dot
let's go
tails
chart Dot
access
l equals to
VX
and chart
dot y
axis
dot title
equals to
put
and
veggies
sales
chart dot Legend
dot position
is to B
okay
so WS dot add
underscore chart
comma
H1 cell
so WB okay let me copy this code from
here
so here I am importing reference and
charts Library like this reference and
charts Library
and just giving title as charts you can
see here chart
so rows are the data from which we will
make chart
and for Loop is to append the data on
the workbook
chart add data chart add data
values titles from data equals to true
this is for adding data to the line
chart object just giving the title X
action and y axis
and all so let's save this and see
whether chart is visible or not
let's save this
okay what is going cannot import name
reference from open file
reference okay let me see
error in line two error in line two
okay sorry my bad okay
now it will workbook
forward number okay W should be capital
should be Capital now it will work I
guess
again that's reference
okay
extort values
dot my bad
h a r t
c h a r t
dot save okay WB Dot
okay finally no errors
so let's save this and see whether chart
is visible or not
let me go to this simply learn
yeah you can see chart is coming and it
is it's looks so good I hope you guys
must have understood the concept of
automating excel with python if you have
any queries or doubt you can ask them in
comment section below our team will
respond as soon as possible and if you
want this full code just comment for the
same a project on Python and how python
can be used to invoke and send messages
in WhatsApp
so what we are going to today do is
we're going to demonstrate you how to
use Pi watt kit it's a python utility
which is available in order for you to
interact directly with the pi Python and
WhatsApp
so we will show you certain examples
using which you can directly interface
with your WhatsApp now in order to
perform this activity first you need to
go to your python installation folder
now in my case I have my python
installed in my app data local programs
python python310 so your first task is
to go and open a command prompt from
this folder
and then you need to install pip install
by what kit so under python310 there is
a folder script
and you paste this command
and you should get this particular
message if you have already installed by
what kit if not then python will install
the relevant library in your computer
after you have done this then go back to
your python root folder
go to the python terminal
and then run the command import Pi what
kit
okay so after you have installed the
piwotkit library then you need to import
the pivot kit and this message should be
successfully imported
now I want to send a WhatsApp message
to a phone number
and I want to send it at a particular
time so right now I'll just set the time
as 20 38.
and please make sure that you are
already logged in to your
web.whatsapp.com and so that you know uh
the when python tries to send a message
you are already pre-logged in okay
okay so now if you see with this message
with this API I'm gonna send the message
at 8 39 so this will go and open the
WhatsApp window in next 46 seconds and
after 20 seconds the message will be
delivered so 8 39 so when the timer in
my system clock will reach to this
particular time
python will open a WhatsApp window log
into that reach to this phone number
which is there in my WhatsApp contacts
and then after 20 seconds this message
will be delivered so let's just wait for
few seconds and wait for python to
perform that activity
yes now python has opened the
web.whatsapp.com in which I'm already
logged in it has reached out to that
number and type the message welcome to
Simply learn world and I can send this
message
foreign
to the another example if I want to send
a message to a WhatsApp group then you
need a WhatsApp group chat ID and the
message you want to send so now in order
to send a message to the WhatsApp group
you can pick any
WhatsApp group in which you are
administrator
go to the group info and
click invite to group via a link
and in this link copy
copy this part copy link go to notepad
just copy this part this is the group ID
okay and paste it over here
okay
so now you can
send message to a group
copy paste this
in your command prompt
set the timing
in 16 seconds WhatsApp will open a
window and after 30 seconds the message
will be delivered
okay so WhatsApp window is open
it will reach out to that particular
group
it will type the message
and submit it
and even it will close the window
automatically now okay so this
particular
command has typed the message submitted
it and closed the window
now if you want to send the WhatsApp
message instantly
you just
use the API send what's message
instantly
and it will send it instantly to the
user
foreign
utility is that if you want to
find a keyword
on YouTube
so we'll just play
on YouTube Simply learn on YouTube so
it will automatically play the YouTube
channel which you have put in that
particular keyword on the YouTube so
python can also directly open a YouTube
url
or if you want to do a Google search
here you go so as soon as you put that
command on the python console it will
open google.com and search it in this
video we are going to perform a really
interesting data analysis using python
on the Spotify music streaming service
platform data set
I'll also be asking you a few questions
related to Spotify during our discussion
please make sure to answer them in the
comment section of the video
so now let's get started
Spotify is a student is audio streaming
and media services provider founded in
April 2006.
it is the world's largest music
streaming service provider and has over
381 million monthly active users which
also includes 172 million paid
subscribers the total number of
downloads on the Spotify app in the
Android store exceeded 1 billion in May
2021
so millions of people listen to music
all day even I am hooked to music as an
analyst what's better than exploring and
quantifying data about music and drawing
valuable insights before I move ahead I
have a quiz question for you people
the name Spotify comes from a
combination of two words so which are
those two words please let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below I
would like to repeat the question again
the name Spotify comes from a
combination of two words so what are
those two words we would love to hear
from you so please put your answers in
the comment section below
now let's use Python libraries and
functions to analyze and visualize our
data set
first I'll show you the two data sets
that we'll be using
so here is the first data set that we'll
be using for our demo and then I have my
second data set called Spotify features
which is essentially about the genres of
the different soundtracks
now these data sets have been downloaded
from kegel.com now the Links to the
datasets have been provided in the
description box please go ahead and
download them now let me just go ahead
and brief you about the columns that are
present in our first data set which is
about tracks we have a column A which is
ID this is the unique ID for each of the
songs then we have the name column which
is essentially the name of the song then
we have a column for popularity so the
popularity ranges from 0 to 100 then we
have duration in milliseconds this is
the duration of the track in
milliseconds next we have a column
called explicit now we are not bothered
about this column because we are not
going to use it in our analysis
then we have artists so the name of the
artist who has composed or sung the song
then we have ID of the artist then we
have a column for release date which is
basically the date on which the song was
released then we have a column for
danceability so this describes how
suitable a track is for dancing based on
a combination of musical elements such
as Tempo Rhythm stability beat strength
and overall regularity the value ranges
between 0 and 1.
next we have a column for energy so the
energy is a measure between 0.0 to 1.0
and represents a perceptual measure of
intensity and activity typically the
energetic tracks feel fast loud and
noisy higher the value the more
energetic is the sum
then we have a column for key so key is
the pitch notes or scale of song that
forms the basis of a song there are 12
Keys ranging from 0 to 11
moving ahead we have loudness so the
overall loudness of the track in
decibels it ranges from minus 60 to zero
decibels
then we have mode
so songs can be classified as major and
minor 1.0 represents major or one
represents major and 0 represents minor
a column for
the cost thickness
so a confidence measure of 0 to 1 of
whether the track is acoustic or not so
1.0 represents high confidence the track
is acoustic then we have other
information about
instrumentalness
then we also have a column for
liveness so liveness detects the
presence of an audience in the recording
then we have a column for valence so
balance is a 22 onwards so all the songs
from 1922 till 2021
cool
okay so I am on my Jupiter notebook so
you can see I have a few cells that have
already been filled up
so we'll start with our analysis first
of all let's go ahead and import the
necessary libraries so I am importing
numpy pandas matplotlib and c bond for
my analysis and visualization I'll hit
shift enter to import the libraries all
right and in the next cell I'm going to
load my data set using the pandas read
underscore CSV function I have my
location already
put here let me show you the location
where the data files or the data sets
are located so this is my location on
the Chrome downloads I have a folder
called Spotify datasets
okay
so let's import and
check the first five rows in the data
set so for that I've used the head
function there you go so here you can
see I have my first five rows of
information from the data set and on the
top you can see the different columns
you have ID name popularity
artist
then we have the release date
danceability energy key loudness
liveliness or liveness
balance Tempo and other information
cool
now
let's check for null values in the data
set I'll just give a comment as
null values
every time when you download a data set
from an open repository there are
chances that the data set would contain
null values so it's better to check them
beforehand
so I'm going to use the is null function
present in the pandas Library
PD I'm using because I had imported
pandas SPD
so PD dot is null then I'm going to use
the variable name DF underscore tracks
because I imported my data set and
stored it in the variable DF underscore
tracks
so I have my data frame under
DF underscore tracks variable
and then I'll use the sum function to
check the total number of null values
present in the data set for each of the
columns if I run it there you go
so here you can see my name column has
71
missing values or null values and we
don't have any null values for the rest
of the columns
okay
now let's use the info method that will
give us the total number of rows and
columns in the data set and we'll also
check the data types and the memory
usage
so I'll see
my data frame name that is DF underscore
tracks dot info
if I run it you can see here
if you mark there are total 5 lakh it is
6601 names or
the names of the songs present in the
data set while the rest all have 5 lakhs
86 672 so clearly there are total 71
song names or soundtracks missing from
our data set
and Below you can see the data types we
have float integer and object and then
you can see the memory usage
cool
now before I move ahead with our next
analysis I have another question for you
which artist or musician has the most
number of followers on Spotify I repeat
which artist or musician has the most
number of followers on Spotify please
put your answer in the comment section
below we would be happy to hear from you
now let's
move ahead and do our first major
analysis in this demo we are going to
find the 10 least popular
songs present in the Spotify data set so
I'll create a variable called sorted
underscore DF that will be equal to my
data frame name that is DF underscore
tracks dot I am going to use the sort
underscore
values function and say
my column name is popularity
so I am going to sort the values based
on the
popularity and then say
ascending equal to true
since I want
only the least popular songs
and then
I'm going to say
head of 10 which means I want the top 10
least popular songs now let's go ahead
and print sorted underscore dear if I
run it you can see
we have the list of
10 least popular songs on Spotify you
can see that popularity is zero
and you can see the names of the songs
some of them are
songs which are not an English language
and you can see the artist names as well
cool
now moving ahead
let's see some descriptive statistics
for the numerical variables that are
present in our column so I'll say DF
underscore tracks dot describe
which is the function to get some
descriptive statistics and I'm going to
use the transpose function after that
if I run it there you go so we have the
statistics about count mean standard
deviation
minimum value 25th percentile 50th
percent 75th percentile and the maximum
value for these columns like popularity
duration in milliseconds then we have
energy key loudness mode
cool but if you see this
popularity column the minimum value is 0
and the maximum value is
100 and you can see the 15th percentile
is 27 which is essentially the median
you have the standard deviation as
18.37 then similarly you can check for
the other features as well
cool
now
we'll see the
then most popular songs which are
greater than 90. so we are going to
check for the top 10 songs with
popularity greater than 90 let me show
you how to do it so in this cell I am
going to create a new variable called
most popular
and I'll say DF underscore tracks dot
this time I am going to use the
query function that is part of pandas
Library again
I'll use the
column that is popularity and we'll set
the condition popularity should be
greater than 90 I'll give a comma and
say
in place equal to false because I don't
want to change my original data frame
and then I'll say
sort underscore
values
and I'm going to sort it based on
popularity
in
descending order so I'll say
ascending equal to false
and then let's
take only the
top 10 popular songs so I'll say most
popular use square brackets
use square brackets and
will then pass the slicing operator and
say colon 10
now if I run this there you go so here
you can see the 10 most popular songs
that is present in our Spotify data set
first we have features by
Justin Bieber
Daniel Caesar and give on
then we also have a song name called
driver's license astronaut in the ocean
save your tears
we also have the business streets and
heartbreak anniversary
so these are the most popular songs that
are present in our data set based on the
popularity you can see Peaches has the
highest popularity with 100.
all right now moving to the next cell
so here we are going to set the index to
be release date column in the main data
frame so I am setting my index using the
set underscore index function I have
passed in my column name as release date
and I'm saying increase equal to True
which means I want to change it in my
original data frame and then I'm
changing the value to date time format
and let's print the head of the
data set
so you can see here we have successfully
changed our index now here you can see
instead of 0 1 2 3 we have the release
date column and the rest of the columns
are intact
cool
now let's move ahead
so suppose you want to check the artist
at the 18th Row in our data set you can
use the index location method for that
let me show you how to
filter only specific rows of information
from the data set I'll use my data frame
DF underscore tracks and using double
square brackets I'll say
by column name which is artists
and I'll use the index location method
and say let's say I want to check the
artist who is present
in the 18th Row in my data set so I'll
use ilock 18 if I run it the artist's
name is
with the voucher
cool
now let's move ahead we are going to
convert the duration in milliseconds to
just seconds so
if you see our data set we have a column
called duration in milliseconds so all
our songs are present in milliseconds
let's convert them into just seconds so
for that I'm using the Lambda function
and dividing the
values in
milliseconds by thousand so that they
get converted into just seconds
I have used in place equal to true so I
want to change it in my original data
frame
let's run it and do the necessary
changes all right
now we'll print the head of the data set
just to check the duration column so
I'll say DF underscore tracks Dot
duration
dot head
if I run it there you go so
you can see the values have now being
changed to just seconds
cool
I have the final quiz question for you
who has the most monthly listeners on
Spotify
please put your answers in the comment
section below we'd be glad to hear from
you
now coming to the next cell
so here we are going to create a first
visualization that is going to be a
correlation map
we are going to drop three unwanted
columns and those are key mode and
explicit and then we are going to apply
Pearson correlation method
now I have set my figure size to 14
comma 6 and then we are using the C bone
heat map function to create our
correlation map I have put the variable
that is
correlation underscore DF you can see
above we had created this and then I'm
setting annotation equal to true
so
this will write the data value in each
cell
I have set fmt equal to dot 1 G so this
is a string formatting code to use when
adding annotations then I have
set my vmin and V Max so these are the
values to Anchor the color map otherwise
they are inferred from the data and
other keyword arguments
cmap here stands for color map you can
just search for SNS cmap you will get
the documentation
so you can choose whichever
color palette or the color map you want
here I have used Inferno
and I have set my line bits and line
color finally I am giving a title to my
correlation map and I have set the
acetic labels let's go ahead and
run this to get our
first visualization
if I scroll down there you go we have
got a
nice
correlation map so here on the right
side you can see the scale it ranges
from -1 to plus 1 minus 1 means the
variables have least or negative
correlation while the values which are
above 0.0
means that the variables have a positive
correlation
now
here you can see there are
values like minus 0.7 for energy and
acousticness which means if the energy
is high the acousticness is Galileo
again for loudness and
say speakiness if the song is loud the
speechiness is low so there is negative
correlation but if you see
for energy and loudness there is really
high correlation between these two
variables you can see the value is 0.8
so if the song is loud this implies the
song has really high energy and vice
versa
now if you see for a few other variables
that is negative correlation between
there is negative correlation again
between
valence and acousticness similarly there
is positive correlation between energy
and balance which is 0.4
and even for danceability and balance
that is positive correlation which is
0.5
cool
so from the correlation heat map you can
note that acousticness appears to have a
strong negative correlation with energy
so if you see for acousticness and
energy there is a strong negative
correlation
and there is a moderately strong
positive relation between loudness and
popularity so if you see for popularity
and loudness the color is orange which
means it lies in this positive region
and there is also a moderately strong
positive relation between danceability
and balance so if you check for
danceability and balance here there is
a moderately strong positive correlation
all right
now let's move ahead we are going to
sample our data and take just 0.4
percent of the total data and will
create two regression plots using this
data so let me first sample my data so
I'll create a sample data frame
using my original data frame which is DF
underscore tracks and say
sample
I'm going to
use the int function and see 0.004
multiplied by the length of my original
data frame which is DF underscore
tracks
all right
now let's
run this
and will print
the length of my
sample data frame
to run it you can see
point
four percent of
my total data set is
2346 rows
cool
now we are going to create a regression
plot between loudness and energy now in
our correlation map we saw there was a
positive correlation between loudness
and energy which was pointed let's plot
it in the form of a regression line so
I'll use
PLT Dot
figure
I'll set my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 6.
I'll say SNS Dot
regression plot so I'm using the
function called reg plot
and I'll use my data as
sample underscore
TF
give a comma
and say
in my y-axis I'll have my column
loudness
and in the x axis we'll have
energy
I'll give a
color to
my
data variable let's say the color is C
then I'll set my
title to
loudness
versus
energy
let's say correlation
all right
let's make sure everything is
fine
now
will run and see a result
there you go
so you can see here clearly
there is a very high positive
correlation between loudness and energy
on the y-axis we have loudness and on
the x axis we have energy and you can
see
all the data points or the songs are
in One Direction so if the energy
increases the loudness of the song also
increases and similarly if the loudness
of the song decreases your energy of the
sound or the track also decreases so
there is a very high positive
correlation and you can see the
regression line here it has gone
and is increasing gradually
cool
now similarly I'll just copy this code
and we are going to see another
regression plot this time for two
different features
let's say we have
popularity in the
y-axis so I'll say popularity
and then in the x axis we have let's say
acousticness
foreign
to let's say B which stands for blue
and
will set the title to
popularity
versus
I'll have
because thickness
correlation
just scroll down and we'll run it to see
the result
there you go
so I have the
different points for the songs and here
you can see the regression line is
downwards which means if the
acousticness of the song increases the
popularity decreases and similarly if
the popularity increases acousticness
decreases you can see
the downward trend of the regression
line
all right
now in the next cell we are going to
create a new column called ear from our
release date column
and I have changed this to date time
format let me just run it cool
now after that
we are going to create a distribution
plot to visualize the total number of
songs in each year since 1922 that is
available on the Spotify streaming app
so I have used my c bond library and
dist plot function now one thing to
remember you need to update your c bond
library to
this version
if you haven't done it so use this
command pip install dash dash user C
burn and
the version
so here in the distribution plot
we are going to plot a histogram so I
have used kind equal to hist which
stands for histogram
let's run and see the result
okay so here you can see I have my
distribution plot so the plot tells us
that the
number of songs for each year in the
data set according to their release date
have increased in the recent years since
music became more accessible to people
globally with technological advancements
so earlier you can see there were very
few songs available in the
1920s later on the
number of songs increased rapidly and
now you can see we have a lot more songs
available for people to listen
cool
now
we are going to see the duration of
songs over the years for that again we
are going to create a bar plot so I'll
first create a variable called total
duration equal to DF underscore tracks
Dot
I'll use the duration column that we
created with seconds
and then
I am going to
set
my
my figure Dimensions so I'll use figure
underscore
dims for Dimensions equal to
18 comma
7 after that I'll have my
figure
access defined so I'll use the
matplotlab
sub plots function
and
I'll set the
figure size
equal to
my figure dimensions
and then
I'll say figure equal to SNS Dot I'll
use the
bar plot function
and say
my x axis to be
years
my Y axis will be
total duration or total underscore Dr
that we created here
I'll set my Axis equal to ax
and then
I'll set error width
equal to
false
let's set the title for my plot as
title equal to
your bosses duration
and finally I'll say plt.x text
I rotate it by
let's say 90 degrees
all right
let me just recheck once if everything
is fine and then we'll go ahead and run
it
my access error width title
okay let me just run it
we will see the result in a moment
if I scroll down
you can see we have the bar plot for the
different years and the duration of the
songs in seconds in the y-axis so
earlier in the 1920s you can see the
duration of the
sounds well less and literate increased
around late
1930s and this remained consistent until
2010 where the
duration was high but after 2010 you can
see the
duration of the songs have started
decreasing
now in the next cell
I am going to create a line plot to
analyze the average duration of the
solves over the years it is going to be
similar to
our bar plot does that now we are going
to visualize it in terms of a line
so I have my code ready
you can see here I've used my C bone
library and the line plot function in
the x-axis I have used and in the y axis
I have total duration I've set my title
to year versus duration and I'm rotating
my
X labels by 60 degrees let's run it and
we'll see the output
there you go now if I scroll down you
can see we have a nice
line plot and on the x-axis you have the
EOS and on the y axis we have the
duration we can see that the songs from
1920s to
1960s have comparatively shorter
duration since most of the songs tended
to be more singing based rather than
instrument Beast
after 1960s you can see the duration of
the songs started increasing until I
would say 2010 and in the present day
the duration of the songs have started
declining since the attention span of
the average listener is also declining
all right now let's move to our second
data analysis project which is based on
genres of the songs so I am importing my
data set using the pandas read
underscore CSV function I have given my
location and here I have my
data set name followed by the
extension of the
type so this is a CSV data set let's go
ahead and run it
okay now
let's print the first five rows of the
data set
I have
stored my data set in a data frame
called DF underscore genre
I'll use the head function to get the
first five rows of information
I'll hit shift enter to run it there you
go
you can see here I have my Joiner column
artist name track name track ID
popularity acousticness
duration in milliseconds again
and we have the rest of the other
columns that we saw in our first data
set just one thing to note here key is
present in terms of c d e c minor F
minor
and not in terms of numbers between 0 to
11.
now we'll see
the duration of the songs for different
genres
for that I am going to create a bar plot
so I'll start with setting the title for
my plot as
duration of
the Souls
in
different
genres
I'll use the
c bond Library
and
I'll set my
color palette to let's see
rocket
into the comma and say as C map equal to
true
this would be color palette
now
I'll say SNS Dot
bar plot in the y-axis I'll have
genre
and in the x axis I'll have
my duration column which is in
milliseconds so duration underscore MS
and then I pass my data frame using the
data argument
so I'll say data equal to DF dot Journal
next
will set the x labels so I'll say PLT
dot X label
let's see my X label is
duration in
milliseconds
and then
so I'll see PLT Dot
by label as follows
now let's go ahead and
run this
there you go so here you can see we have
the different genres on the y-axis and
on the x-axis you have the duration in
milliseconds
and if you see the graph
for
classical genre and for
songs that belong to World genre the
duration of the songs are
more compared to
other genres now if you check for
children's music genre the duration is
less or the least
cool
and finally
we'll move to our
last demo where we'll see the top 5
genres by popularity
so I'll see
sns.set underscore
Style
I'll set my
style to
dark
grid which will be my background
and then I'll see PLT Dot
figure I'll set my
figure
size
to
10 comma 5
then I'll create a variable called
famous
since I want to take only the
most popular songs based on the genre so
I have created a variable called famous
and I'll pass my data frame name that is
DF underscore
genre
and I'll sort the values based on my
popularity column
so I'll see
popularity
and I want to
sort it in descending order so I'll say
ascending equal to false
and I'll take the
first
10 values I'll tell you the reason why
I'm taking the first 10 values and not
5.
then I'll say SNS Dot
bar plot
and in the y axis I'll have
genre
in the x axis will have
popularity
and I'll keep a comma
and using the data argument I will save
my data to be famous which is this
variable that we created
and then I'll set my
title
as
top five
genres
by
popularity
all right
now the reason why I took head of 10 is
because there are a few genres which are
repetitive so if you see this we have
children's music appearing twice so
hence we have taken 10 instead of 5 let
me just go ahead and run it
there you go
so here if I scroll down you can see I
have my top 5 genres based on the
popularity so we have dance pop rap
hip-hop at reggaeton so these are the
five genres which are most popular based
on the data that we have collected
from Spotify
all right
welcome to the simply in a YouTube
channel in this session we will learn
how to create a QR code and then learn
how to decode it but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel like the tutorial and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
and before starting let us have a simple
question to brush upon our knowledge and
please answer in the comment section
below we'll update the correct answer in
the pin comment
and your question is what does QR in QR
code stand for and your options are
quick record
quick response quick review or quick
restore you can pause the video give it
a thought and answer in the comment
section
now moving on let's learn a few facts
about QR codes
QR codes are quick response codes used
to store information that can used to
make a call send a message or email open
a website or even redirect to a location
and a QR code can store up to 4296
connectors or 7089 digits in a single
code making it viable to hold large
amounts of content
let's see how QR code is generated on
web
we will open the browser and search for
any free website that is used to
generate QR code we will search QR code
generator
and we can enter any URL or any text to
just create a QR code
so we will write simply learn
and you can see your QR code has been
generated you can download it copy it
and send to anyone and you can just scan
it and see that accept pillar to check
it we can also
open a QR Scanner in a mobile phone
for that we'll just write QR Scanner in
our Google Chrome or any browser
and open any free one and just
scan it
you can see that it has scanned and
decoded it as simply learned what we
have encoded it in it
so let's move and create our own QR code
scanner using python
for that first we'll create a folder
and name it as creating
QRS scanner
and inside it we will open the command
prompt
and
open Visual Studio code
I have chosen the visual studio code as
my data you can choose any like Jupiter
notebook
foreign
and inside I will create the file
and name it is keywords Canon Dot
py
and now the first thing we have to do is
import the python modules
so for that
the first module we would be importing
is python QR code
that will write the command pip install
QR code
as you can see that it states that the
requirement is already satisfied I have
already installed the python package you
can use this command to install that and
if you face any issues just comment down
in the comment section and we'll get
back to you
now
moving to our Visual Studio code
we will import the package
import
QR code
and now we'll use the function make to
make a QR code for that we will write QR
code
dot make
and inside we will just
copy any URL link or any command any
contact information or anything
so we will go to our browser
oh
please open the YouTube
and search for creating a virtual
assistant
in Python
I will
copy this URL
and paste it
in the make function
so that will
get the QR code
of our own video that is creating
virtual assistant using python
now we'll save
this into a variable and name it as
my QR
and get this variable saved as a PNG
image so that we can get it in a folder
as a folder only contains the python
file
now
when we save this
that's PNG file
now you have to save your code and just
run it
you can see that my QR dot PNG has been
generated
so just open it you can see that you
have got your QR code generated
and you can also
make some options that is scale I will
set the scale
equal to 8
let's save the file
and run it
and you can see the clear code scanner
now
we will
user mobile phone you can use any mobile
phone Android or iPhone and just check
it
using any QR code scanner that is
available on your browser or you have
any other app you can use that
I'm using a free version on my web
and that is QR code scanner dot in
and on scanning I quote the link and
when I open it
I am redirected to the video that is how
to create a virtual assistant using
python
so we have successfully made the QR code
scanner
now we have made the key report scanner
and we can also decode it using the
python libraries so for that
we have to install two more modules
that is price bar and pillow
put that we'll write the command clip
install
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied as I have already
installed these modules and we have also
installed
pip install
this is also installed and if you face
any issue in installing these packages
just comment down in the section we will
get back to you
now moving on to our Visual Studio code
now we'll
use the class decode first we will
import the packages only
from
price per
Dot
by his part
import the decode class
and from
below
import the image class
now
moving to decode that you are good we
will use the decode class comprise bar
and use the image class
and
open our PNG file that is what we named
as myqr.png
foreign
equal to
and now we'll print what is decoded what
would be decoded and we'll just get the
value for that
we will
get the information at the zero index
that is data
we will record it
in ASCII
so yeah now we'll
save our code
and run it
here you can see that you have got this
link that is decoded
what you have encoded in the QR code
scanner
and now I have the question for you
to just check whether a QR code is
working or not now you have to make
the task to just scan the QR code and
see whether it's working or not
put that we will create my
qr1
equal to QR code
dot make
and inside
so we will get the link for our website
now we'll save the file and run it
and I get also
as an image for that we'll write my qr1.
save
and the name of the file
and add a scale of seven let's save the
file
run the file here you can see that the
QR code has been generated
and
we have get it
paste it for you guys
so just scan the QR code and check
whether it's working or not
just scan it and answer as yes or no in
the comment section below
if it's working just answer it yes else
no
hi everyone
welcome to the simply learn YouTube
channel in this session
we will create a QR code scanner using
python but before we begin if you love
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel like the tutorial and hit the
Bell icon to now miss an update
and before starting a project let us
have a simple question to brush upon our
knowledge
and please answer in the comment section
below and we will update the correct
answer in the paint comment and the
question is
what is the minimum decodable size for a
QR code scanner
that is QR code only
and your options are
1.5
by 1.5 centimeter or one by one
centimeter or 1.75 by 1.75 centimeter
or 2 by 2 centimeter
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section
and moving on now we'll start a project
that is create a QR codes scanner
for that first of all create a folder
and name it as
creating QR code scanner
and inside we will
open the command prompt
and write a command code space period
and press enter to open an idea that is
I am using the visual studio code you
can use any IDE
as you are comfortable with
and we'll create a file and name it as
QR Scanner Dot py
and now the first thing we will do is
install the modules that will require
for the project
for that you will open the command
prompt
uh the first module we will install is
opencv
and you can search for the command in
the web or if you know you can just
write it down and press enter for that I
will show you how to get for the command
you can just type opencv
Python and press enter
you will see the first link that is
opencv python
that is the original documentation and
you can see the command here just copy
it
direct to the command prompt
and paste the command here
adjustments enter
as you can see that it states that the
requirement is already satisfied I have
already installed the opencv module you
can just type in the
command and press enter it will just
install it for you
and that's second one module we have
installed is
Pius bar
let's open the old official link
and you can see the command here pip
install files bar just copy it
and redirect back to the command prompt
and paste your command here
and just press enter
it will do the work for you as it is
stating that it's the requirement is
already satisfied I have already
installed the pass by module you can do
that just just writing the command and
press enter
now moving to our Visual Studio code
now we'll start with our code and we'll
first we will import the packages
the first package will import is that is
the CV2 that is the opencv
then next we will import the D code
class from the Pi's bar module
so for that we will write the command
for decode
no
the first thing we will do is we will
create a variable and as the opencl
module to make the video capture
function work for us
for that we will create the variable and
name it as
cm
and the command would be CV2 Dot
video capture
now
we will set the window this is the
window that would be reflected when we
just make our camera equal to true
that is camera is always defaulted as
false you have to make it true to get it
pop it on your window screen
and for that we will set the size
cam dot set
and
first we'll set the width and we'll set
the width as 5.
and
set the pixels as 640
and now we will set the height
cam root set
and height as 6 and pixel glass seems
um
480.
as you wish you can set it as
and now we will make the camera equal to
true
as it is
a button for a camera and it's been
defaulted set as false we have to make
it true
now while camera
is equal to equal to true
we will read the QR code scanner we will
treat the QR code that we will show in a
front camera
so for that we will write the command
when camera equal to equal to true that
is when the camera is open
we would get
two things that is success and the frame
and that would be equal to
cam dot read
it will read the frame that would be
shown into our camera
and the success is it will return the
Boolean value that is 10 and the frame
is it would read the frame as captured
by a front camera and decode it
now to decode it
we will run a group
for
I
we will make it as the code
and inside we will pass the frame
that is the frame captured by our camera
and
print the
type
that is which type it is that is its QR
code or its barcode or its uh any other
code
so it will just capture the frame and it
will return put print it as which type
it is
now
we'll print
what we will decode from the QR code so
that to write the command
code.data what data is stored in it
and we'll use the function report
and the membrane we would be using is
utfdate
oh sorry we have
taken it as I
and now
after we have read the frame and
recorded it we wanted to sleep for some
time for that we will just import the
time module
and you can install the time module from
the date time module you can just write
the command
pip install date time or you can just
search on the Chrome or any browser
about the date time module and python
you can just write date time space
python space module you will be just
directed to the main documentation and
you will get the command there and you
can just copy it and paste it in the
command prompt
and the rest would be done for you as I
have already installed it I will import
the time module
and now make this Frame sleep
for about six seconds
and now
we want
to make or show the camera
uh owner window it should be popped up
and we should be able to see it for that
we will
use the openc module
and write the command
I am sure
and we will name the
camera window with our QR code scanner
you can name it
anything as you want
so I will name it as r
QR underscore
underscore scanner
and the next thing we will do is pass
the frame in it
and
we will just write another command that
would be
weight key function
that would be we were using the open CM
module and the weight key function
and
this would be used to
capture the frame after the three
seconds
so this is our code
we will save it
and make it run
okay we quote an error
okay this area is due to as I was using
the front camera for recording and it
was not able to capture the frames
also have
Switched Off the front camera the webcam
and now we will save the file
and run it
now you can see that the webcam has
opened up and now we'll
show it a QR code
and you can see that it has concluded
its data as https
www.simplant.com I have created the QR
code in my mobile phone
and made it available to the webcam and
it has
showed us the output as http www
simplydan.com we can just
press on click and
click on the right button of the mouse
and we will be directed to the link
hi everyone I am and welcome to the
simplyline YouTube channel in this
session we will create a MP3 player
using python but before we begin if you
love watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel like the tutorial and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
before we start I hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues to let us know in the chat
section and before starting first we
should have a look on what we would
create
for that we will move to our code
simply run this
you can see that the take into window
has appeared and this is a media player
we have named it simply music player we
have the GIF that would be running
continuously
and we have the browse music button
which will direct you to the any folder
you want to open that have the MP3
player files
I have selected this folder it has four
files
and will play Hey there
you just click on that and click on the
play button
it will play the music
now just click on the post button
so this is our MP3 player
so before starting the coding
I have a simple question for you guys
so moving to that
so the question is who wrote the poem
Zen of python
and your options are
Tim honestly
Tim Peters
ome
or Kevin Goldsmith
you could see the poem here also you can
easily get this one you just have to
write import this in your interpreter
and just press enter you will get the
poem
so please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the print comment
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section
so moving to a code
first we will create a folder
and name it as
create
MP3 player
using python
and inside
you will open the command prompt
and write the command code space
sorry period and press enter
this will open up the editor that is
Visual Studio code
if you want you can use any editor you
have hands on animator you can use
anyone
and here we will create a file and we
will name it as player.py only
and we would require music also for that
and some gifs and some images for our
buttons you can easily
get those images from any
free images website or you can just get
them draw in the paint or photoshop them
you can
arrange them from anywhere
so we have our picks in this folder
so we'll copy all these and we have the
music folder
it has four files
and this is the corporate free music so
we can play on YouTube
we will
paste this enough folder only
that is create MP3 player using python
moving back to our Visual Studio code
the first thing is we should install the
python packages before starting our
coding
so we would require the take into
package it is already installed as you
install the python if you want to
install it again just
go to a terminal
and write the command with install
TK
as you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied so you I don't have to
install it again
you can install it just writing the
command and press enter
and the next we have to install is the
pi game to import the mixer class
sorry the command would be
pip install Pi game
and press enter
you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied I have already
installed the pi game module you just
have to write the command and press
enter you will get them installed very
easily in the next module we need is
time
so you can install the date time module
or the time module
it's your wish
so we have
to write the command
web install date time
so it was not installed
on my system
it's been installed and
it doesn't have some
classes in the module it has installed
them and it says the requirement is
already satisfied for other modules okay
so now
and the last is
OS module
let's turn the
this window is not going so we will just
go to the terminal
just get a terminal
and write the point here yep
install
OS
and press enter
so it will install the OS module for you
it is doing for me right now
and we would be using the take into
module to create the GUI and tick enter
is a python module that is used to
develop graphical user interface and as
I told you there's no need to install it
it is the part of the standard python
Library so it would be installed as you
install python on your system
foreign
you just import our packages
first we'll import
time and that we will use an
to get the GIF setup in our GUI
so we'll import the time and from tick
enter
we will put all the classes
and
so let's import the field dialog
and from PI game we'll import the mixer
class to
get a buttons functioning to make our
mp3 music video music
like MP3 file to start playing to pause
it and to resume it again
so for that I'll write the command
from PI game
import mixer
it's still downloading
till then we'll import the OS also
it will get it
download it and install for us
so first of all create the tick enter
video window
for that we'll write the simple command
root
equal to
TK
and circular brackets and
get the command root Dot
main Loop
and if we save it and run it
I'm sorry it was downloading
[Music]
let's pause the downloading okay we'll
see it again so you can see that that TK
enter window has appeared on the screen
it's the output
it's a simple take into video now we
will add functions to it we will add
size to it we will add background color
and we'll do other functionings to that
so tick enter provides many methods and
one of them is geometry method and it is
used to set the dimensions of the take
enter window as we have seen
so we will just position the main window
on the user's desktop we will use the
command root dot geometry for that
set the size as
485
cross
that is X only
and for y-axis it would be 700
and now
we would get it
290 points shifted from x-axis
and
10 points shifted from y-axis
and we have to put them in inverted
commas
we will save the file and run it again
you can see that the take into window
has changed its geometry and it has set
the x-axis as
485 and Y X is at 700 and when it
appeared it was
290
SC what dimension it uses it was 290
points apart from the x-axis and 70
sorry 10 points apart from y-axis yeah
219 10.
so now we'll give the title to this
window
for that we will write the command root
dot title
and just write that item
21 and give it you can give it anyway
so we will name it as simply music
player
and now we'll use the configure function
so take into configure function it is
used on any widget to change settings
that you may have applied earlier or
haven't applied yet
so for that we'll write the command
root dot configure
and we will set the background color
so
right
background
equal to an inverted commas we'll write
the hexa code
for this color
so we are setting the gray color
for a background we'll save it
and run the file so you can see the
output
so we have set the simply music player
as the root title for taking top window
and we have configured background color
right screen
so moving on
now we will use the resizable method it
is used to allow tick enter root window
to change its size according to the
user's need
as well as it will prohibit like it will
not allow you to change the size of the
window
the window you just sew on the screen
that was a take enter window so we will
use the resizable function and we will
prohibit will not allow anyone to change
its dimensions
so for that we will write the command
root dot resizable
volts comma
for it so in this sizeable method user
can pass either positive integer or true
to make them into resizable to make
window non-new sizable user can just
pass zero or false we have passed faults
so our window won't be resizable
and save this file and run it again you
can see now we can't resize it
so first I will command this command
and save it and run it for you guys
you can see that
you can resize it now but after we write
this command
no one is allowed to resize The Tick
enter window
we'll save this
and run it you can see
now no one is allowed to resize this
window you won't get any option
so now
moving on as you have
seen the previous dimensions and the
demonstration of the simply music player
will create
as same as that only
so we will place the GIF a label here
and place the buttons on that and
beneath that we will just create a label
and browse all the file steps
foreign
so we'll start with the frame
for that we'll write the command
first we'll create a
variable and name it as lower frame and
a frame is a rectangular region on the
screen
it can be used as a foundation class to
implement complex widgets it is used to
organize a group of widgets so we'll be
creating a frame and we'll Place
different buttons on that that would be
the play button post button and the stop
button and the volume
that is just the image
we'll place the volume image there
so lower frame equal to
we will write frame to get a frame
and inside we will pass root
and get a background color as white
that will write the hexagon
hash and the hexa code for white color
is
FFF and that is six times you can go and
search on the web about the hexagons
like which color is associated with
which hexa code or you can just write
the simple name of the colors you can
get your background set as well that
also
and here we'll set the width for our
frame
so width will set as 485 only it should
cover the whole window
in X dimensions
and for height we'll set it as 180.
we'll create the same simply music
player as I have shown in new as I've
shown the demonstration earlier
so we have set the height as 180
so
now
we will use the place method that allows
you to explicitly set the position and
size of a window or anything like we are
just creating a frame so it would use to
position and size of the frame
it would be either in absolute terms or
relative
to another window so for that
we will write the command
first
will get the frame
that is stored in the lower underscore
frame
variable
and use the place function
to place it in a decanter window
and write the dimensions for that we
would start from x equal to zero
and paste it at y equal to
400.
now we'll save the file
and run it
okay we have
wanted to already opened so I closed it
you could see that this is the frame we
have set it at x equal to 0 and y equal
to 400 so it would measure
as y equal to 0 here and y equal to 400
here
so we have placed the frame now we'll
place the buttons on that
and first we will set
a logo for simply music player
that we have
enough folder
so this is the logo for our simply music
player we will set it
so that will write the command
first we will create a variable and name
it as image icon
and here we will use photo image
so
click after writing in this photo image
it would like it would create a photo
image object and you can use it
in other widgets that accept an image
argument that is some buttons they
accept image argument photo image
argument
you can use the images there also and
the image object is returned by the
photo image function
it's the easy to display a picture in
Python however the photo image class
only supports the GIF and PGM PPM
formats which is a concern jpeg jpg and
PNG are the formats that are most often
used
so now
in the photo image object we will just
write the location of the file
as we have it in the same folder so we
will write the name only that is logo
space PNG
and the extension that is PNG only
now
to get it set as icon photo we'll write
the command root dot icon photo
and
past argument as false comma
image underscore icon
now we'll save the file
first we'll close the previous one
and run it
you could see that
the logo has been placed there
so
now moving on
we will create the menu
you will again run the file
so here we will create the menu to
browser music
so for that first
we'll create a variable menu
and create a photo image object
and
write the file name only as here we
don't have to set the part
as all the images are in the same folder
only
so for this we will use the menu.png
that is the white inch I will show you
what you will get as output
to
we have to place this in inverted commas
and now for this we will create a label
so in Tinker in dig into some widgets
can display an image such as label and
button
is a widget that is used to implement
display boxes where you can place text
or images
so
we will create a label here
and paste the menu.png image on that
so to create it you write the command we
have started with label and inside we
will pass root
and the image
we will write the variable name here
that is menu
and now we will place it
will position it in our take into window
so for that write the command please
and inside
write x equal to zero
and
the dimensions
okay
so y would be
580
and would also set the width and height
for that
and the width would be 485 so it could
cover
the whole
sorry I didn't try to width
that would be 485 and now we will set
the height
I will set as 100 only guys
it would be
in the bottom section
so
you don't get much height so we'll save
this
and run the file
you can see that we have created a label
here also and a label here also and we
have
pasted the white image place the white
image on that level
so this is the label that is of the
white color and now we have placed
another image on
another label
so I will show you what
purpose we have done that
so first we will create a button
that would be for the browse music
now it will write
first pass root and
then what text we want to show on that
button
that would be
house music
and then we will set the width of that
button
that would be 59
and then
would set its height
and
set the height as 1 only
and now you you can set
phone tool so like which font you want
to get displayed on that button
for that
you just have to write want
equal to
and start the circular brackets
and inside you can write
which font you want I will go with
calibri
and font size would be 12.
and I want it bold
so in inverted commands I will write
vault
and outside this circular bracket
I will set the foreground color
that is the text color only foreground
color
as black
you can write the hexa code we just
write the name of the column
and we will set the background color as
white for this button
use hexapod here
that is 60 MFS
and now
what function does this button do
so it will show us the music that
would be stored in our folder
we will browse the folder and it will
show us the MP3 for MP3 files that would
be contained in that folder
so in command we would write the name of
the function that we will create to get
all the MP3 files
so we will
finish and we're also calling
now outside this bracket
will place it
and showing error as we have not
to find the add music function so we'll
place it
x equal to zero
y
equal to 550.
no
and scroll bar
so that when we get Ola MP3 files we can
just browse just by scrolling
so we can get all the MP3 files on that
small window we will create now
so we'll set the scroll bar for that
for that write the command
scroll bar
and inside
you get off
play music
so first
will
set another frame
and we will
get it as
gray color only with that
we will write the command
frame underscore music
we will create a frame
and inside will pass root
and set the Border equal to 2
and
relief
equal to Rich
so we have set the relief equal to Rich
so relief is a style and it's a style of
a widget that refers to certain
simulated 3D effects and we are giving
the 3D fact to a button and that effect
is rich
so we will see that but before that we
have two
get a add music defined
showing a soup
no you won't get the taken to window as
we have to
Define the
and music
so we have created the frame and now we
will place this and after that we will
create that music
function
for this we will write
name underscore music
that
moves the variable name and
period place
and now we will position it in a tick
enter window
so we want it at x equal to zero
equal to
so we would place it at
585
and we'll so Define its width and height
so width would be 485
and height
100
yeah
so we were creating the scroll bar
so first we'll create the scroll bar and
then Define the add music function
so now we will set the scroll bar in the
frame music
variable as we want the scroll bar in
that frame
I will show you in the demo only after I
create that music function
so first we'll create the add music
function only
so we will create it here
and Limitless add music
ringtone first you want that it should
have path and here we would use
file dialog
so it would pop out the dialog box
to the directory where which we would
assign or take it to
next
foreign
path
change
directory
pass the path here
Source equal to
I stored
list of directory
part
okay
foreign
so first if the path we have chosen
and here we will change the path and in
this songs variable
we'll get the list of all the songs
in that directory
and now
we will
create
mode run a for Loop
or song in songs
but all the songs we got
f
Ong ends with
MP3
that is total MP3
foreign
playlist
Dot
insert
group pass
and process
and
pass the song
so we will
get this playlist variable working in
another function that would be the play
music function
so it should play the music for that
will
create the function
play
music
create a variable name
that would be music underscore name and
inside
playlist Dot get and make it active
and now
we will
print
music name
and this would be printed in the
terminal
first
active that is which music is playing
and now I'm going to use the mixer class
and music Dot node
function and pass the playlist
the function node get and get it as
effective
and now
here Will
complete
now we are getting errors for playlist
so first
create the playlist variable that would
be
having all the songs in that
so with that will write
a variable playlist
and that would be equal to
it would have the list box
equal to
list box
and inside we'll pass the
frame that we have created for music
and set its width
that would be equal to 100
and now we will set the font for that
so
you can see all the names of the MP3
files in the same font only
and for
that would write
Times New Roman
and set the font sizes
10.
and outside this bracket
will set the background color for the
playlist
pull that right PG
and we will set it as gray only
so
I have support for degree is
3333
and that is six times
we'll close the inverted commas
and set the foreground color
and the gray only
now
select background
that would be of the light blue color
set the cursor
and send to
I will explain you
what this means
it will set the Border
equal to 0 only
scroll command
that would be equal to
light blue
now we will set the
y scroll command
that would be equal to scroll dot set
so it should be used to scroll
so we have set the cursor equal to N2
that means that it would convert to hand
when we scroll on the list box
that is when we would try to select any
of the MP3 player files it will show us
the hand cursor
and
the background color is light blue we
have set and scroll command equal to
scroll load set
okay now we will configure it
okay
let me have some errors we will resolve
them and we will see the output also
just after this
so first we will configure the scroll
bar
so that will use variable only scroll
load config
and inside
we will
have the command
equal to playlist
Dot
to buy View
so we should have in the y-axis only
and now
go back the scroll bar
okay shift and right
and fill the y axis
for that will write fill
equal to y
and now
we will
pack the playlist
playlist dot pack
replace it
decide equal to right
and it should
build
both the sides
it should be filled
so that will write the command
which I cannot appear after keyword
arguments
okay
we'll get it sorted
save the file
run it
so you can see that
we have the browse music button here and
if we click it we have the functioning
it will
select the folder
create MP3 player and this is the folder
that is music and we'll select it it has
four files
I will show you in that also so this is
the folder it has four files
it is displaying us all the four files
and you can see that we have the cursor
as hand here that is we have set it as
hand to
so now
we will
do other functionings that is place the
JF run it and place the buttons so first
we'll place the buttons
and run it
so for that
after this Frame music will start with
the buttons
so first we'll create the
play button for that we will create a
variable and name it as button play
and we will use a photo
a picture
put that button that will create a photo
image object
and pass the file for it
and we have that file name play1.png
so we'll just write the name of that
file in inverted commas
and now
we will
set the functioning
set the pattern will pass out
and the image
is equal to
the variable we have set it for that
that is
button
play
skeptical play
and
we'll set the background color for the
button
that would be white only because we have
the white label here
so it would
be perfect for that and I will set the
Border
that would be equal to zero
and
okay we have to place it inverted commas
else it would be
functioning as a comment Only We have
set the border that is equal to zero now
height
okay
hht
oh so just forward the spanning of
height
okay so I have to declare the height
first
so we will
get these buttons in 16 to 60 Dimensions
only we'll set the height as 60 and
width
also S60
and now we would set the command for
this button so what functioning should
it do
for that
we will write the function name
that is play music
and
now we will place this
at x equal to
215
and y equal to
487.
and we have created the play music
function above
you can see that it has the functioning
to play the music
we have used the mixer.music.lord
from the pi game
and it would get the playlist and the
active contents there and it would play
so we are done with a play button
we'll save it and run the file
dip into window is opened
first of all goes right
started
first we'll browse so this was the
folder getting music let's select this
folder you can see we have these four
files we'll click on the one and just
click on the play button
okay uh we forgot to add one functioning
so first
we will
create all these buttons and then add
all other functionings
now we will create the second button
that would be the stop button
put that
you will create a variable and name it
as button stop
and here also we'll create a photo image
object
dude
pass file and inverted commas
we have stop1.png for this
so we'll just write the file name
and in the next line we will Define the
functioning of this button
so inside button will pass root
and image
that is the variable
button stop
and set the background color
equal to White only
and that would be in the inverted commas
and
now we'll set its border
that would be zero
and height and width would be 60 only
and after that we will set its command
that would be
mixer Dot
music
dot stop so we are using the mixer
ask the music class inside that and the
stop function
and now we'll place this
taken to window with that we'll write
the dimensions for that x equal to 130
and y equal to 487
so we have created the stop button
we will save this and run the file
you can see that the stop button is
also displaying on a ticket window
and now
we will make our third button
that would be the pause button
for that we'll use the pose one PNG this
is the image
so for that
you can just
copy these things
place it here
so button
pause equal to photo image and we will
use the image
pose one dot PNG
and
create it
we've only as we have set all others as
big
so button pause background color white
water zero right 60 with 60 command it
would be mixer dot music dot pose
and we'll place it at
300 comma 487
we'll save this file
and run it
you can see that we have the pause
button
displayed here
now
we will get the volume button Note the
volume button just as image
so this is the image volume.png
we will
get it too
so for that we will create a variable
volume one
and create a photo
image object
and set the file location
and the location is
already placed in the same folder so
we'll just write the name of the file
that is volume.png
and that would be in the inverted commas
and now
we will place this
at
x equal to 20
and
y equal to 487
now we'll save this
and run the file
so we are having some errors
okay uh
we contactly use the place here
first
create another variable and create a
label for this image
so for that
to use panel
and equal to
sign will pass root comma
that is equal to
volume one
and now
we will use the place
and place it at
x equal to
it was and
300 and
why would peace
that would be 487.
so now we'll save this file and run it
you can see
okay
we have made a mistake here
so
it should be here so X would be less it
would be around 20 and Y would be same
for that only
so we'll change that
save this
and run the file again
yeah you can see that we have the volume
image
we have the play button the post button
and the stop button so we'll get the job
working for us
and now we will
get our GF working but before that we
will
make the mixer initialize so that uh
buttons they should function that is
play pose and stop
so we've imported the mixer class so we
will initialize it
I will save this and run the file
now you can browse the music
click on the any MP3 file and
click on the play button
you can hear that the music is playing
so I will pause it
and now we will start with the
functioning of our gif
so we have to cut the previous part
and now
start with frame count
so the frame count of rjf is 30 and we
will
store it in a variable
and now we'll create another variable
as frames and inside
start with
square brackets and create a photo image
object
and inside will pass the file
the GI file
the name of the file is A1 dot JF
and here we have to specify the format
of the file
put that you write format
equal to
in
commas
chair
[Music]
index
and we'll set the index
and
I
so we would be using the list
comprehension here
now we will run the loop
so for that right for
I
in
and use the range
on the frame count
so what we will do is
the GIF has so many images in that so we
have to run a loop so it would again
repeat itself as the frame count would
be equal to the count as the images
would be repeated in a loop we will set
the count equal to 0 and repeat it again
so for that
now we'll create a function
and name it as update
inside will pass a variable ID
create a variable with name frame and
inside
we will pass
IND variable
names
and as
this image would be displayed
we will increment
the Indy variable
and if
IND
is equal to equal to frame count that is
if it has displayed all the images in
the gif
we will set it at zero and run it again
and would set the jfn label so
we will configure it
and we have to define the label also
so for that
right label
equal to
label inside will pass the root
and now we'll configure it
and pass image
equal to what
frame we have
currently click
and now
we will use the after function
and pass 40 milliseconds so that
the animation would start again
and pass the update function
the current IND
and now we will place the label
and x equal to 0 and y equal to zero
and again we will run the after function
and pass zero milliseconds and the
update function
zero frames
okay
let's find this
if statement only
okay first we have to
place the label statement about no
no
we are done with a gif
save this
and then the file
so we are getting an error here
okay
so
subtitude
okay then save this file and run it
again
okay
encode displayed
so we have this label above
just browse the files select the folder
and click on any file and just click on
the play button you can see that when
MP3 player is working
and just set the UI again
you close it
or you could stop it
so we will
get this
downwards
okay let's try to move the
buttons
now we'll save the file
and click on run button
you can see that the GIF has taken love
whole frame
and now I'll browse the files
and selected the folder and our if
statement will find the MP3 files and
click on the file
foreign
[Music]
so I will share the code link with you
in the description
hello everyone I am and welcome to
Simply learn today we will take you
through the Hands-On lab demo of how you
can create a speech to text or speech
recognition system using python
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them I am
repeating again before we start I hope
the screen is clearly visible and the
audio is fine if yes please type in yes
if there are any issues do let us know
in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
yeah until then let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
I'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
it I think we can get started
so in today's session we will go through
what is a speech recognition system
moving forward we will see how speech
recognition system works after that we
will create a speech recognition system
using python
we will perform different function and
create speech recognition system using
different python libraries before we
move on to the programming part let's
discuss what is a species recognition
system first and proceed further for the
same
what is a speech recognition system
a program capacity to convert spoken
language into written language is known
as a speech recognition system also
known as automatic series recognition
computer voice recognition or speech to
text despite being sometimes confused
with voice recognition speech
recognition focus on converting speech
form a verbal to a text format whereas
voice recognition only aims to
distinguish the voice of a certain
person
foreign
speech recognition are two distance
Technologies and they shouldn't be
confused
to recognize word in spoken language
speech recognition is used voice
recognition uses biometrical
Technologies to recognize a specific
person by their voice
so after knowing what is speech
recognition system let's move forward
and see how does speech recognition
system work
peace recognition in Python works with
algorithm that perform linguistic and
acoustic modeling acoustic modeling is
used to recognize phonetics in our
speech to get the more significant part
of speech as words and sentences space
recognition start by taking the sound
energy produced by the person speaking
and converting it into the electrical
energy
with the help of microphone it then
converts the electrical energy from
analog to digital and finally to the
text
it breaks the audio data down into
sounds and it analyzes the sound using
algorithm to find the most probable word
that fits that audio
all of this is done using natural
language processing NLP and neural
networks
hidden Markov models can be used to find
temporal patterns in speech and improve
accuracy so here is one question for you
guys I will give you one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answer is given by you are right
or wrong
I'm repeating again so here is one
question for you guys I will give you
exactly one minute for this you can
comment or you can give answer in the
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong
so the question is
which of the following is the correct
extension for the python file
I'm repeating again which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C Dot py and option D dot p
so let us know your answer in the
comment section below
so I'm starting a timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section do let me
know your answers please I kindly ask
that everyone take part in this to make
this live session exciting
so I am starting the timer
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answer is given by you are right
or wrong so the question is which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
37 seconds remaining
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C dot py option D dot p
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
I currently asked that everyone take
part in this to make the life session
exciting
you have 15 seconds remaining
and seconds more
which of the following is the correct
extension of the Python file
three two one after that allotted time
has passed Those Who provided the
correct or response will receive as
response and those Who provided the
incorrect response will receive one
okay so now let's move to our
programming part to create a speech
recognition system using python so first
we will open a command prompt to write a
command to open Jupiter notebook so here
we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you can select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating speech
recognition system
so here we will write
first let me remain rename this
speech peacock
so first I will import import
teach
underscore
recognition
and second import
S three
press enter
so the incredibly attention I repeat the
incredibly extensible speech recognition
Library serves as a wrapper for a number
of well-known speech apis the speech
recognition Library includes default API
key for one of these the Google web
speech API hard coded that implies that
you can start moving without needing to
register for a service
and python project would benefit greatly
from using the speech recognition
package due to its versatility and
usability
and then pyts X3 a python text to speech
conversion library is called pyts X3
it is compatible with python 2 and
Python 3 and work offline unlike
competing libraries to obtain a
reference to a pyts X3 engine instance
an application calls the pytts X3 init
it is very user-friendly program that
turns type text to into speech
so moving forward let's write code for
actual speech recognition system
so here I will write
Sr equals to speech
underscore
recognition
Dot
recognizer
R must be Capital here
that I will write with
speech
underscore
recognition
dot microphone
source
2.
then colon
yeah
here
I will write print
right here okay silence
please
then I will write here Sr dot adjust
underscore for underscore
ambient
underscore noise
then Source 2 comma duration
equals to 2.
okay
then enter
then I will print something like
now
please
something like that
then I will write here audio
to
equals to Sr Dot listen
source
2.
and here I will write for text equals to
Sr
Dot
recognize
okay
underscore
Google
audio
two
then here I have to print in small
letters
in lower case so I will write here text
equals to text
dot lower
just
then here I will write print
it you say
Plus
text
everything look great
so I recognize there is a machine
ability to listen to spoken words and
identify them
you can then use a speech recognition in
Python to convert the spoken words into
text make a query or a give a reply you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words
like every time the recognized speech
from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the edges for
ambient noise this one for ambient noise
the backlog parameter of the listen
function allow a quiz size to be
specified it will listen to what we are
speaking or saying
this recognize Google
a function on the recognizer class
which you have now developed will be
used to query the Google web speech API
and convert spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
python built-in function lower is mostly
used to handle strings
the lower method converts each Capital
character in The provided string to
lowercase before returning the lower
caste string hit accept no arguments it
returned to the original text if the
supplied string has no capital letters
now let's check whether it's working or
not so I will run it yeah Renault
hello how are you doing
yeah you can see hello how are you doing
printed
so let me try another one
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so here you can see subscribe to Simply
on YouTube channel and press that Bell
icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn is printed
so a speech to text is working fine
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any queries
regarding any code or you have any
questions just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
now moving forward what if you want that
system we'll write what we are saying
and speak that too
this will be printed and now moving
forward what if you want the system will
write what we are saying and speak that
too
so for that we will write a small line
of code
so first we will do
we will create one here
like we will insert cell below we will
write a function here so d f
speak now
command
colon then voice equals to
p y t t sx3
dot init
okay
then voice dot say
command
and voice
dot run
and
width
yeah
so what we will do here
we will write like speak
now
then
so his voice is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and init pytx3 engine
has started obtains a pointer to an
instance of an engine that will utilize
the specified driver
if another engine stand is already using
the given driver the other engine stance
is written if not a new engine is built
speak now is a function in which using
get function I am getting the values of
the text this one I will get
now let's run this sort of code and
let's see if it is working or not so I
will run
hello how are you all
Peak now is not different okay
speak now okay and is small
okay my bad ranges again
hello how are you all
hello how are you all
I hope you can hear properly so let me
run this again for another demo example
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
subscribe to simple and YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from simplerlearn yeah so I
hope you guys understand Taylor if you
have any question or any queries
regarding any code
or you have any question related to
python just put as in comments our team
will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
okay okay moving forward so at last
let's create a speech recognition system
from which we can open our websites and
all like YouTube like Facebook like
simply learn anything so we will open
open new file for this I will create the
separate one
here I will write speech
to web
websites
okay
speech
to web
so here I will import import speech
underscore
recognition
and
import
pytds X3
then
one major Library import
web browser
okay then I will run it yeah
I hope you already know these two first
two libraries so this is third library
is used for
web browser is the file source code the
web browser modules offers a high level
user interface that enables user to view
web-based content
in most cases executing the open
function from the this module will
result in the desired outcome
so moving forward let me write code for
it
so I will write code first then I will
explain you line wise
so I will write
if
underscore underscore
name
then again to underscore equals to
equals to
underscore main then again underscore
then colon
yeah then you have to give a path like
for your browser you can use Edge you
can use Google Chrome anything Firefox
anything
so here I will give path path equals to
then
C drive I have my path
already
program
files
and
x 86
Microsoft
and Edge
then
okay then
application
then msh
dot e x e
you have to write at the end this
percentage s
don't forget to write this
okay so path is set so let me create Sr
equals to
speech
recognition
Dot recognizer
same as previous one
and I will write with
speech underscore
recognition
Dot microphone
as source
and Sr dot adjust
or
ambient
noise
then source
now everything seems good
let me write print
but we have wrote there like speak
now please so here I will write
please
say something
to open
okay
I'll write audio
equals to
Sr Dot listen
that source
and I will print
like what you said
so it will here hearing
and I will here I try and accept
then try
so here I will write destination
equals to Sr
dot recognize
underscore Google
then audio
print
you asked
to open
right here Plus
destination
okay
so then web
browser
browser dot get
that path
then open
that destination
destination
okay
so here I will write that accept
caption
exception as
you can write e
then print
if there will be error
error
stria
e
okay
so I recognize the machine ability to
listen to spoken words and identify them
you can use speech recognition in Python
to convert the spoken word into text you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words every time the
recognized speech from mic function is
invoked the recognizer is calibrated for
changing noise condition using the
adjust ambient noise method
a socket is all ready to receive
connection after calling the listen
function prior to performing the accept
method on the server socket the listen
method should be called the backlog
parameter of the listen function allow a
queue size to be specified it will
listen to what we are speaking or saying
the recognize Google function on the
recognizer class which you have now
developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and will convert
spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
okay
so okay so let's try this it's working
or not
let me run this
okay invalid syntax perhaps you forgot a
comma
okay let me see
that print
error
Inc it should be yeah
okay let me check this
let me run this again
valid syntax perhaps you forgot a comma
okay
try to run this again
two
okay let me remove this
I guess it will work fine
still
did input okay okay no issues
so here I will write
again
accept
exception
e
and
errors
TR okay I forgot to write plus okay okay
e
yeah now it will work fine
www.youtube.com
so here you can see YouTube is open
yeah
so we will try this one more time
www.facebook.com
so here you can see Facebook is open
www.facebook.com
one more last time
www.simplyland.com
you can check our amazing courses on
different different Technologies here on
simply learn website simplylearn.com
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any query any question of
regarding any code so just put us in
comments our team will shortly provide
you with the correct solution
okay I'm repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
questions or any queries regarding any
code or related to any python question
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you with the correct
solution I hope you guys must understand
how to create your own speech
recognition system using python if you
have any queries you can ask in the
comment section below our team will
shortly respond you as soon as possible
and if you want this full code if you
want this full code
so just command for the same thank you
so much for being here if you enjoyed
this video please do subscribe to our
YouTube channel and give a like to this
video today we will take you through the
Hands-On lab demo of how you can do the
sentimental analysis of Amazon customer
reviews before we start I hope this
screen is clearly visible and the audio
is fine if yes please type in yes if
there are any issues do let us know in
the chat section so that we can resolve
them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
if you are a tech geek on a continuous
hunt for the latest technological trends
then consider subscribing to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
great I think we can get started so in
today's session we will go through the
what is sentimental analysis after that
we will see types of sentimental
analysis we will see some application of
sentiment analysis and at the end we
will see Hands-On lab demo like how to
implement sentiment analysis using
python in detail we already have Amazon
Customer data set with us we will
perform different function and analyze
data for sentiment analysis using python
you can download data set from the
description box below so before we move
on the programming part let's discuss
what is sentiment analysis actually is
and proceed further for the same
intimate analysis sometimes known as
opinion mining is a technique used in
natural language processing NLP to
determine the emotional undertone of a
document this is a common method used by
organization to identify and group ideas
regarding a certain good service or
concept
text is mined for sentiment and
subjective information using data mining
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
tools for sentiment analysis assist
businesses in extracting information
from unstructured unorganized language
found in online sources like emails blog
posts support tickets web chats forums
and comments algorithm use rule-based
automatic or hybrid technology to
replace manual data processing while
automatic system use machine learning to
learn from their data rule-based system
execute sentiment analysis using
predetermined
lexicon-based rules combining the two
method result in hybrid sentiment
analysis
sentiment analysis or opinion mining can
extract the subject opinion holder and
polarity or the degree of positivity and
negative
from the text and identify sentiment
additionally other Scopes including
document paragraph sentence and sub
sentence level can be used for sentiment
analysis after seeing what is sentiment
analysis let's discuss some types of
sentiment analysis so the first one is
fine grain sentiment analysis by
segmenting sentiment each phrase or
clause in a sentence is broken down and
examined in relationship to the others
simply said you can tell who review a
product and what topics a person is
specifically discuss in their feedback
and the second one is emotion detection
instead of identifying positivity and
negativity emotion detection recognized
particular emotions example could
include shock rage grief frustration and
happiness and the third one is intent
based analysis in addition to identify
opinions in a text the intent based
analysis also identifies behaviors
for instance a frustrated online comment
about changing a battery can motivate
customer care to get in touch to address
that particular problem
and the last one is expect based
analysis collects the precise component
that is being mentioned either favorably
or unfavorably
for instance a client May write in a
product review that the battery life is
too short the system will then respond
that the battery life is the main
complaint and not the product as a whole
so after seeing types of sentiment
analysis let's see some application of
sentiment analysis
organization can employ sentiment
analysis Technologies for a number of
purpose such as
determining brand popularity reputation
and awareness at a particular period or
overtime
customer service requests into
categories and the next one is
monitoring consumer response to new
improvements or products and the fourth
one is identifying the demographics or
Target Market
and the fifth one is determining the
effectiveness of a marketing effort
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answers in
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong so
the question is is text analytics also
refers to as text mining
I'm repeating again is text analytics
also refers to as text mining the
options are true
or false
so let us know your answer in comment
section below or in chat section
so I am starting timer of one minute
just type your answer in comment section
or in chat section
do let me know your answers so I'm
starting timer of one minute
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this to make this live session exciting
so the question is is stacked Analytics
also refers to as text mining
35 seconds are left
do let me know your answers I kindly ask
that everyone take part in this to make
the live session exciting
two one
20 seconds left
you can comment or you can give your
answer in chat section so I can see if
the answer is given by you are right or
wrong
so time up guys
so after the allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the correct response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
okay now let's move to our programming
part to perform sentiment analysis using
Amazon Customer data set
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
okay it's Jupiter notebook
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you can select
new python file
it's loading
so this is how the Jupiter UI looks like
so at first we will import some bunch of
major libraries of python which will
help us in mathematical functioning so
the first one is numpy so first I will
write numpy import numpy
that's NP
and Pi is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has
functions for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely
numpy stands for numerical python
so the next one is pandas
so I will write here
import
pandas
as PD
so pandas is a software Library written
for a Python programming language for
data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structures and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
after that we will import
nltk
so the natural language toolkit nltk is
a Python Programming environment for
creating application for statical
natural language processing NLP for
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning it includes text
processing libraries
so after that
we will import from nltk
Dot sentiment
dot Vader
import
sentiment
HD
analyzer
okay there is no column
yeah
so the Lexicon and rule-based sentiment
analysis tool Vader weather means
valence aware dictionary and essential
reasoning
is a customized precisely two sentiments
expressed on social media
Vader makes use of variety of a
sentiment lexicon is a collection of
lexical elements such as words
that are often classified as either
positive or negative depending on their
semantic orientation
Vader not only informs us of the
positivity and negativity scores but
also of the sentimentally of each score
so the next one is import
re
python re module fully supports regular
expression similar to the those in Perl
if a regular expression compilation or
use error occurs the re modules raises
the expression re
two key functions that are used to
manage regular expression will be
covered so re means regular expressions
so the next one is
from
X blob
import
blob
okay
so a python two or three package called
text blob is used to process textual
data it offers a straightforward API to
explore typical natural language
processing NLP
tasks like part of speech tagging noun
phrase extraction sentiment analysis
classification translation and more
so the next one is
import
words
from
word
cloud
avoid Cloud commonly refers to as a tag
cloud is an image of words popular words
and phrases are highlighted using Cloud
creators depending on their frequency
and importance
they give you immediate straightforward
visual insights that can Inspire more
through analysis
and the next one is import
C bone
as
SNS
yeah
so like an open source python Library
based on matplotlib is called C bone it
is utilized for data exploration and
data visualization where data frames and
the pandas Library c-bond function with
ease
so the next one is import
matplotlib
Dot
Pi plot
as PLT
okay yeah seems good
for Python and its numerical expression
numpy matplotlib is a cross platform
data visualization and graphical
charting package as a result it presents
a strong open source substitute for
Matlab the API is for matplotlib allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI applications
and the next one is
import
links
c u f f l i n k s as
CF
perfect
another python module called cufflink
links plotly with pandas so that charts
can be easily created on data frames in
essence it function like a plugin
so next inline
at lordlip
add plot clip
so you can enable inline plotting by
using the magic function percentage math
problem inline which causes the plots
and graphs to appear below
the cell where you plotting commands are
entered similar to a Jupiter notebook it
offers back-end interactivity in front
ends so next we will import
what you can like we can import okay
from
Earthly dot offline
import
init underscore notebook
underscore mode
comma
a plot
okay
in it underscore notebook
notebook
mode
who gets through yeah
EF dot go
underscore offline
so
yeah in order to display the plot inside
the notebook you need to initiate
broadly notebook mode as follows like
this
keep rest of the script as it is like it
and run the notebook cell by pressing
you can shift to a center graph will be
displayed offline inside the notebook so
basically it is used for the offline
graphing you can see okay so next we
will import
um plotly
dot subplots subplots are important
import
make underscore
subplot
hey yeah
the non-leaf nodes in this figure schema
are represented by a hierarchy of python
classes that was automatically
constructed and is found in the plotly
dot graph objects
which is normally imported as go
these class instance are refers to as
graph object the plotly defined
fundamental classes
okay
so here we will import some like
warnings you can say
like to get not error
so we will import let me give a line
space
import
warning
earnings yeah
warnings
dot filter
warning
ignore
warnings dot one
and
this uh like will not show
and let me add something PD
dot set
option
display Dot Max underscore
plums
okay import import words from word cloud
okay there is an error let me check
what's the error
okay import
this
is what cloud
from word cloud
capital
and W is also capital
here will be capital
that's it what is small only
from word cloud
okay my bad here one from word cloud
from word cloud
import word cloud
okay
yeah seems good
so wherever we
yeah or in warnings despite the
notification the software continues to
execute to display warning messages
utilize the one
found in the warning module the python
built-in class inspection is a subclass
of the warning module which is used to
display warning messages import warnings
okay for seeing full data every single
columns like
okay there is error c bond
no module has c bond so
s will be small
got it okay inline
this only live
something like that in line
okay any errors now
I guess no error
okay
yeah for seeing full data like every
single Columns of PD so here we are
using this PD dot set option
so we can use for it
so moving forward let's import data set
so for importing data set we will write
here
uh
like DF equals to
PD Dot
read
CSV
okay
add data set name
so
you can download data set from the
description box below so no worries of
for that
let me run this
okay
so like here is PD is for pandas Library
read is used for reading the data set
from the machine and CSV is used for the
type of file which you want to read
so let's see our data
so here I will write DF Dot hat
yeah
so
if you want to like if you want to see
top five rows of your data set you can
use head and if you want to uh like see
five rows of your data set you can use
tail insert instead of head this one
okay so this is our data set with only
five rows
if you want to see full data set you can
like from starting from 0 and ending it
four nine one four rows okay
four nine one one five rows and 12
columns
it
so let me give something like this for
the pattern visual
yeah
okay so moving ahead let's sort this
Wilson bound column to ascending order
for better analysis so I am talking
about this Wilson lower bound column
this one for it's not zero zero zero
like you know all the rows
so let me show you
so here you have to write like DF equals
to DF dot sort
values
Wilson
spelling should be correct
lower
bound
make it to ascending order
ascending
sorry descending order so
BF dot drop
named
unnamed
colon 0
okay
in place
in base equals to true
comma axis
equals to one
okay so let's see our data
so here you can see the data is sorted
in s
in as ascending order okay
so the provided row or column is
eliminated via the drop function the
draft method eliminates the specified
column when the column axis is specified
the drop method eliminates the
designated row when the row axis is
supplied
okay so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any queries or like any
queries regarding any code or there is
something questionable here just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
okay
so moving forward let's make a function
for missing values
so
okay
so I will write here like DF
missing
values
analysis
okay it's def or function we use def
columns
was true
n d f Dot
columns
if
DF
column
is null
dot sum
greater than zero
underscore Miss
you
DF
underscore columns
let's go
is null
dot sum
but with DOT sort values
sort underscore values
like in ascending
ascending
ascending equals to
true
okay
like some
maybe like this and this
that's fine I guess
yeah so here I will write ratio
underscore equals to
DF n a underscore columns
underscore
Dot
is null
same thing
that sum
foreign
hundred
or sort
values
ending
was true true
fine
okay okay
that means okay and the TF part
that sort value is because you're
standing because you're true fine
so
here we will write missing
underscore DF equals to PD
Dot concat
B dot round
issue
underscore comma
two
perfect
well access will be 1.
okay
is
equals to
that will give like
total where I will write message missing
values
okay
comma ratio
underscore DF equals to PD
dot data frame
score DF
okay so let me return
DF
let me create one more function for like
check data frame so DF
that underscore data frame
okay
it equals to five
comma tail
equals to
5.
so here I will write print
okay
yeah
Dot Center
comma
again for row Sprint
close
belly braces
okay
dot format
what format
yeah
dot shape
you know
so for column Sprint
or shape
paint
and types like of types of data
Dot
Center
same as like that 82
comma
and
DF dot d types
Center
just printing this is like you will see
don't worry
just stay with me you will see the
beautiful result
okay print
values
Trend missing values uh analysis and
cases like DF
okay
then again
you did
values
like there's many how many duplicate
values are there
so dot same for the center
gee
one more
again this one
end
you have Dot duplicated
don't worry I will explain you like line
by line
just stay with me let me write the whole
code
first print
tiles
like I am printing multiple of things
so just be with me
Dot
82
comma
F Dot
one tile
zero five
comma
one
okay
check
data frame
I'm hoping like there will be no error
yeah
so you can see now like multiple
information regarding data set is
printed
so this shape is for like how many rows
and columns present in the data set like
in types you can say like every column
type like object
N64 float 64 and many more are like
present so like you can see review text
is like object and their differences N64
and Wilson lower bound is float 64.
okay so total missing values
so total missing values are like uh
1 from here and one from here like one
in from reviewer name and other is from
reviewer text
and like there is no duplicated values
in our data set
and here you can see so like after that
quantize a quantile defines a particular
part of the data set that is a quantile
determines how many values in the
distribution are above or below a
certain limit
special quantiles are the like quartile
quarter and you can say quintile that
the fifth one and the percentile which
is from 100th okay so quantile is for
like quarter
or the you can say the fifth one
so why I wrote this 83 82 and this for
this purpose
for making this something look cool
that is why
okay and
so moving forward
let's see unique values and in each
column
okay so I will add
check
Plus
frame
unique
f equals to PD
Dot data
a frame
variable
variable
the frame
columns comma
classes
colon
data frame
I
will write like an unique
unique
UE
or
I in
data frame
Dot
columns
okay like and unique
you
or DF equals to
dot sort
values
classes
comma ascending
equals to
false
okay
and unique
underscore DF equals to n
unique
F dot reset
index
drop a question
true
return
and unique
q-u-e and unique
let's go PF
check underscore class
which one DF
so let me run this first
yeah it's running you can see here
okay there is an error classes
okay
check class DF
is saying that
this is
kses Capital C Small
let me run now yeah
so here you can see the every column
having unique values are sorted in
descending order like review tags have
like more unique values so it come first
and then review your name reviewer time
day difference Wilson lower bound score
average then goes to overall
okay moving forward let's do some
categorical variable analysis for
overall yes so this will be like amazing
something amazing is going to be
happened
so
constraints equals to so I am giving
here like some
color values so
B 3 4
d
2 2.
e b 0 0 C
okay
so you can change you can like write
whatever you want color
s
stack
right hashtag here
hashtag
three come on
it's done
0 C
9 to e b
yeah
EB 0
3
and then d
you like five right
okay so d f let's make function Okay
small d f
categorical
variable
okay
DF comma
column
categorical variable summary yeah
perfect
so let's make some figures so make
subplots
plots
rows
equals to
1
comma calls
equals to 2.
let me write from here like subplot
ALS
equals to
count plot
like one for percentage
percentage
okay
so specs speech
equals to
okay like
type
colon
colon
that's why
okay
same type
colon here
domain
figure dot at
and then Trace
Dot
bar
like one bar and one that pie chart okay
why
equals to DF
columns
column name
values Dot
to list
4X you can click string
yeah Str
I
or I
in
yeah
column
name
dot value
Dot counts
index
text
equals to DF
column name
dot value
counts and then bracket
dot values
dot to list
okay
so for text
font
the size should be
14 is enough I guess
is to column
UNESCO name
X position
so I'm doing for like making chart so
stay with me to see that amazing chart
okay
so show Legend
s to take
colors
these two constraints
so these are the like colors so I'm
giving here value like very variable
name
because
constraints
comma line
equals to
let
hashtag
DB
e
6 AC
one
Okay small
okay let me just like go over through
everything is correct or not for the
column name
will accounts index yeah it's fine
text equals to TF column name
dot value
counts
dot values
to to list okay
text font equals to take size then okay
14 size is enough
name equals to column name and text
position equals to auto
and show Legend false and Mark
detect like color equals to constant
okay fine line equals to color
and this yeah this okay
cool
o equals to one
comma column request
one
that seems good
like for pie chart we will make figure
dot add
so this is done for the light line chart
not line chart that bar chart and this
I'm doing for the pie chart okay
Trace
go Dot
pi
f
columns
column name
value
is
equals to DF
again that column name
or tell you
count
counts
and Dot values
text font
because you take
yeah size
I will prefer 18 is enough
position
like Auto is fine
so Legend
let's do no need of Legend false
m equals to column name
and your column name
then colors
equals to constants
will go to one
column equals to like in second
okay you will see and you will get to
know don't worry
so if we got dot update
layout
equals to
column
0.9
and 5
come on
X
all right
should be on centered
and Y anchor
we are on top
red equals to
tally
okay
I plot
figure
let me run this okay like
call equals to 2
now let's see the chart of like column
overall one so we will write here
categorical
okay
variable
variable
summary
and then data frame name DF
comma overall
okay let's run this
okay it's loading here
it's loading
yeah
you can see this is this is our bar plot
and this is our pie chart
so
like this is overall
uh from overall you can say that column
so like percentage bar and that bar plot
so this is how our like pie chart and
bar chart looks like I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
questions or any query regarding any
code
okay like any code any sort of code
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you at the correct
solution
so moving forward our goal is to rank
the com comments by the sentiment
analysis so we don't get hung up on the
other details I have sorted this data
set according to certain rules before
so moving forward we want to clean our
data so let's see the sample data for
cleaning
so DF Dot
review
text
okay dot
hat
let me run this so
so this is how sample data looks like so
let's see like data full data for this
okay let me see for
for this I guess okay
or like any particular row you can say I
can take okay
so I will write review
underscore example
example
equals to DF
Dot
review
text I will take a random two zero three
one I guess
Okay so
review
underscore example
so this is like at two zero three one
there is one review text
okay so in that the whole data is here
like like so my lovely wife bought me a
Samsung Galaxy Tab for father this is
this this like to find the exact model
number this is a long you know command
I got the this this is it works like a
charm okay
so
after seeing this data what we're gonna
do is like we will clean it from
punctuation and numbers using regex
regex what regular expression okay so
here I will write
review underscore example
okay
oh
equals to re dot sub
and what I will do is
okay I will explain
don't worry
small rate
to capital a
to Z
okay
comma then space
comma G view underscore example
exam
but
sorry
yeah
review
so here we used re for regular
expression
okay and
so all the punctuation and numbers are
removed from particular data
so let me check first
okay this A to Z then A to Z okay fine
so like all the punctuation and numbers
are removed from particular data I will
now convert the texture to all lowercase
our machine learning algorithm
recognized words that start with the
capital letters as a different word and
we will convert them to lowercase so
thus our machine learning algorithm will
not perceive words that start with the
capital letter as a different word so
what I will do is
here I will write review
scramble
sample
equals to G View
again example
dot lower
I will split
split
okay
yeah example
so here you can see we have converted
all the words in the lowercase letter by
using lower function and why they are
coming in new lines because we are
splitting them using split function okay
if you see only did lower case for
single row like we did for the like two
zero I guess two zero three one okay
yeah so let's make all rows same in
lowercase so I will write here RT
equals to Lambda
X
Google
Str
X
so DF
U
text
is capital text
DF
View
text
text
okay equals to DF
View
just
yeah dot lower
we have done
add
see all the data is in like lowercase
so I printed just top 10 rows and in
like in reviews text column all the are
in the lower case now so I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or any query regarding any code
or question till here like any code just
put as in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution and if
you need this full code you can comment
down below okay
so now the time has come to do sentiment
analysis because all the data is sorted
so what
will I write here
let me do it little bit up
yeah
so I will write
from
yeah
from Vader
sentiment
dot Vader
and pigment
report
sentiment
intensity
analyzer
if
polarity
subjectivity
is subjectivity
let's do DF
View
text
dot apply
the
next PD
dot series
a little text
blob
then again text
Dot
like sentiment
let me run for Loop for index
comma row
in DF
G View
text
but either
items
for you
intimate
density
analyzer
or polarity
scores
row
it if score
or neutral I will write score
if for positive
if
this is something crazy if negative is
greater than positive
then DF dot location
index
comma
demand
equals to
negative
negative
yes Dan
lcf
positive is greater than negative
then in this case
DF Dot
log
index
comma
sentiment
first two
positive
P capital
else
e f dot LSC
X
intimate
let's do
neutral
yeah
so like this is for sentiment analysis
and text block
this thing like text blob this blob okay
it's blob
a text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity polarity indicates your
mood that is whether it is positive
or negative or neutral it returns a
value between 0 and 1 the closer to 1
the more positive and the closer to zero
is more negative
okay let me run this it will take
a little bit time
because this sentiment okay it is
getting error
like model Panda has no attribute series
okay which one
explosion
next sentiment
okay here what is the thing as his
capital
let me run now
it is executing
like fade for a while wait
so it will take time to run because like
because of this sentiment intensity
analyzer
it take times
again sentiment intensity
analyzer okay spelling mistake again
y index index is not defined
sorry again
index
it will run I guess because everything
seems good
negative positive and this else
loading so I have to wait like for like
two minutes more I guess
still loading guys
I take time
sentiment intensity analyzer
so let me tell you again sentiment
analysis like this text blob
text blob will return polarity and
subjectivity
so polarity indicates your mood that is
whether it is positive it is negative or
it is it will be neutral it returns a
value between 0 and 1. the closer to one
the more
positive the closer to zero more
negative okay
I guess it's still
running
[Music]
so
it will take time so let me write code
for that 20 interpretation I repeat
moving forward let's identify the 20
interpretation now we can include the
positive negative and neutral status of
the command
okay
then DF
DF
sentiment
what's equals to
positive
ought
lose
lower
ending
equals to
false
yeah
dot head
it's five
if I will run it may
evare us to me because it's still
running
still running here it's still loading
so let let me write code for that
unbalanced data problem so like we will
category that data into positive
negative and neutral
Okay so
categorical
variable
summary
DF
event
yeah
it came like this because of this
wait I will tell you
yeah so here you can see the pie chart
distributed in negative positive and
neutral emotions
okay or you can say ratings and here you
can see the bar chart also
so
and
you can see the percentage distributed
in each like in positive negative and
neutral one so I hope you guys must
understood the concept of sentiment
analysis how we can implement it using
python if you have any queries you can
ask in the comment section below our
team will respond you as soon as
possible if you want this full code
just comment for the same thank you so
much for being here if you enjoyed this
live session please do subscribe to our
YouTube channel and give a like to this
video thank you and keep learning
hi everyone I'm ambition and welcome to
the simple and YouTube channel
in this section we will create an OTP
verification GUI using python but before
we begin if you love watching Tech
videos subscribe to our Channel like the
tutorial and hit the Bell icon to now
miss an update
and before we start I hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes and if there is
any issue do let us know in the chat
section
and let us have a simple question to
brush upon our knowledge
and please answer in the comment section
below and we will update the correct
answer in the print comment and your
question is
how is a code block indicated in Python
and your options are brackets
indentation
key
or none of these
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section moving on
first you will see WhatsApp project and
how it looks like
so
we will save it and run the program
foreign
and this is our project and this is what
we're gonna make in this video so using
twilio I have received the OTP on my
mobile phone
and that is 4601
and if I submit it
I can see the show info window that says
that the verification is successful
and we have one more window for you guys
if you want
you can also make it uh we will also
discuss this in this video
so you can see this is the first window
we will create and after we click on the
generate OTP button
it will redirect to the second window
that is verify OTP and there you could
just type in the OTP you get on your
mobile phone and the OTP I got is 6709
and I will just click on the submit
button it will show that the
verification is successful
there's a decent OTP button and there's
a timer as the twilio tokens they are
default available for 10 minutes only so
I have set up a timer for 10 minutes if
you want you can also make the timer as
you could just go with the verify OTP
GUI and the resend button it will just
make that video send the OTP again to a
mobile phone so if there is any
difficulty in reaching the RDP to us so
moving on now
we will start with our project
that is first we will create a folder
and name it as OTP verification
and inside
we will open the command prompt
and now we'll open the editor I would be
using the visual studio code you could
choose any editor as you like or you
have the hands on any editor
for that I will write the command code
space period and press enter
so here we will
create the name of the file as program 2
Dot py
and now we should install and import the
modules uh for tick and term we don't
have to install it like click enter is a
python module that is used to develop
GUI that is graphical user interface
there's no need to install any module as
decanter module is a part of the
standard python Library
and here we need to install twilio
so for that
we'll open the command prompt and write
the command
okay install
value and press enter
as it states that the requirement is
already satisfied I have already
installed the twilio module and used it
in the project so you just have to write
the command and press enter in the
command prompt or in the terminal of
your editor
and the rest would be done for you
so moving on
we will
import the modules
so from click enter
we will
import all the classes and files
and from the video
we will import the client class
and to generate the OTP we will use the
random module and generate the
OTP with the random function
random
and we would also be using the message
box but here we will see it later on
so now we'll create a class
in the taken term
so in order to initialize the class we
use the underscore underscore init
function this creates a method that
prints itself when we form an object
from the class
so we will make a class
and name it as OTP wire verifier
OTP underscore verified
and inside you will pass TK
colon
and as I said we will
make the
init
and pass self in it
so we will create a root window and
display it on the screen for that we
will just run window dot main Loop to
pop out The Tick into window
and for that
and the slow we will just
write
to a super
yeah
foreign
provides many methods and one of them is
the geometry method this method is used
to set the dimensions of vetting enter
window and is used to set the positions
of the main window on the user's
textbook
so for that we will use the geometry
function
and write the command self
documentary
and inside the cutting places for
recycle bases
we'll set the y-axis
as 1000 course x axis with 580
and
mute
to make it shift with 200 dimensions
then y-axis
80 dimensions and the x-axis
now we will configure the window so we
will use the config function so config
and configure function they both are
same and they can be used on any widget
to change settings that you may have
applied earlier or haven't applied yet
so for that we'll write the command
self.configure
and inside we will set the background
color as white only for the tender
window
and use the hexa code for the colors you
could use for example on just bright
white
so for right we
have
six apps you can search for the port
back support
or you could just write the white color
now we will use the resizable function
so this method is used to allow decline
term root window to change its size
according to the user's need as well as
we can probably that is sizing of the
decender window so basically if you want
to create a fixed size window this
method can be used in resizable method
user can pass either positive integer or
true to make the window resizable
but if you want to prohibit the resizing
of the window you could just pass false
or zero
so we would just provate it
we will write the command
self Dot peace size table
so we have provided our window
and now
before executing code python interpreter
read source file and Define few special
variables or Global variables if the
python interpreter is running the source
file as the main program it sets the
special variable that would be the
underscore underscore
name variable
as value equal to Main
that value
would be equal to underscore underscore
main if this file is being imported from
another module so the name variable will
be set to the module's name module's
name is available as value to name
variable that is the global variable
so to execute it
we will write the command
if
name equal to Main and that
pin line but it commas
here first we will
clause
window equal to
vertically underscore
verifier
and now
we'll write a command to run the main
group
that is the main thing to get a window
popped up so we'll save the file
and run it
we go to Arrow here
so
it is due to the spaces
don't
have to Make spaces in the geometry
method
and now we'll save it and run it you can
see that the click enter window has
popped up
now
we will make its GUI and before that
we will see that video so this is the
twilio console you have to login into
that and that would be your account Sid
the token and the phone number from
which you will get the OTP
so I will show you the demo for that
you can just visit the value
website
so 12 is an American company that is
based in the San Francisco
which provides programmable
communication tools for making and
receiving phone calls sending any Sim
text messages and Performing other
communication functions using it web
service apis
so this is the website here you can just
go
sign up
as I have the account already I will
just log in in it you will just write
the first name last name email and
password that should be 16 plus
characters and after that you will
accept it and start a free trial it
doesn't need any credit card or
something you can just use it without
any payment mode
and after that it will ask you to get
your phone number assigned or it will
ask first it will ask you like what
purpose are you serving the 12 year
so you could just make it that you want
to run it for your project or any code
purpose and after that you have to
generate the phone number from which you
will get the SMS
so I have my console already I have
logged in
so I'm going to the chord part
now we'll use twilio
to get our DB
on our mobile phones
so
for that we will write the command
in the class only that is
otbi file
we will use the current function for
that we will create a variable
self.client
and that is equal to
and use the client function
and inside will pass two parameters
that would be from the console
that would be the account Sid we will
copy that
and
will paste it in the inverted commas
and the next parameter will pass
the authorized token that would be
unique for you
paste this
and
that could also bend the inverted commas
only
and next
we'll write the command serve.client dot
messages
that is we'll use the variable
above there goes the client variable
and we'll create the messages
and here we will write our phone number
that here two and equal to
and inside
the brackets we will write the contact
number
you want to receive the message
so here I am writing my contact number
and
not highlighted
as it
as I can get the Spam messages or spam
calls so I would not highlight it
and
we will
write the contact number that we have
got from the twilio
that contact number is material your
phone number we will copy that
and right wrong
so from underscore
the paste that with your phone number
comma and then the body what body we
want to receive as a text message from
this number so the body we want to
receive and OTP
so for that we will use the random
module and generate an OTP
so first we will create a variable
store it in a variable n
and hold that we should use the random
module to generate the OTP for that we
will just
make a function and name it as OTP only
and inside you will pass
self
and this function we will return
foreign
range function
and pass the range
so this function will choose any number
from this range and return to us
so we will ask this function to generate
a phone number OTP
so
we have
made the function
for the OTP and now we'll assign it
to the variable we have declared above
so in this variable
we will click on that the OTP should be
passed as a string
because body would take as number as a
string only
true so that will write the command
Str
yourself dot OTP
in the body will get the variable
and only
for that we'll write the command self.n
now
we will
save it
and run it
example
if there's an issue here
element
would successfully executed so sometimes
it takes time and a little bit during
okay
and now we'll start with the GI GUI and
for that
will create a function so that we can
store all the widgets there
and we will name the function as labels
and first thing we will create would be
the canvas Widget the Cano switch it
lets us display various graphics on the
application it can be used to draw
simple shapes to complicated graphs we
can also display various kinds of custom
widgets according to our needs so first
we will
create a variable
and name it as C
and inside
we will make the canvas widget
then now set its background color
and that
I will use the hexa code only if you
could just
see
that's the gray color
you could use
the example or you can just write the
name of the column
or if you want you can just search on
the web you would get the hexa boards
and you would get the variations of all
the colors in hexa board and I will set
the width for the canvas and width would
be equal to 400 as you can see that it
is in the comments
we have to put the hex support in the
inverted commas
yeah
so we have set the weight and now we
will set the height
that is
280
and now
we will place this canvas for that we
will use the Place function and the
place function allows you explicitly set
the position and size of a window either
in absolute terms or relative to another
window